THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER ONE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. TODAY WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING VARIOUS HEALTH
RELATED PROPOSALS INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
SPECIFICALLY THIS HEARINGS FCUS
IS ON ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
INSTRUCTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING
TO HELP INSURE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYONE HERE TODAY WHILE
ALLOWING FULL PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION. FOR THE
PANELISTS TODAY WE ARE HAVING
THE PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING AT THE STATE CAPITOL IN
HEARING ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX. THE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA OR
APPEARING REMOTELY USING ONLINE
TECHNOLOGY. WE ARE ACCEPTING
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING BOTH IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS TOLL FREE.
1-877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SIX. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
PERSON MAY DO SO BUT MUST WEAR A
MASK AT ALL TIMES AND FOLLOW ALL
POSTED GUIDANCE. WE WILL BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS
HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS
FOR THE PANEL THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES IN TODAY'S HEARING. AND
FINALLY WE ALSO ACCEPT WRITTEN
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK
THROUGH THE SUB ONE EMAIL
ACCOUNT AND THE ADDRESS IS
BUDGET SOMEONE. OUT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. BEFORE WE INVITE OUR
FIRST PANEL TO BEGAN I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW INTRODUCTORY REMARKS.
AND THEN SEE IF ANY OTHER
COLLEAGUES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN. BUT. REALLY WANTED TO
BEGIN A FIGHT COULD- WITH
SOMETHING THAT I HEARD THIS PAST
SUNDAY AT CHURCH FROM MY PASTOR
THAT WE AS A PEOPLE ARE CAPABLE
OF GREATNESS AND I'D LIKE TO
HUMBLY OFFERED THAT THE MOVEMENT
OF HEALTH FOR ALL IS AN EXAMPLE
OF JUST THAT AN EXAMPLE WHEN YOU
LISTEN TO PEOPLE AND AMPLIFY
THEIR VOICES THAT WHEN YOU WORK
WITH ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS SUCH
AS CIBC HEALTH ACCESS AND THE
LOTUS WORK THE FOUNDATION THAT
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE
CHANGE THAT WE WANT TO SEE IN
THIS WORLD. I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
BECAUSE FOR MANY OF US WE FEEL
AS IF OUR PRAYERS HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED. THE VERY REASON THAT I
RAN FOR OFFICE AND LEFT MY
CAREER IN EMERGENCY MEDICINE
CAME HERE TO SACRAMENTO WAS TO
WORK TOWARDS UNIVERSAL HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
. SO WELL MANY OF US WISH THAT
HEALTH FOR ALL WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED YESTERDAY WE AND WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR TOMORROW IT IS
TODAY THAT WE MUST FOCUS ON THE
HARD WORK OF IMPLEMENTATION AND
ROLLING AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WILL COME
TODAY WITH THAT LET'S BEGIN.
LET'S BEGIN WITH A PANEL ONE ON
THE PROPOSED MEDICAL EXPANSION
TO INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS TWENTY
SIX TO FORTY NINE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE HAVE
THREE PRESENTERS ON THE PANEL
INCLUDING MICHELLE BOSS DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. J. C. COOPER STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF HEALTH CARE
PROGRAMS FOR DH CS AND LUKE COST
MORROW THAT WOULD BE L. A. ON.
WILL HOLD ALL MEMBERS QUESTIONS
UNTIL AFTER THE PRESENTERS HAVE
INCLUDED CONCLUDED. LET US BEGIN
WITH DIRECTOR BOSS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE REALLY THANK YOU
FOR THOSE OPENING COMMENTS
REALLY RESONATED WITH THAT I
KNOW THE ENTIRE D. H. U. S.
DEMANDED MINISTRATION. OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS
EXPANDED MEDICAID COVERAGE TO
CHILDREN YOUNG ADULTS AND OLDER
ADULTS AGE FIFTY AND OVER
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THE BUDGET BUILT ON
THOSE EXPANSIONS AND INCLUDES
EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETEEN POINT
THREE MILLION SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
TÍNH POINT FIVE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND TWO POINT THREE
BILLION ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. TO EXPAND FULL
SCOPE ELIGIBILITY TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE ADULTS AGE TWENTY SIX
THROUGH FORTY NINE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS BEGINNING NO
SOONER THAN JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR MEDICARE WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS. BY REMOVING A
BEARD TO HELP ACCESS DUE TO
IMMIGRATION STATUS THIS PROPOSAL
PROVIDES COVERAGE TO THE
REMAINING AGE GROUP OF
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS AND
WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIAN ADULTS HAVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE AND AFFORDABLE
CARE. EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE OFTEN LEADS TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES FINANCIAL
SECURITY AND WORKER PRODUCTIVITY
AND ULTIMATELY BETTER LIFE
OUTCOMES. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
IN THE AGENDA IS- IT REGARDING
THE NEED FOR A TWO YEAR DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION WE PROPOSE A
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
START DATE FOR THE EXPANSION A
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL TO
INDIVIDUALS AGE TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE. I TO
ENSURE A SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION THIS EXPANSION
WILL ADD APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED FOURTEEN ADDITIONAL
MEDICARE ENROLLEES AND IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST EXPANSIONS OF
MEDICAID ELIGIBILITY IN RECENT
YEARS. AS SUCH THIS TRANSITION
WILL REQUIRE EXTENSIVE
COORDINATION BETWEEN DH YES
COUNTY PARTNERS MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND STAKEHOLDERS AND THIS
INCLUDES THE DEVELOPMENT OF
POLICY AND GUIDANCE NOTICES FOR
AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS TO INFORM
THEM OF THE EXPANSION. PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO THOSE ENROLLED IN
RESTRICTED SCOPE MEDICAL TODAY
ABOUT THE TRANSITION TO FULL
SCOPE COVERAGE. INSURING THAT
MEDICARE RATES A MANAGED CARE
PLAN NETWORK ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS ARE APPROPRIATELY
ADJUSTED TO REFLECT THE GROWTH
IN ENROLLMENT. OF THESE
ADDITIONAL MEDIC CAL ENROLLEES.
ADDITIONALLY BETWEEN NOW AND
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
MANY SIGNIFICANT POLICY
INVESTMENTS ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED RELATIVE TO MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY INCLUDING. RESUMING
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS DUE
TO THE END OF THE FEDERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. IF A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WERE TO END IN
APRIL REDETERMINATION WOULD NEED
TO BEGIN MAY HAVE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. EXPANSION OF MEDICARE
HEALTH TWO ONE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND OLDER ADULTS AGE FIFTY
AND OLDER REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS EFFECTIVE MAY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
ELIMINATION OF THE MEDICAL ASAT
TEST PHASE ONE WHICH RAISES THE
ASSET LIMIT TWO. HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND AFFECTED JAIL
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO YOU
KNOW. AND THE CONSOLIDATION OF
COUNTY ELIGIBLE ELIGIBILITY
SYSTEMS INTO ONE STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED WELFARE SYSTEM SAWS AS
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. MIGRATION IS SET TO
BEGIN SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND AS A RESULT THE SAUCE
WILL BE IN A STATE A FREEZE
WHERE THEY KEEP IT CANNOT MAKE
THAT PROGRAM CHANGES UNTIL THEY
FULLY MIGRATE TO CAL FONG IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO CANNOT BE PHASED
IN BY AGE GROUPS AS EACH STATE
ESSENTIALLY EQUATES TO THE SAME
LEVEL OF EFFORT BOTH FROM A
POLICY AND SYSTEM PERSPECTIVE OF
THE FULL PROPOSAL. THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES NECESSITATES
THE PROPOSED STARTDATE OF
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM JC COOPER. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE L. L. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRITISH MORROW THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE'RE TALKING NOTING THAT BASED
ON THE MINISTRATIONS ESTIMATE
THE PROPOSAL WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED
CALIFORNIANS. BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ESTIMATE FOR
THIS EXPANSION ALONG WITH THE
OLDER ADULTS EXPANSION APPROVED
LAST YEAR WHEN WE ROUGHLY
ESTIMATE THE UNINSURED
POPULATION IN THE STATE COULD BE
REDUCED BY ABOUT ONE MILLION
PEOPLE WHICH IS ROUGHLY ONE
THIRD OF THE. CURRENT UNINSURED
POPULATION IN THE STATE. WE WANT
TO RAISE A FEW ISSUES FOURTEENTH
. IN REGARDS TO THIS PROPOSED
EXPANSION- BUT WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO EVALUATE THE
MINISTRATIONS AND COMMUNICATE
CERTAIN COSTS AND THAT ANY SUCH
EXPANSION IS SUBJECT TO
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY IN
TERMS OF THESE ESTIMATES. NOW
CAN I CAN NOTE THAT IT DOES IT
DOESN'T INVOLVE AN EXTENDED TIME
BRING RELATIVE TO PAST
EXPANSIONS AND IT HAS AN IMPACT
ON ACCESS TO COVERAGE. A SHORT
IMPLEMENTATION PRIME BRING
SIMILAR TO THAT PAST EXPANSIONS
COULD IMPROVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE SOONER. THE END EXPECT.
EXTENDED TIME FRAME COULD BE
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EIGHT OUT OF FOUR
SKEPTICAL MEDI CAL IF THE TRUMP
RUNNING TWENTY SIX. PRIOR TO
GETTING ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
IN SUCH CASES THESE INDIVIDUALS
WOULD BE SHIFTED TO LIMITED
SCOPE MEDIC HAL WHICH ONLY
COVERS EMERGENCY SERVICE IN
PREGNANCY- AND THEN WE MOVED
BACK TO FULL SCOPE AFTER JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR CAUSING A
LAPSE IN COVERAGE. WELL WE ARE
CONTINUING TO ASSESS THE
POTENTIAL NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
COULD BE IMPACTED BY THIS WE
ESTIMATE THAT TYPICAL YEAR OF
THE NUMBER OF UNDOCKING
RESIDENTS YOU AGE OUT OF
COVERAGE. IS. LIKELY IN THE LOW
TENS OF THOUSANDS. THIS WOULD BE
MUCH HIGHER END UP YOUR- DUE TO
A THE FEDERAL. DON'T PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. COULD BE. FROM
MAKING L. WELL THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IS IN EFFECT EXCEPT IN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES. WE KNOW THAT
THE MINISTRATION HAS STATED THAT
IT WOULD BE WORKLOAD CHALLENGES
WITH AN OLDER IMPLEMENTATION
CONSISTENT CHANGES AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL AND OTHER. TEMPORARY
WORKLOAD DUE TO POLICY CHANGES
THAT HAVE PEACEFUL IMPLICATIONS
WE DEFINITELY RECOGNIZING THESE
WATER CHALLENGES ARE REAL BUT
THEY CAN INCREMENTAL APPROACH
COULD EXPAND COVERAGE FASTER
WITH MORE MANAGEABLE WORKLOAD
IN. FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE STEPS TO PREVENT LOTS
OF BOTH GOOD COVERAGE OF PEOPLE
WHO AGEOUT OF COVERAGE PRIOR TO
JANUARY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
WE ARE HAPPY TO DISCUSS. HOW DO
YOU LARGEST COULD BE STRUCK THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION- AND
WILL BE RELEASED A PUBLICATION
THAT COTTON WEEKS WITH A MORE IN
DEPTH AND HOUSE THIS PROPOSAL. I
WILL FOR THE TIME BEING WE
RECOMMEND THAT TO THE EXTENT
LAWCENTER IS INTERESTED IN
ADOPTING. AN EXECUTIVE TIMELINE
FOR ALL OR PART OF THE
POPULATION IMPACTED BY THIS
PROPOSAL AT THE REQUEST
MINISTRATION FIND INFORMATION ON
THE FEASIBILITY OF DOING SO. AS
WELL AS POTENTIAL ALTERNATIVES
WHICH COULD BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY INCLUDE OPTIONS
RAISED- IN. THIS TESTING ON IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHAT THAT I
WILL BRING BACK UP TO THE DÍAS
TO SEE IF. MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS. C. NON I WILL KEEP IT
WITH THE CHAIR- FIRST DIRECTOR
I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
FILLIOS COMMENTS REGARDING-
THOSE WHO CURRENTLY ARE AGING
OUT. AFTER THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX
AND- WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
WORK WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN. NOT TO
HAVE THEM HAVE COVERAGE. HAVE TO
KICK THEM OFF AND THEN RE ENROLL
THEM IN A FEW YEARS FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN KEEP THAT CONTINUITY
AND- WOULD APPRECIATE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT IF YOU'RE AMENABLE TO THAT
. YES I'D BE HAPPY TO ENGAGE WE
WOULD ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT
WE ENGAGE OUR COUNTY PARTNERS
BECAUSE THIS WOULD LIKELY
INVOLVE MANUAL OVERRIDES IN IT
YOU KNOW IMPACT SOME OF THE
COUNTY PROCESSING AND AS WELL
SO. HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
CONVERSATIONS AND WORK TOWARDS
THIS BUT RECOGNIZING THAT THIS-
THIS TYPE OF LOGIC IS PROBABLY
MORE OF A MANUAL OVERRIDE. I'M
WOULD LIKE TO FOLLOW UP WITH ONE
SPECIFIC QUESTION ABOUT THE TBL-
WITHIN YOUR PROPOSAL IT STATES
THAT THIS WILL ONLY OCCUR AFTER
THE DIRECTOR DETERMINES. THAT
THE SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN PROGRAMMED
FOR IMPLEMENTATION. I WAS HOPING
YOU COULD ELABORATE ON WHAT THIS
MEANS SPECIFICALLY AND- WHETHER
OR NOT. THAT'S REFERRING TO THE
I. T. SYSTEM UPGRADES YOU WERE-MENTIONING EARLIER AND HOPING
YOU COULD PROVIDE SOME CLARITY.
I THINK WE GENERALLY INCLUDE
THAT IS A STANDARD JUST WRITING
THIS IN THAT THAT THE SYSTEM IS
READY TO PROCESS THIS NEW
ELIGIBILITY- AUTOMATICALLY AND
THAT IT'S NOT A MANUAL PROCESS
AND SO I THINK THIS IS STANDARD
LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE INCLUDED- IN
PAST EXPANSIONS. WITH THAT I
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND
MOVE ON TO YOU PANEL TO. THE
WILL- CONTINUE TO WORK TO ENSURE
THAT THE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT THOUSAND. ELDERS AND
SENIORS YOU MENTIONED TO BE
ENROLLED BY MAY OF TWENTY TWO.
THE WE HAVE A PLA THAT WE ARE
DOING OUTREACH AND WORKING WITH
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE- ENROLLING AS
MANY AS POSSIBLE. UNTIL WOULD
APPRECIATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOUR DEPARTMENT AS
WELL. TO MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
ALL WE CAN TO. HELP THOSE IN
ROLE WHO SHOULD HAVE COVERAGE BY
MAY OF THIS YEAR. DEFINITELY
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE PANEL TO TELEHEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE PANEL
ONE WE WILL HAVE TO TELL HEALTH
PROPOSALS HERE THE FIRST IS A B.
C. P. UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE TO IMPLEMENT
AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN RELATED TO
TELEHEALTH IN THE COMMERCIAL
MARKET. AND THE SECOND PROPOSAL
IS A MEDIC CAL TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL FROM DH CS WE WILL HAVE
FIVE PRISONERS ON THIS PANEL
MARY WATANABE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. DAN SOUTHERN CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR DMH C. DIRECTOR
BOSS FROM DH CS J. C. COOPER. A
STATE MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF DH CS
AND CORY HAAS SHIDA WITH THE L.
A. M. LET US BEGIN WITH DIRECTOR
WATANABE. AFTER NEARLY UP NAME
IS MERRY WHAT'S NOT BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED DIRECTOR THE MANAGED
HEALTHCARE AND I HAVE DANCE
OTHERS WITH ME IN DANCE ACTUALLY
GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
OUR P. C. P. AND THEN WE'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. WELL
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN RESERVE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MONIES DANCE OTHER
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR THE MEAT
C. IT IS VERY NOTED I'LL PROVIDE
YOU WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR
PROPOSAL VAST. WORKLOADS AB FOUR
FIFTY SEVEN. AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
AND OF PROTECTION OF PATIENT
CHOICE. TELL HEALTH PROVIDER.
STATES THE PURPOSE OF TELEHEALTH
IS TO ALLOW PATIENTS DIRECTOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER. IN STATE
YOUR CONVENIENCE MAKES IT IN
PERSON TREATMENT DIFFICULT OR
IMPOSSIBLE. THE BILL REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO FILE REPORTS THE
DEC REGARDING UTILIZATION OF
CORPORATE TELEHEALTH SERVICES
REQUIRES HEALTH NEEDS TO ENSURE
THAT CORPORATE TELEHEALTH
PROVIDERS SEND PATIENT RECORDS
TO THE ROLE LEADS PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN ADS SECTION THIRTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR POINT ONE FOUR ONE
TO THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE.
ESTABLISHES REQUIREMENTS FOR
HEALTH PLANS WHEN THEY OFFERED
WILL BE SERVICES TO A THIRD
PARTY. OR PATEL PROVIDER
INCLUDING DISCLOSURE TO ROWLEY'S
UNAVAILABILITY OF RECEIVING
SERVICES. THE RIGHTS TO ACCESS
THE SHIP- IT'S- CORRECT ACCESS
TO THIRD PARTY CORPORATE
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS AND CABLE
REPORTING BY HEALTH PLANS. AB
FOUR FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES A DVC
DRAFT LEGAL MEMORANDUMS REGARD
IMPLEMENTATION AB FOUR FIFTY
SEVEN. AMONG EIGHT A REGULATION
TO CLARIFY THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
HEALTH NEEDS REIMBURSEMENT OF
TELEHEALTH IN CALIFORNIA. UPDATE
NETWORK ADEQUACY REGULATIONS
PERTAINING TO THE REQUIRED
FILINGS INVESTIGATE AND TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AS
APPROPRIATE IN THIS HEALTHCARE
TO DO NOT COMPLY WITH
REQUIREMENTS TO BE BEFORE FIFTY
SEVEN. REVISED THE TELEHEALTH
CHECKLIST TO NEW DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AND DRAFT SUMMARY
AND GUIDANCE. TO AN ALL PLAN
LETTER. ENHANCE THE TIMELY
ACCESS TO NEVER CHEMICALS HE
SYSTEMS TO COLLECT ALL HEALTH
DATA RADIO NETWORK IT'S TIMELY
ACCESS REVIEWS AND FINALLY
REVIEW THE ADDITIONAL DATA
SUBMITTED BY HEALTH PLANS DO WE
SEE. UNDER HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE SECTION THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN POINT ZERO THREE FIVE FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE KNOX KEEN.
TO ADDRESS THIS WORK WITH THE
TEAMS IS REQUESTING THREE
POSITIONS AND EXPENSE REPORTING
FROM THE MANAGED CARE FILE. THIS
REQUEST INCLUDES A HUNDRED
NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND LIMITS OUR
RESOURCES. JUST NEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. THAT TO CONDUCT
LEGAL RESEARCH LEGAL MEMORANDUM
AND PROBABLY GET A REGULATION.
AND FINALLY THIS REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AT THREE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR FOR
CONSULTING FUNDING TO ENHANCE
THE TIMELY ACCESS NETWORK
ADEQUACY SYSTEMS TO COLLECT THE
TELEHEALTH DATA FOR A NETWORK
ENTIRELY ACTS READS. THAT
CONCLUDES WITH A BRIEF OVERVIEW.
ONE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. NEXT HEAR FROM
DIRECTOR BY. I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO A CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR J. C.
COOPER AND SHE WILL BE HANDLING
THE REMAINING ITEMS FOR EACH THE
US AS WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON- ONE
THING I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
BECAUSE IT'S A QUESTION A NUMBER
OF ITEMS FOR THE COMMITTEE
TODAY- BUT REALLY IN REGARDS TO
OUR TRAILER BILL. I'M BEING
RELEASED WE JUST WANTED TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF GETTING ALL TRAILER BILL OUT
ON A FLOW BASIS AS SOON AS WE
CAN- AND WE'LL BE UPDATING
PEOPLE ALONG THE WAY WE DO RENT
HIS ANTICIPATED COMING OUT IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. TO ALLOW
SUFFICIENT TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE STAKEHOLDERS TO
REVIEW ANY PROPOSED CHANGES AND-
ARE WORKING TO GET THAT AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. IN REGARDS TO OUR
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT DID A RELEASE THAT ON
FEBRUARY THIRD- WITH WITH MANY
DETAILS HOWEVER GIVE IT OUT A
LITTLE BIT OF IT A FRAMING OF
THAT PARTICULAR PIECE IN YOUR
OTHER QUESTIONS TODAY. SO IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN PRIOR TO THE
ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC DH CS HAS
UNDERTAKEN. A PRETTY LARGE
PROCESS TO REVIEW AND REFINE ITS
TELEHEALTH POLICIES. THIS
PROCESS RESULTED IN A REVISED
MORE EXPANSIVE POLICIES THAT
AFFORDED SUBSTANTIAL
FLEXIBILITIES PROVIDERS TO MAKE
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE DECISIONS
REGARDING THE USE OF TELEHEALTH
ACROSS. MULTIPLE AREAS INCLUDING
MEDICARE FEE FOR SERVICE AND
MANAGED AND MANAGED CARE- AFTER
THE ONSET OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY OF FOOD HAVE
DISCUSSED. OTHER DEPARTMENT
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITIES ON
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY TO BROADEN THE
FLEXIBILITIES AROUND TELEHEALTH
SERVICES. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
LEADING- IT HAS BEEN A LEADING
STATE IN REGARDS TO THE
EXPANSIVENESS OF COVERAGE AND
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SERVICES
DELIVERED VIA TELEHEALTH. IN DH
CS IS VERY COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO ENABLE BROAD
TELEHEALTH COVERAGE AND PARITY
OF REIMBURSEMENT BETWEEN IN
PERSON AND BDO AND AUDIO ONLY
TELEHEALTH VISITS. ALL POSE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY POLICIES
ARE PROPOSED BY THE DEPARTMENT
WERE GUIDED BY SEVEN KEY
PRINCIPLES. EQUITY ACCESS.
STANDARD OF CARE ASIAN CHOICE.
CONFIDENTIALITY STEWARDSHIP. AND
PAYMENT APPROPRIATENESS. AND WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE TELE
HEALTH ADVICE GROUP FURTHER. OFF
OUT THESE ITEMS. AS AGREED IN
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR DH YES
FORGET. ADVISORY WORKGROUP. OF
THIS WORK GROUP CONSISTED OF
MEMBERS- WITH VERY SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE- AND OF REALLY
ALLOWED US TO LOOK AT. WHAT
WHERE WE WOULD ADOPT VARIOUS
BILLING AND UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS FOR
TELEHEALTH. WORKGROUP MET THREE
TIMES IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WORKGROUP MEETINGS
WERE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AND
FOLLOW UP FOLLOWING EACH MEETING
ELECTRONIC SURVEYS WERE
CONDUCTED TO SOLICIT ADDITIONAL
WORKERS INPUT- I'M IN DHS
CONDUCTED A DOZEN ONE ON ONE
INTERVIEWS WITH INDIVIDUAL
STAKEHOLDERS REPRESENTING A
VARIETY OF ORGANIZATIONS AND
PERSPECTIVES. WE WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT WE WERE ENGAGING
WITH A BROAD GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS TO INFORM OUR
ULTIMATE RECOMMENDATIONS. IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE DEPARTMENT PUBLISHED THE
TELEHEALTH WORKGROUP REPORTS.
AND REVIEW THE POLICY APPROACHES
THE WORKGROUP- DELIBERATED ON.
ON FEBRUARY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
TO BE RELEASED THE PROPOSAL AS I
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY. AND WE
WILL BE HOSTING A WEBINAR ON
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH 2% THE
TELEHEALTH POLICY PROPOSAL TO
THE ADVISOR. GROUP AND OTHERS
PROBABLY. I'M TO GO OVER A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE POST
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
TELEHEALTH POLICY I'M I'LL GO
THROUGH A NUMBER OF THE MAIN
PROPOSAL ITEMS- DOMINANTLY
THOUGH WE ARE MAINTAINING MANY
OF THE POLICIES INTRODUCED
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. INCLUDING THE
CONTINUED COVERAGE OF
SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO AUDIO ONLY AN
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH COVERAGE
ACROSS MULTIPLE SERVICE AND
DELIVERY SYSTEMS- AS THE DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY THIS
INCLUDES EVEN ACROSS OUR
NINETEEN FIFTEEN SEE RAVERS. IN
VARIOUS DELIVERY SYSTEMS WE ARE
ALSO PROPOSING TO CONTINUE
PARITY IN REIMBURSEMENT LEVELS
BETWEEN IN PERSON SERVICES IN
SELECT TELEHEALTH MODALITIES-
AND REMOVING THE SITE
LIMITATIONS ON ACTUATES THESE.
HOWEVER AFTER CONSULTING
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE TELEHEALTH
ADVISORY WORKGROUP HE ALSO
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF NEW
POLICY APPROACHES INFORMED BY
THAT GROUP- AND I WILL WALK
THROUGH THOSE NOW. ALLOWING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW PATIENTS
ONLY THROUGH IN PERSON FACE TO
FACE OR SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO
SUBJECT TO CERTAIN PROTECTIONS.
PROHIBIT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
NEW PATIENTS USING AUDIO ONLY OR
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH. THE
DEPARTMENT BELIEVES THIS WILL BE
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE BY
STABBING NEW PATIENTS VIA
TELEHEALTH WHILE IMPROVING THE
ABILITY OF PROVIDERS TO VALIDATE
IDENTITY OF THE PATIENT. THEREBY
IMPROVING PROGRAM INTEGRITY AND
ENSURE A DEEPER LEVEL OF INITIAL
PATIENT PROVIDER COMMUNICATION
IS AVAILABLE FOR THE INITIAL
VISIT THAT OFTEN REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT EVALUATION AND
ASSESSMENT. THROUGH JUST THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS AN
EXCEPTION WAS MADE FOR FQHCS ARE
FOR THE USE OF ASYNCHRONOUS
TELEHEALTH WHEN CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET SUCH AS. THE
VIRTUAL DENTAL HOME INITIATIVE.
WE ALSO WILL BE REQUIRED THE USE
OF SPACE MODIFIER TO IDENTIFY
THE TELEHEALTH MODALITIES USED
INCLUDING THE ADOPTION OF
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED CPT CODE
FOR AUDIO ONLY VISITS. I WOULD
NOTE SINCE WE ROLLED OUT THE
POSSIBILITIES DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES SO QUICKLY.
NOT ALL OF THE VARIOUS
MODALITIES HAD A SEPARATE
MODIFIER THIS WILL NOW ALLOW US
TO SEPARATE THE USE OF AUDIO
ONLY FROM OTHER VIDEO OR OTHER
MODALITIES WHICH WILL BE
CRITICAL AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
THE VALUATION. AS WELL AS-
OVERALL PROGRAM INTEGRITY.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE LOOK AT A
NUMBER OF PATIENT PROTECTIONS
AND HOW TO ENHANCE THOSE
RELATIVE FEW. TELEHEALTH
INCLUDING STRENGTHENING CONSENT
LANGUAGE FOR PATIENTS INCLUDING
THE RIGHT TO FACE TO FACE
SERVICES. THE USE OF TELEHEALTH
BEING AN OPTION OF THE
BENEFICIARY RECEIVING
INFORMATION ON THE LIMITATIONS
AND RISKS OF SERVICES BEING
DELIVERED VIA TELEHEALTH.
AVAILABILITY OF TRANSLATION
SERVICES AND PHASING IN A
REQUIREMENT THAT INSURERS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE CHOICE OF
TELEHEALTH MODALITY WHEN CARE IS
PROVIDED VIA TELEHEALTH. AN
OPTION FOR IN PERSON CARE.
ADDITIONALLY A LOOKING TO ADOPT
THE USE OF EVALUATION AND
MANAGEMENT CODES AND
ASSESSMENTS- IN MANAGEMENT
BECAUSE THE DELIVERING
TELEHEALTH SERVICES VIA AUDIO
ONLY MODALITY- THIS AUTHORS
PROVIDERS AN ADDITIONAL AND MORE
ACCURATE OPTION TO IDENTIFY
BRIEF AUDIO ONLY CHECK IN
INTERACTIONS WITH PATIENTS.
INCREASE THE ACCESS TO CARE BY
ALLOWING A MEDICAID MANAGED CARE
PLANS MENTAL HEALTH PLAN AND
RECOMMEND IT- MEDIC HELP
ORGANIZE DELIVERY SYSTEMS I'M TO
USE CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE AUDIO
VIDEO SYNCHRONOUS INTERACTIONS
AS A MEANS TO DEMONSTRATE
COMPLIANCE WITH NETWORK
ADEQUACY. TIME AND DISTANCE
STANDARDS THE ACS HAS DONE AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW OF HOW THIS IS
BEING IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE
NATION AND WE HAVE FOUND OTHER
STATES ARE ALSO BEGINNING TO
ESTABLISH PARAMETERS FOR
CONSIDERING TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS
IN THEIR NETWORK ADEQUACY
STANDARDS- AND SO WE WILL ALSO
BE CONSIDERING THAT AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT IN OUR PROPOSAL. AS
WELL. A NUMBER OF
CONSIDERATIONS. WITH RESPECT TO
THE- OP- LEVERAGING TELEHEALTH
MODALITIES AND- PRESERVING
PATIENT PROTECTIONS ARE SIMILAR
IN THE COMMERCIAL AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE MARKETS I'M STATE
SEEMS TO BE ESTABLISHING
GUARDRAILS AND SIMILAR MATTERS
FOR COMMERCIAL PLANTS AND
MEDICAID PROGRAMS. PARTICULARLY
AROUND TELEHEALTH ONLY PROVIDERS
WE HAVE DONE THE NATIONAL
SCANNED TO REALLY HELP INFORMAL
RECOMMENDATIONS. IN LIGHT OF-
THE PROPOSAL AS WELL. AND LASTLY
IN REGARDS TO ONGOING MONITORING
OF PROVIDERS DO YOU SEE US WILL
CONTINUE TO APPLY RISK BASED
APPROACH BY EXPANDING ANALYTICS
AND ALGORITHMS DEVELOPED TO
EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY SUSPECTED
TELEHEALTH ACTIVITY TO BE
AUDITED OR INVESTIGATED. DURING
EXTENT EXPANSION OF OUR PROGRAM
INTEGRITY OUR PROGRAM HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT. CURRENT RISKS
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED- INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED YOU ARE CODING
TIMING COMPLEXITY OF SERVICES
PROVIDED. PROVIDER SERVICES VIA
TELEHEALTH THAT WOULD BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR IN PERSON
SERVICES MISREPRESENTING THE
VIRTUAL SERVICE PROVIDED BILLING
FOR SERVICES NOT RENDERED AND
KICKBACKS. THE TELEHEALTH
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION PLANT IS
CURRENTLY UNDER THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE WORKGROUP HAS RECOMMENDED
SPECIFIC RESEARCH QUESTIONS
WHICH WILL BE ADDRESSED IN THE
PLAN. I'M SUCH AS HOW TELEHEALTH
CONTRIBUTES TO ACCESS TO CARE.
OF FOR DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THE
IMPACT CLINICAL OUTCOMES FOR
SPECIFIC CONDITIONS AND THE USE
COMPARES AS THE USE OF COMPARING
IN PERSON VISITS TO OUR YOU KNOW
VARIOUS TELEHEALTH MODALITIES
ACROSS THOSE VARIOUS
POPULATIONS. THE MONITORING AND
REPORTING OF TELEHEALTH
UTILIZATION WILL CONTINUE OVER
THE NEXT FEW YEARS AND THEN IT
WILL ALSO BE CHANGED AS WE GET
OUTSIDE OF SOME OF THESE INITIAL
FEW YEARS TO REALLY MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO
EVALUATE THE HEALTH OUTCOMES.
IMPACT OF THESE VARIOUS
MODALITIES. I'M BLESSED WITH
JUST ONE TO. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS RAISED SPECIFICALLY IN
REGARDS TO PROVIDERS HAVING A
REQUIREMENT TO EVENTUALLY OFFER
BOTH VIDEO AND AUDIO SERVICES
WHICH WAS A RECOMMENDATION
WITHIN OUR PROPOSAL. OF MANY
PROVIDERS INCLUDING SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS- IMPROVED
INFRASTRUCTURE TO OFFER VIDEO
SERVICES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
DURING THE WORKGROUP PROCESS WE
HEARD AGREEMENT ACROSS THE BOARD
THAT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR
BENEFICIARIES TO HAVE A CHOICE
IN THEIR MODALITY OF CARE. THEY
ASKED DH YES TO PHASE IN A
REQUIREMENT AND NOT HAVE IT BE
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY WHICH IS
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING
IN NO SOONER THAN JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR FOR THAT
RECOMMENDATION. WE THINK THE
MODALITIES SHOULD BE DRIVEN BY
WHAT'S BEST SERVES THE PATIENT
CARE AND THE PREFERENCES
ABILITIES OF THE BENEFICIARY AND
DON'T WANT BENEFICIARIES TO BE
FORCED TO USE AUDIO. BASED ON
THE- PROVIDERS PREFERENCE OR
UNWILLINGNESS TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS I TO IMPROVE PATIENT
CARE. WE HAVE LESS EVIDENCE AND
EFFECTIVENESS AND QUALITY FOR
AUDIO ONLY CARE- AND OFTEN
OFFERING CHOICE OF THE
MODLITIES WE FEEL IS IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT BENEFICIARY
CHOICES DRIVING. OF THE MODALITY
THAT IS BEING USED A GIVEN THE
PAYMENT PARITY PROVISIONS WE ARE
CONTINUING. UP FOR IN PERSON
AUDIO ONLY VIDEO AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OFFERING AUDIO
LOOP ARE YOU ONLY CAN BE-
SOMETIMES MORE CONVENIENT FOR
PROVIDERS I MEAN WE TAKE THE
UNDER RECOGNITION KNOWING THE
INVESTMENTS ARE FOR SOME OF THE
VIDEO ONLY- AT AND WE WILL TAKE
THAT AS WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS ON A PROPOSAL. AND
THAT CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'LL BRING IT BACK UP TO
THE DENTIST. TO SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS. EXCUSE
ME- NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM HOW
SHE DOES WITH THE L. L. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA AB
KOREA SHEET WITH THE ALLEY OOP
WE JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS TO
RAISE ON THE NET CAL. L. IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR RADIO- JUST THE AD
WILL REVIEW IT WHEN IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE AND FOLLOW UP IF WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS- THE
ADMINISTRATION DID SORT OF MAKE
THAT FACT SHEET AVAILABLE WHICH
DESCRIBES THE COMPONENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL
AND WE'VE HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
THAT- WE WOULD JUST RAISE A FEW
COMMENTS FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION ON A FEW ASPECTS
OF THE PROPOSAL- FIRST THE
PROPOSAL YOU KNOW AS MENTIONED
EARLIER GENERALLY PROHIBITS
AFTER THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ENDS THE
ESTABLISHMENT. OF NEW PATIENTS
THROUGH- AUDIO ONLY OR
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH
MODALITIES- BUT DOES A LOT OF
PCS TO PROVIDE FOR SPECIFIC
EXEMPTIONS TO THIS REQUIREMENT
BASED ON. STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK-
IN ADDITION TO THE ONE THAT THE
ADMIN JUST NOTED FOR FQHCS- THE
LEGISLATURE DISTINGUISHED TO
CONSIDER HOW THIS ASPECT THE
PROPOSAL WILL. IMPACT SERVICE
DELIVERY AND MONITOR WHAT
SPECIFIC EXEMPTIONS TO THIS
POLICY END UP BEING DEVELOPED
GOING FORWARD AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS- SECOND YOU KNOW WE FIND
THE ADDITION OF SPECIFIC BILLING
MODIFIERS TO IDENTIFY TELEHEALTH
VISITS BY MODALITY TO BE.
APPROPRIATE AS THESE BILLING
MODIFIER TO ALLOW FOR. THEIR
CAPACITY TO TRACK THE DELIVERY
OF TELEHEALTH SERVICES- AND MAY
ULTIMATELY HELP WITH EVALUATING
THE IMPACTS OF THE VARIOUS
TELEHEALTH ANALOGIES ON PATIENT
OUTCOMES. THIRD GIVEN PROPOSER.
FOR ANY PROVIDER MAKING
TELEHEALTH SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
THEM BY BOTH- UP LIVE VIDEO AND
AUDIO ONLY BY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FOUR THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO JUST CONSIDER WHAT
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY- SUCH AS
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE- YOU
KNOW BEYOND SORT OF WHAT.
PROVIDERS HAVE ACCESS TO NOW
THEY WILL NEED TO SORT OF MEET
THIS REQUIREMENT- INCLUDING
WHETHER THIS CAPACITY OR NEED
FOR CAPACITY VARIES BY
GEOGRAPHIC REGION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- AND WHETHER SORT OF
ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT WILL BE
NEEDED FOR THESE PROVIDERS TO
MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS- FINALLY
THE ADMINISTRATION INDICATES
THAT IT WILL DEVELOP. A RESEARCH
PLAN FOR EXAMINING HOW
TELEHEALTH UTILIZATION AS
IMPACTED ACCESS QUALITY AND
OUTCOMES IN PROVIDER IN ROLE THE
EXPERIENCES AND MEDIC HOW- YOU
KNOW WHILE WE FIND THIS TO BE A
POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO SORT OF
MONITOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT
ALTERNATE PLAN. AND WHAT DETAILS
ARE NOT BEING INCORPORATED
WITHIN IT- THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE FURTHER
ASSISTANCE WHERE NEEDED. THANK
VERY MUCH WE'LL BRING IT UP TO
THE DIOCESAN BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND JUST THE
COMMENT ON THE ON THE PREVIOUS-
PRESENTATION AS FAR AS A TELE
HEALTH NET I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT-
TELEHEALTH NET THAT WE ARE
INCLUDING- URBAN INDIAN HEALTH
CENTERS AS FAR AS THE DIALOGUE-
IN THE COMPONENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ALL. MOVING IN THAT
SPACE TO MAKE SURE THAT
TELEHEALTH THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
ALL- IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CLEARING THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE AND I
KNOW THAT. LATER ON ON- ISSUE-
THIRTEEN WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THAT BUT I JUST
WANTED TO. MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CHIMING IN ON THE SUCCESS OF
TELEHEALTH THAT BUT FOR ALL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU AYE I WILL BEGIN MY- FIRST
QUESTION FOR G. C. COOPER AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE A COMPANY
TRAILER BILL. BUT WHEN YOU
SUBMITTED I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
ALSO PLEASE PROVIDE A SIDE BY
SIDE OR CROSSWALK OF THE
CURRENT. PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
PROPOSALS COMPARED TO WHAT WOULD
CONTINUE. BEYOND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. AND HOPING YOU
CAN PROVIDE THAT WHEN THE
TRAILER BILL BECOMES AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REQUEST WILL
BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO PROVIDE- A
CROSSWALK ADD TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO AN INFORMED DECISION THE
LARGEST ITEM I WOULD A FLAG IS
REALLY THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
NEW PATIENT ACROSS ALL
MODALITIES THAT WAS. SOMETHING
THAT WAS EXPENDED EXPLICITLY
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY BUT WE'D BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT ROSTOCK
INCLUDING THE NEW OUR BENEFITS
YOUR PERFECT PROTECTIONS I WHICH
WE ARE PROPOSING ONLY FOR THE
POST PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
ITEMS THAT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MY NEXT QUESTION IS FOR DAN
SOUTHERN- IN YOUR CONCEPT PAPER
YOU TALKED ABOUT UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS FOR
TELEHEALTH I WAS HOPING YOU
COULD PLEASE ELABORATE ON THAT
AND CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME
REASSURANCE. YOU DON'T FORESEE
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT. AS A
TOOL TO LIMIT UTILIZATION FOR
COST PURPOSES SO MUCH SO THAT IT
DIMINISHES THE OVERALL VALUE.
AND POTENTIAL VALUE OF
TELEHEALTH. THAT'S FOR D. THREE
OVERALL. CHECK THE CHURCH CARE
COULD YOU REPEAT THAT FIRST
PORTION OF THE QUESTION FOR ME
YEP AND APOLOGIES FOR- SAYING
DOWN SOUTHERN I BELIEVE THE
QUESTION IS FOR DH YES- IT'S
THANK YOU. SO J. C. COOPER CAN
YOU SET YOUR REPEAT THAT
QUESTION JUST TO MAKE SURE I
GET. EVERYTHING YOU'RE WANTING
FROM US PLEASE I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT TALK ABOUT UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS FOR
TELEHEALTH I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. AND HOPING YOU CAN
GIVE US SOME REASSURANCE
REASSURANCE THAT THIS WON'T
LIMIT UTILIZATION FOR COST
PURPOSES SO MUCH THAT IT
DIMINISHES THE POTENTIAL VALUE
OF TELEHEALTH. THANK YOU YES THE
ALTERNATELY AND MANY OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ADVISOR
GROUP WE DIDN'T REALLY MOVE
FORWARD IN REGARDS TO MANY KIND
OF FORMAL UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
PROTOCOLS FOR EXAMPLE CAPS OR- A
NUMBER OF VISITS PER MODALITY.
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE ARE LEANING
TOWARDS IS IMPLEMENTING THE
FLEXIBILITIES DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY BUT REALLY
ENFORCING BENEFICIARY CHOICE
ALONG THE WAY IN REGARDS TO THE
BEST MODALITY FOR THE SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED. AND THEN OF
COURSE ALLOWING PROVIDERS TO USE
THEIR CLINICAL JUDGMENT AND
ASSESSMENT IN REGARDS TO WHICH
MODALITY IS THE MOST EFFECTIVE
UP FOR THE BENEFICIARY I WAS
STILL MAINTAINING- PAYMENT
PARITY IS WHERE WE LANDED IN SO
WE WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
THAT BEARD. YOU KNOW VARIOUS
WAYS LOOKING AT PROGRAM
INTEGRITY AND THEN THE
EVALUATION TO INFORM IF IN THE
FUTURE WE NEED TO EVALUATE ANY
ADDITIONAL UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT ITEMS BUT AT THIS
TIME I DID NOT ULTIMATELY
RECOMMEND A LARGE NUMBER OF U.
M. CONTROLS WITHIN. THE WORKER
FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED. THANK
YOU VERY. WITHOUT ALL THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS FOR PANEL TO WE
WILL MOVE ON THE PANEL THREE. ON
THE CAL HERE'S BCP. WILL HAVE
TWO PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
JAMES DAWKINS. CAL HERE'S
PROJECT DIRECTOR. AS FROM THE
OFFICE OF SYSTEMS INTEGRATION AS
WELL AS BRIAN METZGER WITH THE
L. A. L. LET'S BEGIN WITH JAMES
DAWKINS. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
JAMES FROM THE CALAVERAS PROJECT
DIRECTOR WITH NORTHSTAR. I'M
GOING TO PROVIDE YOU A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE CITY. THE
OFFICER INTEGRATION REQUEST SIX
FROM POSITIONS AN INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND AND GENERAL FUND THE
SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY POINT THREE
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
STABILIZATION OF CRITICAL
SERVICES WITHIN CAL HERE'S- THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD EXPAND THE
GOVERNOR'S TEAM CONTINUES TO
CONTINUE TO SUCCESSFULLY
DEVELOP. CAST AND IMPLEMENT
FEDERAL AND STATE MANDATED
SYSTEM CHANGES. I REQUEST ALSO
ADDRESSES THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
REQUIRED TO SUCCESSFULLY MANAGE
TO RECENT CHANGES SYSTEM
INTEGRATOR. I APPROVAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS CRITICAL TO ENHANCE
THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
PERFORMANCE YOU SERVICE LEVELS
ARE RESTRUCTURING ROLES
RESPONSIBILITIES ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY OF THE STATE'S
. PROJECT. THE CARD IS PROJECT
REQUIRES HIGHLY EXPERIENCED
LEADERSHIP STAFF WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE YOU PROPOSALS DEVELOP
IMPLEMENT AND RESOLVE COMPLEX I.
T. ISSUES AS WELL AS IMPLEMENT
COMPLEX POLICIES WHILE ADHERING
TO COMPLIANCE RULES REGULATIONS
CONFIDENTIALITY REQUIREMENTS AND
STATE SECURITY IMPACTS ACROSS
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURES THE GOAL
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS TO PROVIDE
THE CARRIAGE PROJECTS BOUNCERS
PARTNER STAKEHOLDERS AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR THE MOST
EFFICIENT AUTOMATED SYSTEM TO
APPLY FOR AND OBTAIN AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE THROUGH
COVERED. CALIFORNIA OR MEDI CAL
. NOT CONCLUDE REPORT AND
WILLING TO ANY QUESTIONS MIGHT
HAVE. THEY YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM THE L. A. L. BRIAN METZGER
LMAO WE HAVE REVIEWED THIS
PROPOSAL AND HAVE NO CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WITH THAT
I'LL BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS
SINAN NOVEL THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL THREE WILL MOVE ON THE
PANEL FOR ON THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MEDIC CALLOUSED MESS.
WE WILL HAVE THREE PRESENTERS ON
THIS PANEL MICHELLE FOSTER
RECTOR OF DH CS TRACY COOPER
STATE MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR DH CS
AND LUKASZ MORROW WITH THE L. A.
L. LET US BEGIN WITH. J. C.
COOPER. THANK YOU. UP TO THE
MISSION OF THIS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE INTEGRATED HIGH
QUALITY HEALTH CARE I'M
INCLUDING MEDICAL DENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT SERVICES IN LONG TERM
CARE ON NOW I WILL DO A HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW OF THE ASSONANCE
- THE MEDICAL ESTIMATE PROJECTS
MEDI CAL SPENDING TO BE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION TOTAL
FUNDS TWENTY SIX POINT EIGHT
BILLION GENERAL FUND. FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR REFLECTING A
SLIGHT INCREASE OF ZERO POINT 5%
IN TOTAL FUNDING OF FOUR POINT
7% DECREASE IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING COMPARED TO ESTIMATES
FROM THE BUDGET ENACTED LAST
SUMMER THE MAJOR DRIVERS OF THE
CHANGE IN THE ESTIMATE- IN
REGARDS TO GENERAL FUND SPENDING
INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY. ONE
BILLION RELATED TO THE REDUCE
CODE NINETEEN COSTS PRIMARILY
RESULTING FROM ADDITIONAL
SAVINGS FROM INCREASED AFTER NOT
BEING AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO- PARTIALLY
OFFSET BY ADDITIONAL CASE LOW
COST OF FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
MILLION RELATED TO THE SHIFT OF
MULTI YEAR SPENDING- INTO LATER
YEARS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
MILLION RELATED TO INCREASE FOR
OUR- INCREASE FUND FROM THE
HOSPITAL QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE
FOR CHILDREN OF COVERAGE. ON ANY
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION RELATED TO REDUCED ARE
PROJECTED COSTS FOR THE KALENJIN
ARTICULATION AND FIVE HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT MILLION RELATED. TO THE STATE ONLY CLAIMING. R.
FOR BUT YEAR- THE DEPARTMENT FOR
SPENDING IN MEDICARE TO BE A
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION TOTAL FUNDS. THIRTY FOUR
POINT NINE BILLION GENERAL FUND
THIS REFLECTS A SEVEN POINT 1%
INCREASE IN TOTAL FUNDING. A 30%
INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING COMPARED TO THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. A GROWTH IN
PRODUCTION- OUR GROWTH IS
PROJECTED IN MEDICARE FUNDING-
AND SPENDING IN BUDGET YEAR
RELATES TO A VARIETY OF FACTORS-
OUTLINED IN DETAIL IN THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA. ARE TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW A MAJOR ISSUES
THE GENERAL FUND COSTS ARE
PROJECTED TO GROW SIGNIFICANTLY
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AS INCREASED FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR MEDICAID ALL IS THE
SAME TO ENDS. IF I'D BASED ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
ENDING- AND ROCKCASE LOADS
REMAIN HIGHER THAN- OTHERWISE. I
WOULD BE L. A. AS IN- WHAT
CASELOADS REMAIN HIGHER THAN
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE
FOR GIVEN THE GRADUAL
REDETERMINATION OF EVERYONE OVER
A TWELVE MONTH PERIOD OF TIME- I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT THERE ARE
NO. OF THINGS UP. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WOULD
INCREASE THOSE COSTS- FOR A FEW
JUST TO MENTION THINGS LIKE THE
FOUR YEAR COST OF THE FULL SCOPE
OF COVERING OLDER ADULTS FIFTY
AND- OLDER REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BRIDGE HOUSING AT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE. ELIMINATION OF
CERTAIN EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
REDUCTIONS PREVIOUS PROP FIFTY
SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT. AND
RATE INCREASES MOVING TO
PERMANENT RATE INCREASES ON
USING GENERAL FUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MOBILE CRISIS
BENEFIT. OF REDUCED MEDICARE
PREMIUMS TO ZERO THERE'S
FINANCING OUR OUR NURSING
FACILITY FINANCE REFORM IN
EQUITY AND PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PAYMENTS. I KNOW
NUMBER OF THOSE ITEMS WILL BE A
REVIEW TODAY AND OUR FUTURE
HEARINGS I LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING EACH OF THOSE IN
THOSE RESPECTIVE TIME PERIODS.
REGARDING CASELOADS ARE THE
COMMITTEES QUESTIONS ON
CASELOAD. OF THE PANDEMIC HAS
RESULTED IN A SIGNIFICANT GROWTH
IN THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
ENROLLED IN MEDI CAL THE
INCREASE IS PRIMARILY DUE. TO
THE CONTINUOUS COVERAGE
REQUIREMENT THAT IS TIED TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY WHICH
PREVENTS MOST ON DISTANT ROMANCE
OF FROM THE PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ASSUMES THE
MEDICAL CASE LIVE GROWING TO A
PEAK OF OVER FIFTEEN MILLION
AFTER WHICH ELIGIBILITY WILL BE
DETERMINED GRADUALLY OVER THE
TWELVE MONTH PERIOD. THE
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO INDIVIDUALS AGE
FIFTY AND OVER REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS PROJECTED
TO RESULT IN OVER A HUNDRED
EIGHTY. THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING POST OF COVERAGE BY
THE END OF THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. HOWEVER
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT'S CASELOAD
PROJECTIONS TO INCLUDE A SMALL-
OVERALL INCREASED- A FEW
THOUSAND CASES FOR EXAMPLE DUE
TO THIS EXPANSION THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE WILL GAIN FULL
SCOPE COVERAGE THROUGH THE-
EXPANSION ALREADY HAVE
RESTRICTED SCOPE COVERAGE AND
MEDICARE. AND ARE ALREADY
REFLECTED IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
CASELOAD PROJECTIONS ARE. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL SIMPLY BE
SWITCHING FROM I'M RESTRICTED
SCOPE COVERAGE TO FULL OF COVER
. WITHIN THE OVERALL CASE
PROJECT. IN THIS AND MICHAEL AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WE WILL FROM THE L. L.
THANK YOU MOREOVER THE L. A. L.
WE RECENTLY RELEASED OUR
ANNOUNCES A MAJOR ADJUSTMENTS
THE MEDICAL BUDGET ALL BE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IS A VERY
HIGH LEVEL- WITH A POTENTIAL
EXEMPTION UP ADMINISTRATIONS
CAREFUL SOMETIMES WE GENERALLY
FIND ADMINISTRATORS MEDICAL
ESTIMATES TO BE REASONABLE. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE IT ON
ITS UNDERLYING ASSUMPTIONS. OVER
THE COMING MONTHS. FIRST ON THE
INCREASE IN FUND KNOW THE TO OF
PROPOSED INCREASE OF ABOUT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
SPENDING BETWEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY THREE.
TWENTY THREE THIS TRANSLATES TO
ABOUT A 30% INCREASE YEAR OVER
YEAR I HAVE ABOUT 80% OF THIS-
PROVIDES TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS.
AND THE REMAINING TWENTY
PERCENT. REFLECTS NEW
DISCRETIONARY PROPOSALS THAT
WOULD IMPLEMENT IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. ON THE PHD.
POLITICAL EMERGENCY. THIS IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY IN
THE MEDICAL BUDGET AND ISN'T
THIS SEEMS EXPIRATION THE
MINISTRATION- WOULD MEAN FOR
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO- WHAT IT
DOES ULTIMATELY AND THIS WILL.
TRIGGER TWO MAJOR THINGS OR IF
THEY'LL BE A MENTOR- DECREASE IN
FINAL FOUR MATIC CAL. AND ALSO
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING OF
BUILDING TERMINATIONS- THAT
WOULD BE A BIG DROP IN CASELOAD
AS THE- ADMINISTRATION'S NOTED
JOIN PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THERE'S BAD IT UP ACTIVELY
APPLAUSE ON THE BUILDING
TERMINATIONS FOR MOST PEOPLE A
MEDIC CAL WHICH THE LAN CABLE.
TO GROW SUBSTANTIALLY. THAT
MEANS THE OF THE THAT AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT IT ON STATE RISK
AND PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY MORE
THAN OFFSETS AT AMOUNT. SO IF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
EXTENT THE JUNE- THERE COULD BE
SUBSTANTIAL FISCAL SIGN FOR THE
STATE- MICHAEL. RANGE OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND. FOR EACH NINETY
DAY EXTENSION. IN TERMS OF THE
CASELOAD ASSUMPTION. WE FIND
THAT THEY ARE OF. DUE TO SLOWER
ALTHOUGH STILL POSITIVE CASE OF
GROWTH IN RECENT MONTHS AND WHAT
WAS THE SCENE IN THE BUDGET. AND
WE KNOW THAT THE BUDGET YOUR- OF
AND HAVE A GOOD ONE THAT HE H.
E. ON AND DATE AND PROPERTIES. I
ALSO DIFFER DIMINISH ON K. THE
NAY. NONE OF THE WEAPONS THAT TO
DEVELOP DETERMINE. ARE WHAT CAR
. AND PUBLIC HEALTH. LBS MORE
COULD IN HIGH. CASE SUCH AS THE
NEW YORK PERSONS INSTANT. THIS
IS SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
FISCAL ESTIMATES WHAT CASELOAD.
A FINAL ISSUE THAT I WOULD RAISE
IT IS RELATED TO THE MCO TAX
WHICH THE TOP ONE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS- THANK YOU THE-
I'M NOT THE REVENUE FROM THIS
TAX IS USED OFTEN GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND MEDICARE. IS TAX
GENERATED UP AVERAGE NET GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT OF OVER ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. AND IS ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
INCLUDES FEDERAL FUNDING TO THE
STATE OTHERWISE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO TALK ON THE TAX. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
PROPOSE TO EXTEND AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS DEADLOCK WOULD LOVE TO
EXPIRE HALFWAY THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE RESULT IN
THE LOSS OF THIS ROUGHLY ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION GENERAL FUND
BENEFIT. THE MILITARY HAS NOTED
THAT LIKE BIG CHANGES AROUND
WHICH NCOS PARTICIPATED IN
MEDICAL MANAGED CARE DID WAS
DELIBERATE BUT YOU'RE ONLY AS
WELL AS ANTICIPATED VOLATILITY
IN THE CASE OF COMPLICATED WE
KNEW ALL UP AND. SEALED TAX. WE
AGREED IT IS RID YOU MAKE CAUSE
CHANGE. BUT THESE WOULD BE. IN
NATURE. NOT THE OPPORTUNE I. OF
A HELP CENTER SORT OUT. I THINK
YOU ARE GOING TO THREE OPTIONS
FOR THE LAST TO CAN. FOR ALLEGED
COULD WITH THE AND TAX BASED ON
THE EXISTING FOR ONE. CALGARY OR
- IN THIS WOULD ALLOW THAT STATE
OVER THAT HOW EVERYBODY SHERMAN
SAID THE CHANGE IN TIME TO NOT
ABOUT HIS. CAR TOLD TWENTY FOUR.
OR TWENTY FOUR LATER YEARS
LEGISLATION NEED TO CONSIDER
WHEN IT WOULD BE FEASIBLE TO
ENTERING. INTO TALKS. ABSOLUTELY
THE NEW. LEGISLATURE COULD MORE
YEAR RE AUTHORED THAT TALKS THAT
WOULD BE IN PLACE BOTH BEFORE
AND AFTER THE REBOOT YOUR MEANT.
A LOT OF VACATIONS YOUR DRAFT
CHALLENGES INTRODUCED BY THE
WEEK WHAT YOU WANT. AND FINALLY
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALLOW THE
MCO TAX TO BLOCKS AND THEN WE
KNEW IT AT A LATER DATE SUCH AS
THE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE STATE HAS A
BETTER IDEA WHICH INSTILLS ABOUT
HIS PAY AND MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
AND. WHAT LITTLE BIT WILK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
OPENING UP THE DIE TO SEE ANY
MAN. HAVE THE NONE- I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT ON PAGE
THIRTY THREE OF THE AGENDA.
THERE'S A LINE ITEM FOR FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
MILLION COST RELATED TO
ADDITIONAL DRUG REBATES. AND WAS
HOPING YOU COULD PROVIDE SOME
CLARITY TO THAT LINE ITEM. SO I
THINK I MAY NEED TO. BRING IT
BACK JUST TO MAKE SURE I KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE REFERRING TO
THERE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THAT CAN IMPACT REBATES
IT'S GOING TO BE A COMBINATION
OF THAT CALIBER ACTS WITH THE
INCREASE OF EVERY BATES BEING
ASSUMED. WE ALSO HAVE SOME
INTERACTIONS IN REGARDS TO AND I
DISAPPEAR AND THAT CCS AND G. H.
B. P. R. REBATES BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE KNOW WHAT'S
COMPILED IN GROUP UNDER THE FULL
OP FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO YOU.
AFTER THE HEARING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WILL THANK ALL
OF THE PANELISTS FOR PANEL FOR
WE WILL MOVE ON TO PANEL FIVE.
ON THE NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FAMILY HEALTH ESTIMATE WE
WILL HAVE TO PRESENTERS
DIRECTOR. MICHELLE BOSS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND G. C. COOPER STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR DH SEE US.
LET US BE AGAIN I BELIEVE WITH
TRACY COOPER. THANK YOU. SO THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY ONE A FAMILY
HEALTH ESTIMATE PROJECTS
SPENDING FOR STATE ONLY-
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
THE- GENETICALLY HANDICAPPED
PERSONS PROGRAM ARE BUT IT'S
ALSO KNOWN AS G. H. P. P. AND
THE EVERY WOMAN COUNTS PROGRAM
FOR FISCAL FOR THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR THE ESTIMATE GLOB
PROJECTS SPENDING OF TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY NINE MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS TWO HUNDRED AND- TWO
HUNDRED TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
REFLECTING EIGHTY SIX POINT 4%
DECREASE IN TOTAL FUNDING A SIX
POINT 9% DECREASE IN GENERAL
FUND SPENDING COMPARED TO
ESTIMATES FROM THE BUDGET
ENACTED LAST SUMMER. MAIN FACTOR
FOR THE REDUCED ESTIMATES
SPENDING IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR- IS REDUCE COSTS RELATED TO
KOBE NINETEEN AND- ENROLLMENT
AND PACKS I'M ENROLLMENT IS THE
ONLY A CCS HAS DROPPED SOMEWHAT
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC DUTY
INDIVIDUAL SHIFTING TO MEDIC CAL
CCS THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
UTILIZING SERVICES AND EVERY
WOMAN COUNTS PROGRAM HAS ALSO
AND I'M SOMEWHAT LOWER SENSE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY BEGAN
ALTHOUGH UTILIZATION IS
INCREASING AND- APPROPRIATE- AS
WE AS AS PRIOR TO KIND OF PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS. FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THE DEPARTMENT
PROJECTS SPENDING IN FAMILY
HEALTH PROGRAMS TO BE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE MILLION TOTAL
FUNDS A TWO HUNDRED THIRTEEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND WHICH
REFLECTS EIGHTY SIX POINT 4%
INCREASE IN TOTAL FUNDING EIGHTY
FIVE POINT 4% INCREASE IN
GENERAL FUND SPENDING COMPARED
TO THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR
GROWTH IN PROJECTED MEDICARE
SPENDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR
RELATES PRIMARILY TO THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THE REDUCED
SPENDING DUE TO COPE AT NINETEEN
IMPACTS WILL PHASE OUT AT THE
END OF THE BUDGET YEAR. AND THAT
REMAINS. I ALL MY COMES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL BE IT UP TO
HIGHEST IF ANY MEMBER HAVE.
FACING NON HELLO THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL FOR AND WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PANEL SIX. ON TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH PROPOSALS. WE WILL HAVE
TO PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
STARTING WITH G. C. COOPER STATE
MEDICAID DIRECTOR. AND CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND BEN JOHNSON WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
LET US BEGIN WITH JC COOPER.
THANK YOU ON THE FIRST I WILL
START REGARDING THE FAMILY PACK
COVERAGE OF THE HUMAN PAPILLOMA
VIRUS VACCINE ON SAID THE BUDGET
REQUEST EIGHT MILLION IN BUDGET
YEAR AND I'M GOING TO INCLUDE H.
P. V. AS A COVERED BENEFIT UNDER
THE FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE AND BILLS AGES NINETEEN
THROUGH FORTY FIVE EFFECTIVE
JULY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THIS POLICY I WOULD INCREASE
ACCESS TO THE H. P. I. BAXEEN
WHICH PREVENTS VARIOUS CANCERS
I'M IN REDUCES THE RISK AND
WORK- MORBIDITY AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH HPV RELATED
DISEASES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
INCREASING ACCESS TO THE VACCINE
FOR UNINSURED UNDERINSURED
UNVACCINATED OR UNDER VACCINATED
INDIVIDUALS SERVED BY THAT
FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM MAY HELP
TO REDUCE THE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN CANCER
INCIDENCE AND OUR MENTALITY
RATES AMONG MINORITY WOMEN AND
THEN. THE ADDITION OF THE H. P.
P. R. TO A TO F. PACK WITH A
LINE THE BENEFIT WITH MEDIC CAL
BOTH FEET FOR SERVICE AND
MANAGED CARE COVERS HPV
VACCINATION FOR FEMALES AND
MALES BETWEEN A NINE IN FORTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE AND BASED ON
THE ADVISORY IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES ARE RECOMMENDED
INDICATIONS. REGARDING THE
MEDICATION ABORTION SERVICES ARE
THROUGH THE COBIT NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
MEDICATION ABORTION PROVIDERS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE VISITS
THROUGH TELEHEALTH INCLUDING THE
POST ABORTION FOLLOW UP IS THAT
I'M DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY DH CS HAS MODIFIED
POLICIES REGARDING THE USE OF
CULTURE SOUNDS AND DID NOT.
PURSUE REIMBURSEMENT REDUCTIONS
. HOWEVER AS WE CONSIDERED YOU
OPPOSED HEALTH EMERGENCY. MOSEL
OF YOU HAVE FORWARD A PER IN THE
WHICH IS NEUTRAL OF THE
DEPARTMENT PROPOSES TO MODIFY
WHAT'S CALLED THE S. R. ZERO ONE
NINE NINE CODE WHICH IS VERY
TECHNICAL ESSENTIALLY BUILDING
CODE- IN MEDICATION ABORTION
RELATED SERVICE CODES- IN THE
FOLLOWING WAYS- TO IMPROVE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THE USE OF SUCH
CODE I TO BE ALLOWED WHEN PRE
ABORTION ULTRASOUNDS ARE NOT
REQUIRED. WHEN CLINICALLY
INDICATED POST ABORTION
ULTRASOUNDS ARE NOT REQUIRED
WHEN NOT CLINICALLY INDICATED
AND REMOTE A PREGNANCY
COMPLETION ASSESSMENT IS
ALLOWABLE IF CLINICALLY
INDICATED AND IF PATIENT PREFERS
REMOTE ASSESSMENT IN PERSON
VISITS MUST BE OFFERED BUT IS
NOT REQUIRED TO BUILD THE BUNDLE
RIGHT. ADDITIONALLY ARE MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO MODIFIER
FIFTY TWO PAYMENT REDUCTIONS AS
IT APPLIES TO THE USE OF THAT
CODE- MODIFIER OF FIFTY TWO YOU
MUST BE USED IN THE FOLLOWING
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN FEWER THAN TO
CULTURE CELLS ARE PROVIDED BASED
ON AN ASSESSMENT THAT ONE OR
MORE OLDER SON IS NOT CLINICALLY
INDICATED PROVIDERS WILL HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO ASSESS
WHETHER OLDER SOUNDS ARE NEEDED.
IF ONE OR MORE ULTRASOUNDSARE
NOT PERFORMED BASED ON LACK OF
CLINICAL NECESSITY PROVIDERS-
MAY STILL BUILD THE BUNDLED RATE
HOWEVER BECAUSE THE BUNDLED RATE
REFLECTS THE COST OF AT LEAST OF
AT LEAST TWO OLDER SOUNDS THE
MODIFIER MUST BE USED WHEN FEWER
THAN TO OFFER SOUNDS ARE
PERFORMED. WHEN A PROVIDER IS
UNABLE TO PERFORM AN ABORTION
COMPLETION ASSESSMENT OR FOLLOW
UP VISITS WHICH MAY INCLUDE A
PATIENT NOT SHOWING UP FOR A
VISIT OR PARTICIPATING IN THE
ASSESSMENT- REDUCE THE LEVEL OF
PAYMENT REDUCTION ASSOCIATED
WITH THE USE OF MODIFIER FIFTY
TWO THE DEPARTMENT REDUCED THE
PAYMENT REDUCTION ASSOCIATED
WITH THE USE OF MODIFIER FIFTY
TWO FROM TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
GIVEN THOSE HOSTILITIES WE
WANTED. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE NOT OVER DO YOU SEEING THE
REDUCTION TO PAYMENT TO PER. OF
IN THIS REALLY TO FOR AVERAGE
COST OF A CULTURE SOUNDS NOT
BEING PROVIDED ARE BASED ON
CLINICAL INDICATIONS THAT THAT
NOT BEING NEEDED. THE
REIMBURSEMENT ADJUSTMENT
REFLECTS YOU A LOWER INTENSITY
OF SERVICES IS NEEDED TO PERFORM
THE SERVICE A SAFELY. BUT WE
ALSO OF WORK TO REMOVE A
FREQUENCY LIMITATIONS FOR
ULTRASOUNDS AS WELL AS MAINTAIN
THE FOLLOWING- ITEMS WITH NO
CHANGES WITHIN THE PROPOSAL WE
DID NOT MAKE CHANGES. TO THE
WHAT'S CALLED FROM THROUGH
BILLING ON AS MANY OF PROVIDERS
WILL TALK ABOUT WE ALSO DO NOT
MAKE ANY CHANGES TO PROVIDER
DISCRETION TO BUILD THE BUNDLED
RATE OR TO BILL FOR THE SERVICES
INDIVIDUALLY WHICH IS AN OPTION
THAT PROVIDERS DO YOU HAVE. I'M
AS WELL AS WE DID NOT MAKE ANY
CHANGES TO THE MEDICATION
ABORTION WHICH WOULD REMAIN YOU
ARE SEVENTY DAYS JUST SESSION-
H. I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
NEITHER OF THESE PROPOSALS
REQUIRE TRAILER BILL. AND CAN BE
DONE ADMINISTRATIVELY. AND THIS
ENDS MY COMMENTS AT THIS TIME.
AND YOU NEXT WE WILL HEAR. FROM
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE L. L. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR AT DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MEMBERS WE JUST HAVE ONE BRIEF
COMMENT ON THE H. P. V. A
PROPOSAL. FINDING THAT THERE IS
A STRONG POLICY RATIONALE FOR
PROVIDING COVERAGE OF THAT HPV
VACCINE WITHIN FAMILY PACKED AS
IT WOULD EXPAND ACCESS ACCESS TO
AN EFFECTIVE PREVENTIVE SERVICE
AND I HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT UP TO THE DÍAS TO
SEE IF ANY MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS. SAYING NINE I WILL
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
CLARITY ON THE CLINICAL
NECESSITY. REGARDING ULTRASOUNDS
WITH THAT WE WILL THANKS VERY
MUCH ALL THE PANELISTS FOR PANEL
SIX AND WE WILL MOVE ON THE
PANEL SEVEN. ON THE MATERNAL
CARE AND SERVICES SB SIXTY FIVE
B. C. PEOPLE- WE WILL HAVE
PRESENTING ON THIS PANEL J. C.
COOPER STATE MEDICAID DIRECTOR
FOR DH CS SO LET US BEGIN WITH
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR COOPER.
THANK YOU. SO THE DEPARTMENT
REQUESTS FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND TOTAL FUNDS OF FOR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY TWO THOUSAND
TOTAL FUND FOR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FOR TWO LIMITED FOR
THE FORD TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM A
RESOURCES EQUIVALENT TO TWO
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SENATE BILL
SIXTY FIVE AND TO TRACK BENEFIT
IMPLEMENTATION AND MANAGE THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THESE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW THE ACS TO
COMPLETE INCREASE WORKLOAD
ASSIGNMENTS RESULTING FROM THE
PROGRAM POLICY CHANGES SURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION AND
TRACKING OF THE DO A ENEFIT.
AND THE ABILITY PROJECT- TO
PRODUCE ARE YOU KNOW BUT DRIVEN
QUALITY PRODUCTS IN A TIMELY
MANNER REGARDING THE DO THE
BENEFIT AS A PART OF THE BENEFIT
OF THE BUDGET AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION I DO LIST
SERVICES WILL BE ESTABLISHED AS
A MEDIC HOW BENEFIT DH CS ON HAS
BEEN MEETING WITH STAKEHOLDERS
SINCE THE FALL OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AJ RECEIVED THEIR INPUT ON
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
QUALIFICATIONS TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES REQUIREMENTS TO
INITIATE THE PROVISION OF THE DO
YOU DO A SERVICE- RATES AND A
DESCRIPTION OF THE DO A
SERVICES. INPUT RECEIVED FROM
THE WORKGROUP MEMBERS WILL BE
USED TO INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE NEEDED STATE PLAN
AMENDMENTS OF FOR ADDING THESE
SERVICES AS A COVERED BENEFIT
UNDER MEDICARE ALL ON FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH A G. H. YES INFORMED OF
THE DUALISTIC COLORS THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE DEAL A
BENEFIT WILL BE MOVING FROM JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. THE DELAY IS ALLOWED- IS
REALLY TO ALLOW THE NEEDED TIME
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN REGARDS TO
BENEFIT DESIGN PROVIDER
ENROLLMENT REQUIREMENTS
ENGAGEMENT WITH MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND REQUIREMENTS FOR
VALIDATION ON AS PLANNED
PROVIDER OF AS WELL AS WORKING
REALLY DO YOU UNDERSTAND THE
RIGHT DEVELOPMENT- PIECES AND-
OTHER THINGS LIKE. DO A REGISTRY
ON THAT IS REALLY NEEDED FOR US
TO OUR ARMS AROUND TO. THE PAUL.
ARE WE LOOK FOR TO ENGAGE WITH
STATE IN THIS COUNTRY MY CON AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL IT UP TO THE DIET TO SEE IF
AN MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS.
SEEING NANA WILL THANK- OUR-
PANELISTS FOR PANELS SEVEN I
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE EIGHT.
MEDI CAL PROVIDER RATE PROPOSALS
TRAILER BILL- WE WILL HAVE TO
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
BEGINNING WITH CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR G. C. COOPER WITH DH
CS. FOLLOWED BY COREY HOW SHEILA
WITH THE L. A. L. LET'S BEGIN
WITH. CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
COOPER. THANK YOU I'M UP WITH
OVER OUR SORRY WHAT YEAR OVER
YEAR REDUCTIONS IN PROPERTY SIX
FUNDING AND THE GROWTH NEEDED TO
ELIMINATE LONGSTANDING MEDICARE
RATE CUTS A DH CS IS PROPOSING
CHANGES TO HOW THE DEPARTMENT
USES PROP FIFTY SIX IN THE
ELIMINATION OF SELECT EIGHTEEN
NINETY SEVEN REDUCTIONS ON TO
INFORM THESE CHANGES DHC HAS
FOCUSED ON OUR LEARNINGS FROM
THAT COULD BE NINETEEN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY AND USE THE
MEDIC HOW COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY
IN EQUITY STRATEGY TO IDENTIFY
CORE POPULATIONS IN SERVICES A
FOCUS ON AS WELL AS FURTHER
PREPARE THE MEDICAL PROGRAM FOR
THE FUTURE CODE NINETEEN.
RELATED SEARCHES OR ENDEMIC
CASES- RATES AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. AFTER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. GUARDING EVEN
SEVEN THE BUDGET INCLUDES TWENTY
MILLION TOTAL FUND NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND- IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FOUR
MILLION TOTAL FUNDS ON GOING TO
ELIMINATE A VERY IS SB NINETY
SEVEN PAYMENT REDUCTIONS FOR THE
BERRIES FOLLOWING PROVIDERS. IT
WOULD INCLUDE NURSES OF ALL
TYPES- YOUR THING SERVICES MAKES
A DIRECT IMPACT ON OUR THE CARE
PROVIDED TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES AND NURSING
SHORTAGES HAVE BECOME MORE
CRITICAL SENSE AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. ADDITIONALLY
NURSES ARE A VITAL COMPONENT OF
THE MEDICAL WORKFORCE- BOTH IN
RURAL AREAS WHERE LICENSED
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS MAY NOT
BE READILY AVAILABLE AND IN
MEDICALLY I DIDN'T UNDERSERVED
URBAN AREAS. DEVOID OF ADEQUATE
A LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS AND MEDICAL
SPECIALISTS. IT ALSO INCLUDES-
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT ARE
FOCUSED IN A SUBSET OF THOSE
SERVICES AROUND OXYGEN AND
RESPIRATORY SERVICES AS WELL AS
RESPIRATORY CARE PROVIDERS OF
DME OMPONENT IS A CONTINUATION
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
A FLEXIBILITY THAT WAS PUT IN
PLACE ADDITIONALLY DH CS HAS
IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN CHRONIC
RESPIRATORY DISEASES ESPECIALLY
ASTHMA. IT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
CLOSING THOSE GAPS ARE
INCREASING RESPIRATORY CARE IS
ALSO NEEDED IN LIGHT OF THE
WILDFIRES THAT WE EXPERIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA ON A REGULAR BASIS
YOU REALLY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AS WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
QUALITY HEALTH OUTCOMES IN THE
SPACE. WE ALSO WERE INCLUDING
ARGUE- AUDIOLOGISTS AND HEARING
AID DISPENSERS ONTO A LINE WITH
THE EXPANSION OF HEARING AID
COVERAGE IN ENSURE CHILDREN HAVE
A FULL ACCESS TO NEEDED
AUDIOLOGY AND HEARING AID
SERVICES. INCLUSION OF CHRONIC
DIALYSIS CLINICS- WAS A CRITICAL
ITEM. AS YOU WOULD IMAGINE
PRODUCT DIALYSIS CLINICS SERVE
TO PROVIDE LIFE SUSTAINING
DIALYSIS SERVICES FOR PATIENTS
WITH END STAGE RENAL RENAL
DISEASE WHEN PATIENTS DON'T
RECEIVE DIALYSIS SERVICES THEY
WILL RAPIDLY DOES DETERIORATE
CLINICALLY. AND WITHIN DAYS I TO
THE POINT OF NEEDING VARIOUS
OTHER EMERGENT DIALYSIS FOR
EMERGENCY RETIREMENT DEPARTMENT
OR HOSPITALIZATION SO A CRITICAL
NEED FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES.
ADDITIONALLY ALTERNATIVE
BIRTHING CENTERS GIVEN THE
REIMBURSEMENT- THIS IS LESS
EXPENSIVE OUR ALTERNATIVE TO
DELIVERY OF COMPARED TO HOSPITAL
DELIVERY ESPECIALLY- IF VAGINAL
RATHER THAN CESAREAN DELIVERY IS
PERFORMED. ON AND REALLY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OPTIONS
ARE AVAILABLE FOR PREGNANT WOMEN
IN OUR PROGRAM I DO YOU
IDENTIFIED THE TYPES OF A BIRTH
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
EXPERIENCE. IT ALSO DIRECTLY
ALIGNS WITH- OUR COMPREHENSIVE
QUALITY STRATEGY WHERE WE ARE
VERY FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
MATERNITY. OUTCOMES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA YEAH. THE
INCLUSION OF A- ERR MED TO-
WHAT'S CRITICAL EMERGENCY ERR-
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDERS
TRANSPORT THE MOST CRITICAL
PATIENTS. FROM THE SCENE OF AN
INCIDENT AT TWO HOSPITALS AND
TRAUMA CENTERS IN ORDER TO ALLOW
PROVIDERS TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
THESE SERVICES. D. H. THE S. IS
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS AND
ELIMINATE THE EIGHTY NINETY
SEVEN REDUCTION AND INSTEAD
PROVIDE A RATE INCREASE FUNDED
BY GENERAL FUND AND FEDERAL
FUNDS. DO YOU SEE AS HAS
PROVIDED- AUGMENTATION AMOUNTS
TO SUPPLEMENT THE BASE
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
REIMBURSEMENT FUNDED BY PENALTY
ASSESSMENTS- FROM CERTAIN
VEHICLE CODE AND LOCAL ORDINANCE
VIOLATIONS ARE CURRENTLY THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL AIR
TRANSPORTATION ACT REQUIRES
EXTENSIONS TO THE PROVISIONS-
AND AN ANNUAL APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE. AND LASTLY
WITHIN THE B NINETY SEVEN
INCLUSION OF NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION IS A
CRITICAL SERVICE ALLOWING FOR
BENEFICIARIES TO RECEIVE NEEDED
CARE GHC HAS PROVIDED
AUGMENTATION AMOUNTS VIA PROP
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS.
INCLUDING THE OFFSETTING OF AB
NINETY SEVEN REDUCTION AMOUNTS
TO DH CS IS PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE THE REDUCTION IN
PROVIDING ON GOING RATE INCREASE. JUST OF COURT THIS CRITICAL
SERVICE. AND WE'RE BUT THE PROP
FIFTY SIX PROPOSED. OF PROP
FIFTY SIX REVENUES HAVE DECLINED
OVER TIME AND ARE SUFFICIENT TO
SUPPORT THE CURRENT PROPERTY SIX
PER PAYMENTS BEGINNING IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
MEDICAL SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT- IN
ITS FUNDED BY PROPERTY SIX ARE
PROJECTED TO EXCEED REVENUES
FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. THE BUDGET
PROPOSES TO FULLY TRANSITION THE
FOLLOWING PAYMENTS VALUED AT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN MILLION.
ONGOING RATE INCREASES SUPPORTED
BY THE GENERAL FUND BEGINNING
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWO. ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES GREENING'S
WORK HE SAYS SCREENING AIDS
WAIVER OF SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS.
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
OR C. BASS SERVICES
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS
FREESTANDING PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
COME HOME HEALTH SERVICES. I
CFDT SERVICES NON EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION IN
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN ADDITION THE BUDGET
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF TWENTY
NINE MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO FULLY FUND THE REMAINING
PROPERTY SIX PAYMENTS. ARE AT
THEIR CURRENT LEVEL IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
AND FINALLY ON THE EQUITY IN
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION PAYMENTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF PROPOSES FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION TOTAL FUN TWO
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
ONE TIME FUNDS TO MAKE EQUITY IN
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION
PAYMENTS. TO QUALIFYING MEDICAL
PROVIDERS- TO FLOWS CRITICAL OF
HEALTH EQUITY GAPS ADDRESS GAPS
IN PREVENTIVE MATERNITY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH MEASURES IN
ADDRESS THE GAPS OF CARE THAT
AROSE FROM THE- CODE NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. ON SUCH
PAYMENTS ARE INTENDED TO PROMOTE
PATIENT CENTERED MODELS OF CARE
IN PEDIATRIC PRIMARY CARE OBGYN
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SETTINGS
INTO ALIGNED WITH THE GOALS OF
THE MEDIC HOW COMPREHENSIVE
QUALITY STRATEGY- HE'S FUNDS
WOULD INCLUDE BOTH INITIAL
PLANNING GRANTS AND PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION GRANTS. THE
PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION GRANTS
WERE IT INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED TO CHANGE MANAGEMENT OR
OTHERS MECHANICS IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING UNDER UTILIZATION AND
CLOSING CARE GAPS BUT TRONIC
MEDICAL RECORDS SYSTEM UPDATES.
POPULATION HEALTH IMPROVEMENTS
TELEHEALTH REMOTE PATIENT
MONITORING AND A VARIETY OF
OTHER INITIATIVES TO HELP
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OUTCOMES- WE
WILL ALSO HELP AND PRACTICES
ALIGN THEIR WORK TO ME HOPE THAT
WE REALIZE THE BOLD GOALS THAT
WE HAVE LAID OUT IN OUR
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY STRATEGY.
OF THE APPLICATION AND SELECTION
PROCESS WILL ENSURE THAT THE
GRANTS ARE DISTRIBUTED ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL
AS WITH THE LENDS TO INVEST IN
THE LEAST ADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND LASTLY A DH CS
IS DEFERRING THE ADDITIONAL
PROPERTY SIX FUNDING QUESTIONS
IN THE AGENDA TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THIS CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL HEAR FROM
COREY HOW SHE DOES WITH THE L.
L. THANK YOU DR ARAMBULA. SHEET
WITH THE L. A. L. REGARDING THE
ELIMINATION OF EIGHTEEN NINETY
SEVEN PROVIDER RATE REDUCTIONS
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT DOWN WE
DO FIND IT UNCLEAR WHY CERTAIN
MEDICARE PROVIDERS ARE
PRIORITIZED OVER OTHERS FOR
RESTORED RATES IN THIS PROPOSAL-
THE LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WISH TO
CONSIDER THE MERITS AND COSTS.
OF RESTORING PAYMENT RATES FOR
OTHER OR EVEN ALL MEDICAL
PROVIDER TYPES THAT REMAIN
SUBJECT TO BE THE B. NINETY
SEVEN RATE REDUCTIONS- WE
ESTIMATE THE ANNUAL COST OF
ELIMINATING ALL THE EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN REPRODUCTIONS- A
FOR ALL PROVIDERS AT. ROUGHLY
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND- WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION MAY HAVE USE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC TO INFORM THE
SELECTION OF PROVIDERS FOR
RESTORED RATES- YOU KNOW
ACCORDINGLY THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO CONSIDER REQUESTING THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE-
INFORMATION SUCH AS YOU KNOW THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS OF
COPING NINETEEN ON. THE SELECTED
ACCOUNT PROVIDERS RELATIVE TO
OTHER PROVIDERS TO SORT OF
SUPPORT THIS- THIS RATIONALE- IN
ADDITION YOU KNOW WILD MANAGED
CARE PLANS MAY NOT ALWAYS TIE
THE RATES THAT THEY PAID THEIR
PROVIDERS. TO RATES IN THE FEE
FOR SERVICE SYSTEM IN MEDIC CAL
WE FIND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO.
RESTORE RATES WOULD LIKELY
AFFECT PAYMENT RATES IN MANAGED
CARE AS WELL AS THE PER SERICE-
HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL'S COST
ESTIMATE ONLY INCLUDES THE COST
IMPACT ON THE FEET FOR SERVICE
SYSTEM- WHICH WE FIND ME UNDER
STATE THAT THE ULTIMATE COSTS.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOTED
THAT IT BELIEVES THAT THE
MANAGED CARE COSTS FOR THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD BE SMALL BUT- THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO REQUEST
INFORMATION. JUSTIFYING THIS
THIS ASSUMPTION- NEXT TO
PROPERTY SIX YOU KNOW WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSUME
REDUCTION IN PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX REVENUE. IS LARGELY
ATTRIBUTED TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB SEVEN NINETY THREE WHICH
IMPLEMENTS A BAN ON SALES OF
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS- WHICH
WOULD RESULT IN FEWER
TRANSACTIONS INVOLVING TOBACCO
PRODUCTS FOR THE STATE TO TAX-
THE ADMINISTRATION ASSUMES THAT
THE UPCOMING REFERENDUM FOR
VOTER APPROVAL OF SB. SEVEN
NINETY THREE WILL SUCCEED
ALLOWING THE BAND TO GO FORWARD-
SHOULD THIS REFERENDUM FAILED
THOUGH- WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX REVENUES-
SHOULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER
THAN ASSUMED WHICH WOULD GREATLY
REDUCE THE NEED FOR. GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT CURRENT-
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX RELATED
ITEMS IN IN MEDIC CAL. REGARDING
THE EQUITY AND PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PAYMENTS PROPOSAL
YOU KNOW FIRST WE WOULD NOTE
THAT WE FIND THIS PROPOSAL
APPROPRIATELY TARGETS KEY AREAS
OF CONCERN RELATED TO QUALITY IN
EQUITY IN MANY CAL WITH ITS
FOCUS ON CHILDREN'S PREVENTATIVE
SERVICES AND MATERNAL HEALTH-
THIS SPECIFIED GOALS SUCH AS
IMPROVING CHILDHOOD IMMUNIZATION
RATES. ALSO SEEM TO ALIGN WITH
THESE AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT-
HOWEVER A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW WOULD BE NEEDED TO SEE IF
THIS PURPLE THIS PROPOSAL LEAVES
ANY SPECIFIC QUALITY OR OR
EQUITY DEFICIENCIES UNADDRESSED
IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. SECOND
ON THIS- ITEM WE WOULD NOTE THAT
YOU KNOW WE DO NOT HAVE A SENSE
OF THE CURRENT STATE OF CLINICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THESE AREAS OF
QUALITY IN EQUITY TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THIS IS A KEY FIRST STEP
IN MEETING THE GOALS OF THIS
PROPOSAL- AND THAT YOU KNOW A
LONGER ON GOING STRATEGY.
INCLUDING THROUGH PROVIDING
INCENTIVES FOR- YOU KNOW
IMPROVING QUALITY IN EQUITY IN
MEDIC HOW WILL BE NECESSARY TO
CREATING SUSTAINED IMPROVEMENT
IN THIS AREA- LATE LAST YEAR DH
CS RELIEF TO RELEASED A DRAFT
REPORT OUTLINING A STRATEGY IN
THIS REGARD. WHICH WE'VE
REVIEWED- WHICH MAY PROVE
BENEFICIAL GOING FORWARD- YOU
KNOW FINALLY WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE GATHER SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS PROPOSAL
BEFORE APPROVING- SOME KEY
OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS RESOLVED
INCLUDE- WHAT KEY QUALITY IN
EQUITY GOALS ARE LEFT
UNADDRESSED IN SHOULD BE
INCORPORATED INTO THIS PROPOSAL-
YOU KNOW WHAT IS THE CURRENT.
CONDITION OF MEDIC HELP
PROVIDERS CLINICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WISE CLINICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A KEY FIRST
STEP TO TAKE WITH THIS PROPOSAL-
HOW WILL GRANT APPLICATIONS BE
SELECTED AND HOW WILL TEACH THE
S. OVERSEE THE ALLOCATION OF
THESE FUNDS- AND HOW WILL TEACH
THIS DEFEATS THE ESSENCE OTHER
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE. MEDICAL
PERFORMANCE ON QUALITY IN EQUITY
MEASURES CONTRIBUTE TO ONGOING
IMPROVEMENTS IN IN THESE AREAS-
THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME AND WE'RE HAPPY TO BE
OF FURTHER ASSISTANCE WHERE
NEEDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL BRING IT. TO THE DIOCESAN
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR WITH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND MY QUESTION IS
FOR- FOR J. C. COOPER- AND IT IT
IT IT ACTUALLY FOLLOWS ALONG THE
LINE OF THINKING THAT WE WERE
HEARING FROM. MR ISHIDA- I DO
HAVE A QUESTION AT WHAT PROVIDER
CATEGORIES REMAIN. A SUBJECT OF
THE PRODUCT TO THE EIGHTEEN
NINETY SEVEN REDUCTION AFTER
THIS PROPOSAL. MAN WHO'S LEFT
OTHERS ARE. THE LONGLIST STILL-
AND WE'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THAT ON TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO INDICATE WHERE WE
HAVE RESTORED THOSE RATES- AND
WE'RE WE STILL HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF SERVICES
THAT ARE SUBJECT TO. REDUCTIONS
AND I GUESS- IS THE REASON THAT
THESE REDUCTIONS ARE NOT BEING
PROPOSED FOR ALL PROVIDERS TO ME
THE STATE'S IN PRETTY GOOD SHAPE
AND THESE GO BACK TO THE LAST
RECESSION AND WE'RE SPENDING A
WHOLE LOT OF MONEY ON A WHOLE
LOT OF THINGS. BUT YOU HAVE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS ARE PEOPLE
PROVIDING HEALTH CARE THAT FOR
YEARS NOW HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
THESE REDUCTIONS- AT WHAT IS
THERE A POINT AT WHICH WE CAN
GET BEYOND THIS I MEAN. I JUST
IT JUST FEELS IT JUST FEELS
UNFAIR. UNFAIR YEAH WE HAVE TO
TAKE THAT BACK AND ASSESS THE
REMAINING- WHEN PUTTING FOR THE
PROPOSAL I THINK WE REALLY USE
BOTH THE- THE QUALITY STRATEGY
IN THE COBIT NINETEEN EXPERIENCE
TO REALLY INFORM THIS IMMEDIATE
NEED. A GROUP OF PROVIDERS I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT BACK FOR
ASSESSMENT. I GUESS I WOULD
ARGUE THAT ALL THESE PROVIDERS
WOULD CONSISTENTLY BE AN
IMMEDIATE NEED- THEY'VE BEEN
WAITING SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE
I BELIEVE. SO THAT'S A LONG.
THANK YOU I THINK A DOCTOR
WOULD- I WILL STICK WITH- J. C.
COOPER IF I CANNOT I'D LIKE TO
TAKE IN ON THE EQUITY PAYMENT
PROPOSAL AND I'M HOPING YOU CAN
EXPLAIN HOW THE STATE WILL HELP
TO HOLD THE PLANS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR SHOWING PROGRESS IN EQUITY
MEASURES AS A RESULT OF THIS
FUNDING. YES REALLY THAT THE
INTENTION OF THE FUNDS IS REALLY
TO GO AT THE PROVIDER LEVEL- IN
MEETING GO TO TALKING TO A
NUMBER OF PROVIDER- GROUPS ARE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT THERE ARE REAL
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO PROACTIVELY IDENTIFY
GAPS OF CARE INCLUDING BEING
ABLE TO DISSECT THAT WITH AN
EQUITY LENS AND SO WE FELT IT
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT WE WERE PROVIDING A GRANT
DOLLARS. YOU ON VARIOUS
PROVIDERS TO BE ABLE TO UPDATE
THEIR SYSTEMS PROCESSES TO
IDENTIFY THOSE GAPS SO THE BE
ALTERNATELY CAN BE AT THE LOWEST
LEVEL THE DIRECT PROVIDER LEVEL
I'M USING DATA TO REALLY INFORM
AND DRIVE OTHERS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS IN OUTCOMES. I MEAN
WE DO KNOW THAT SOMETIMES-
THAT'S HARD FOR PROVIDER OFFICES
YOU- HAVE THAT RISK AND MAKE
THOSE INVESTMENTS AND SUPPORT BY
PROVIDING THESE GRANTS ARE WE
WILL HAVE A SHORT LIST OF
MEASURES THAT WE WANT TO SEE A
CONTINUE TO INCREASE. IT WOULD
ALIGN WITH THE OVERALL BOLD
GOALS WE HAVE ANNOUNCED YOUR
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY STRATEGY
AND SO REALLY IT'S IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS BUT THE INTENT IS
REALLY TO GET THESE DOLLARS
DIRECTLY TO AN ALL MOST IF NOT
ALL OF THE DOLLARS WILL BE GOING
DIRECTLY TO. THE PROVIDERS TO
FUND A PRACTICE TRANSFORMATION
AT THAT INDIVIDUAL PRIMARY CARE
OFFICE PEDIATRICIAN OBGYN. OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDER LEVEL
. CAN YOU DESCRIBE IN MORE
TEETH. YOUR FIFTY BY FIVE BOLD
GOAL INITIATIVE. I WOULD BE TO
TAG OUR CHIEF QUALITY OFFICER
WHO IS ON FOR Q. NA I APOLOGIZE
WOULD YOU. PLEASE WALK THROUGH
OR GET AN OVERVIEW OF THE BOLD
GOALS. EVERYONE ABSOLUTELY- TO
THAT FIFTY BY TWENTY FIVE- BLOOD
GOALS INITIATIVE WAS REALLY
DESIGNED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE SETTING AMBITIOUS BUT
ACHIEVABLE TARGETS TO REALLY
HELP. THOSE IN OUR MEDICAL
POPULATION- WHO'S YOU KNOW
CERTAIN QUALITY SCORES THAT
WE'VE SEEN LAGGING FOR QUITE
SOME TIME SO I'M GONNA JUST READ
THROUGH THEM BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE ANY. SO
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE HOPE TO
CLOSE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES AND WELL CHILD
VISITS AND IMMUNIZATIONS BY
FIFTY PERCENT- BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE WE HOPE TO CLOSE THAT
MATERNITY- BUT DISPARITIES THAT
WE'RE SEEING SPECIFICALLY FOR
BLACK AND NATIVE AMERICAN.
BIRTHING INDIVIDUALS BY 50% WE
WANT TO IMPROVE MATERNAL AND
ADOLESCENT DEPRESSION SCREENING
BY 50% GIVEN THE SPECIFIC IMPACT
OF MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS ON
THOSE TWO POPULATIONS. THAT ARE
REALLY AT RISK WE ALSO WANT TO
IMPROVE FOLLOW UP- FOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS BY 50% THAT SPANS A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT SPECIFIC
CORE MEASURES BUT TO HELP REALLY
IMPROVE FOLLOW UP FOR. PEOPLE
FOR WHO SCREENED POSITIVE FOR
DEPRESSION SCREENING OR FOLLOW
UP FOR A SUBSTANCE USE DIAGNOSIS
AND IT HAD AN EASY SET A MARK
BEEN INITIATED ON TREATMENT. AND
WE ALSO AT THE LAST GOAL YOU
KNOW DOES NOT SOUND OVER HERE
WE- AS SPLASHY BUT IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO US TO REALLY TACKLE
THOSE HEALTH DISPARITIES AND IT
IS TO MAKE SURE. THAT EACH AND
EVERY HEALTH PLAN ACROSS THE
STATE EXCEEDS OUR MINIMUM
PERFORMANCE LEVEL WHICH IS THE
FIFTIETH PERCENTILE NATIONALLY
FOR ALL CHILDREN'S PREVENTIVE
CARE MEASURES SO THAT CHILDREN
INDEPENDENT OF THE COUNTY THEY
LIVE IN OR YOU KNOW WHICH PLAN
THEY ARE ASSIGNED TO YOU CAN BE
ASSURED. A VERY ROBUST LEVEL OF
CARE FOR ALL OF THEIR PREVENTIVE
SERVICES. HI THANK YOU FOR THAT-
IS THE GOAL OF THE EQUITY
PAYMENT PROPOSALS TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE
FIFTY BY TWENTY FIVE BOLD GOALS
AND- IF SO ARE WE- TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE GOALS- AS
SET OUT BY THIS BOLD INITIATIVE
. YEAH I MEAN AT THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES THE INTENT BEHIND
THESE GRANT DOLLARS TO PROVIDERS
WOULD BE TO ALLOW FOR PROVIDERS
TO DIRECTLY INFLUENCE OUR
ABILITY TO IMPROVE THOSE ARE
QUALITY OUTCOMES- IN THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE A REPORTING
PUBLICLY. ON THOSE OUTCOMES OVER
THE COMING YEARS TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE TRACKING IMPROVEMENT IN
THOSE AREAS AND IF WE'RE NOT
SEEING IMPROVEMENT OF DOING ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSES TO IDENTIFY WHY
WE'RE NOT SEEING IMPROVEMENTS IN
WITH THE NEW STRUCTURE WITH OUR
CHIEF QUALITY OFFICER AND OUR
QUALITY AND POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT DIVISION. WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON ATTRACTING THOSE
OUTCOMES IN THOSE IMPROVEMENTS.
I'D LIKE TO- FOLLOW UP EARLIER
YOU HAD SAID THAT THE PAYMENTS
WOULD GO TO PROVIDERS. AND YET
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S A FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR TOTAL
FUND TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS IT'S COMING WITH A 50%
FEDERAL. MATCH BUT WOULDN'T THAT
THEN GO THROUGH THE PLANS TO
QUALIFY AND- WORK FOR THE 50%
FEDERAL MATCH- ARE ARE WE
WORKING THROUGH THE PLANS ARE WE
WORKING THROUGH THE PROVIDERS.
YES SO I WE ARE WORKING THROUGH
THE PLANS TO BE ABLE TO DRAW
DOWN THE FEDERAL FUNDS LIKE
WE'VE DONE IN A HANDFUL OF THESE
INITIATIVES I THINK THE BEST
EXAMPLE WHERE WE HAVE DONE THIS
VERY EFFECTIVELY I'VE
PREVIOUSLY. IS THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INTEGRATION GRANTS ARE WE
WORKED COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR
MANAGED CARE PLAN OUR PROVIDERS
TO DEVELOP ON THE APPLICATION
THE PARAMETERS FOR THE GRANT
DOLLARS ON THE CRITERIA AND THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE
COLLECTIVELY THREE STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK AND ENGAGEMENT. THEN WE
ROLL OUT A STANDARDIZED- YOU
KNOW MODULE AN APPLICATION
STATEWIDE THROUGH OUR MANAGED
CARE PLANS WHO HAVE THE DIRECT
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE PROVIDERS
ALSO REALLY ALLOWS FOR THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE LOCALLY I
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THOSE PROVIDERS
REGARDING THE OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE. ON THE DAY THEN I
TAKE THE APPLICATIONS FROM THOSE
AND USE A DH CS CREATED ON
STANDARDIZED CRITERIA FOR
EVALUATION OF THOSE GRANTS AND
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND ULTIMATELY THE
DEPARTMENT REVIEWS THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS- SO WE ARE.
USING THE MANAGED CARE PLANS AS
A CONDIMENT IN LIAISON TO THE
LOCAL PROVIDERS OF WHO THEY HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY OF BUT REALLY THE
INTENT IS FOR THOSE DOLLARS I
WANT TO BE APPROVED AND THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS APPROVED THE
APPLICATION. THOSE DOLLARS TO
FLOW DIRECTLY. TO THOSE
PROVIDERS. FOR QUESTION- THE
ADMINS FEE OF. AND MAKING
INVESTMENTS INTO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO DRIVE EQUITY
PARTICULARLY AS COMPARED TO
MAKING BIGGER AND BIGGER
INVESTMENTS INTO FOR PROFIT.
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATIONS.
HOPING YOU COULD CALL JUST TO BE
CLEAR THESE DOLLARS ARE MEANT TO
GO DOWNSTREAM TO PROVIDERS- AND
SO- THAT'S ONE THING I WOULD
NOTE THERE BUT I WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS A NUMBER
OF ITEMS WITHIN THE BUDGET. THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON INCREASING
PAYMENTS IN GRANT DOLLARS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE THE PATH THE DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE WITHIN THE BUDGET
PROVIDING ACCESS IN TRANSFORMING
HEALTH. IS DIRECTED TOWARDS
COUNTIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS TO MEET
THE GOALS OF CAROLINE- AND THERE
IS A ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR TOTAL FUNDS- I DOLLAR
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
AS WELL AS MANY OF THE KALYAN
INCENTIVES I CAN GO DOWNSTREAM
TO THOSE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THEY ARE CRITICAL
PARTNERS. IN REGARDS TO CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS AND TRANSFORMATION
AS WE MOVE THROUGH AND ENGAGE
ALL PROVIDERS ON THE GROUND
HOWEVER MANY OF THE MEASURES
THAT WERE TALKING ABOUT-
DIRECTLY ADMINISTERED BY. A
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
PEDIATRICIANS OBGYN OR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS AND
SO AS WE ARE TARGETING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY WITH THESE
DOLLARS THOSE OF OTHER FUNDS
AVAILABLE IN THE BUDGET WOULD BE
DIRECTLY- YOU'RE FOCUSED ON I.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AMONG OTHER PROVIDERS AS WELL. I
WILL- THE ONE FOLLOW UP BY I
WILL MENTION THAT- HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE FUND WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO
BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AS WE GO FORWARD
LOOKING TOWARDS EQUITY AND WOULD
ASK FOR US TO HAVE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS AS WE'RE GOING
FORWARD. WITHOUT THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL EIGHT WE WILL MOVE ON THE
PANEL NINE ON THE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT MODEL PROPOSAL FOR
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS. WE WILL HAVE TO
PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL TRACY
COOPER. CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR DH CS AND COREY HOW SHE
DEALT ITH THE L. A. L. WE BEGIN
WITH CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
COOPER. THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALSO
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. UNDER
SENATE BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN- THE
AUTHORIZATION OF A PILOT PROGRAM
FOR COUNTY AND COMMUNITY BASED
FQHCS WAS ACTED. UNDER THE
PROPOSED PILOT A PARTICIPATING
FQHCS WOULD MOVE AWAY FROM
TRADITIONAL VOLUME BASED PPS
PAYMENT SYSTEMS ARE TO ONE THAT
BETTER ALIGNS WITH THE INVOLVING
FINANCING AND DELIVERY OF HEALTH
SERVICES AND CAL. THE PROPOSAL
AS PROPOSED UNDER THAT OUR
PILOTS- THAT PPS PAYMENT AND
WRAPAROUND WOULD BE REPLACED BY
AN UP FRONT A CLINICALLY
SPECIFIC CAPITATION RATES. ARE
THE BENEFITS ADD TO THE
PARTICIPATING FQHCS IS THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE A SIMPLIFIED PAYMENT
PROCESS REPLACING THE PREVIOUS
BILLING APPROACH AND ASSOCIATED
DELAYS IN PAYMENTS. AT UBC'S
WOULD RECEIVE. YOU TO WAIT UNTIL
THE END OF THE YEAR FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY BENEFICIAL TO CASH
STRAPPED HEALTH CENTERS. THIS
PAYMENT REFORM BUT ALSO ALLOW IF
YOU SEE THE ABILITY TO OPERATE
MORE EFFICIENTLY- AND DELIVER
CARE IN INNOVATIVE WAYS THAT
WILL REALLY EXPAND BEYOND- OR
EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
PRIMARY AND SPECIALTY CARE
ACCESS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OF FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU WHICH THESE WOULD PROVIDE
NONTRADITIONAL SERVICES NOT
CURRENTLY REIMBURSED UNDER THE
TRADITIONAL VOLUME BASED PPS I'M
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
GROUP IT SETS AN EMAIL VISITS
PHONE VISITS A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER- OF CONTACTS CASE
MANAGEMENT. A CARE COORDINATION
ACROSS SYSTEMS ADDITIONALLY OF
THE REFORM REMOVES INCENTIVES TO
INCREASE THE VOLUME OF SEPARATE
VISITS ON THIS PROPOSED PILOT-
WAS ALSO EXPECTED TO INCREASE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS- AND THE
PARTICIPATING FQHCS. ABOUT BOTH
WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS BOTH WOULD ALSO
EXPERIENCE INCREASED VALUE FROM
BETTER COORDINATION CARE-
THEREBY HELPING TO REDUCE
UNNECESSARY UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES AND IMPROVE BENEFITS
YOUR EXPERIENCE. AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES. HOWEVER GFCIS WAS
UNABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE PILOT AS
OUTLINED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FIFTEEN DUE TO AN- TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL APPROVAL BASED
ON STATUTORY TRIGGERS FOR
RECONCILIATION TO INSURE FQHCS
WERE REIMBURSED AT LEAST THE PPS
RATE. OF OUR THE REVISED DH CS
PROPOSAL WHICH IS PROPOSED IN
THIS BUDGET- UPDATES EXISTING
LAW THAT AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENTED ALTERNATE
PAYMENT MODELS- REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY FOR FQHCS NO SOONER
THAN JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. THE PROPOSAL MAKES- THE
FOLLOWING CHANGES TO THE
EXISTING AUTHORITY CHANGES THE
APM FROM UP HIGH LEADS TO AN
ONGOING REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISM.
MODIFIES LANGUAGE WHICH TRIGGERS
RECONCILIATION TO BE ACTUAL
UTILIZATION COMPARED. TO YOU
PROJECTED UTILIZATION AND AS
LANGUAGE TO ESTÁ BY AND ACCESS
DANDER. AND IF THE PARTICIPATING
ATHLETES HE DOES NOT MOVE THE
ESTABLISH. ARE THE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO RETURN A PORTION OF
THE P. M. P. M. REVENUE WHILE
ENSURING REVENUE RECEIVED WILL
NOT BE LOWER THAN THE AMOUNT
THAT WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN
RECEIVED UNDER THE TRADITIONAL
PPS REIMBURSEMENT. I DH CS BEGAN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH AFFECTED
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP THE
PROPOSAL IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. LEVERAGING OUR
VARIOUS LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PRIOR EFFORTS AND DISCUSSIONS TO
ESTABLISH THE NEW ATHLETES EIGHT
PM. I'M CURRENTLY ARE TARGETED
ENGAGEMENT INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA AND REPRESENTATIVES
OF FQHCS AND LOCAL AND
COMMERCIAL HEALTH AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS- DH CS
CONTINUES TO ME BY THE GRIEF
WITH A CORE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY BEST
POSSIBLE WAYS TO DESIGN. AND
OPERATIONALIZE THE EIGHT PM DH
CS HAS FACILITATED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ORGANIZE A SERIES OF
FORMAL MEETINGS WITH A LARGER
POOL OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY A NEW PAYMENT
METHODOLOGIES. THE CLOSE CROSS
COLLABORATION WITH ASSOCIATIONS
AS WELL AS A FEW WEEKS THE
PROVIDERS. AND MANAGED CARE
PLANS HAS GIVEN DH THE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE SUCCESS OF THE PRO
FOR BOTH PROVIDE AND MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES SERVED BY FQHCS. I
THROUGHOUT TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE DHS WILL CONTINUE
TO HOLD RECURRING SMALL
WORKGROUP MEETINGS AND LARGER
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS AS WELL AS
TARGETED SUPPORT GROUPS. WE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
SUCCESSFUL LAUNCH IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- WE WOULD NOTE I'D
ADD THIS WILL REQUIRE TRAILER
BILL AS MENTIONED AND IDENTIFIED
AND WE ARE HOPING TO RELEASE
THAT TRAILER BILL AS SOON. AS
POSSIBLE THIS CONCLUDES MY
COMMENT. NEXT WE WILL HEAR FOR
KOREA HOW SHE'D I WITH THE L.
THANK DOCTOR REGULATORY WITH THE
L. A. L. I'M ON THIS ISSUE WE
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THE- TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL THAT WAS MADE AVAILABLE
TODAY AND- WE WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IF WE HAVE.
ANY CONCERNS OR COMMENTS TO
RAISE ABOUT PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
I WILL BRING IT TO THE TIRES TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS.
C. NON I WILL THANK VERY MUCH
PANEL NINE WILL MOVE ON THE
PANEL TEN. ON DISCONTINUING THE
CHILD HEALTH AND DISABILITY
PROGRAM. AND EXPANDING THE
CHILDREN'S PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY. WE WILL HAVE J. C.
COOPER CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
DH THE S. BEGIN. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU- SO NEED OUR
CHILDREN HEALTH AND DISABILITY
PREVENTION PROGRAM PROVIDES
SCREENING AND FOLLOW UP SERVICES
AS WELL AS CARE COORDINATION FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE WHO ARE ENROLLED
IN THE FEW FOR SERVICE MEDICARE
PROGRAM ADDITIONALLY IT PROVIDES
C. H. D. P. GATEWAY WHICH SERVES
AS A PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY
ENTRY POINT FOR CHILDREN AND
LOCAL ADMINISTRATION OF THE
HEALTH CARE PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE. AND THE CHILD
HOOD LEAD POISONING PREVENTION
PROGRAM IS DONE BY THE CCP
PROGRAM AND TEAMS LOCALLY I IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO G.
ACS AS A PART OF ITS CALAIS
MANAGED IT BEGAN TRANSITIONING
NON DUAL ELIGIBLE MEDICARE
POPULATIONS INTO MANAGED CARE OF
THIS INCLUDES- THE MAJORITY OF
CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE A BY JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE MOST
CHILDREN AND YOUTH UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY ONE WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. WILL BE ENROLLED IN A
MANAGED CARE PLAN TODAY ABOUT
HALF OF THE FOSTER CARE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH RECEIVE SERVICES
THROUGH THE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE
PROGRAMS AND HALF RECEIVE
SERVICES THROUGH MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS FOSTER CARE
CHILDREN ARE THE ONLY REMAINING
POPULATION OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH
THAT WILL NOT BE FULLY
TRANSITIONED INTO MANAGED CARE
HOWEVER THIS POPULATION IS
COVERED UNDER THE HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE A WHICH WILL REMAIN ON AS A
STANDALONE PROGRAM WHEN I C. H.
T. T. SUNSETS. OUT ONCE THE FEE
FOR SERVICE TO MANAGED CARE
TRANSITION IS COMPLETE IT WILL
NO LONGER BE NECESSARY TO RETAIN
THE COMPONENTS OF THE CHD BROWN
SAYS THE MANAGED CARE PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO COVER ALL MEDICALLY
NECESSARY PREVENTATIVE SERVICES
FOR CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND THE
CDP PROGRAM IS FOCUSED ON FEE
FOR SERVICE SERVICES. THEREFORE
THE DEPARTMENT IS PROPOSING TO
SUNSET AT THE AT THE CHILD AND
HELP DISABILITY PREVENTION
PROGRAM- BY JULY ONE OF. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IN ORDER TO
SIMPLIFY AND STREAMLINE THE
DELIVER OUR SYSTEM TO. YOU UNDER
THE AGE OF ONE. ON EACH IS
PROPOSAL TO SUNSET PHD PRO. WERE
WILL. WILL NOT AFFECT AT YOU
PSTG SERVICES AS THEY ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO BE COVERED
BOTH THE MEDICARE FEE FOR
SERVICE AND MANAGED CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS. MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
CARE COORDINATION TO CHILDREN
AND YOUTH UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY ONE. INCLUDING A
GUARANTEED APPROPRIATE AND
TIMELY ACCESS TO ALL NEEDED
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER DEVELOPMENTAL
DENTAL SOCIAL AND EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS COORDINATING
REFERRALS TO NON COVERED
SERVICES. MANY OF MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE ALSO REQUIRED TO
ASSESS THE NEEDS OF CHILDREN AND
YOUTH FOR SCREENINGS- SUCH AS
ADVERSE CHILD. EXPERIENCES AND
DEPLOY STRATEGIES TO MITIGATE
IMPACTS OF SOCIAL DRIVERS OF
HELP INCLUDING THE COORDINATION
OF COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. AND
OTHER APPROPRIATE RESOURCES.
OFFER POSH CARE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH NOT ENROLLED IN A MANAGED
CARE PLAN SYSTEMIC COORDINATION
OF SERVICES AND COMPREHENSIVE
CARE MANAGEMENT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE PROVIDED THROUGH THE HEALTH
CARE PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN. IN
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM FURTHERMORE
THE PROPOSAL WILL NOT IMPACT THE
EXISTING PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY
FUNCTIONS- ALSO KNOWN AS THE HDP
GATEWAY I DCS COOPER ARE
PROPOSES TO PRESERVE THE
AUTOMATED PRE ENROLLMENT PROCESS
FOR NON MEDICARE ALL. UNINSURED
CHILDREN CURRENTLY KNOWN AS AS
THE HDP GATEWAY AND TRANSITION
THIS FUNCTION TO A NEW
CHILDREN'S PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY PROGRAM. THE TRUCK
THAT CHILDREN'S PRESUMPTIVE LG
PROGRAM WILL EXPAND TO ALL
APPLICABLE MEDIC HELP PROVIDERS
WHEREAS THE CURRENT PROGRAM IS
ONLY FOR CHD P. PROVIDERS.
THEREBY PERMITTING MORE
PROVIDERS TO MAKE PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS AND
EXPANDING ACCESS TO MEDICAL
SERVICES FOR MORE CHILDREN IN
USE. ALLOWING ALL APPLICABLE
MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO DETERMINE A
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY WILL
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE COVERAGE TO
MORE CHILDREN NOT YET ENROLLED
IN MEDI CAL OR WHO WERE
PREVIOUSLY DISTANT ROLLED HER
DROPPED FROM MEDIC HELL. IN
INCREASE OVERALL. ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH FURTHERMORE
DH CS PERSON ARE PROPOSES TO
PRESERVE THE- OF THE HEALTH CARE
PROGRAM FOR CHILDREN IN FOSTER
YOUTH AS MENTIONED EARLIER. I'M
AS A STANDALONE PROGRAM IN
TRANSITION ON CERTAIN COMPONENTS
OF THE CHILD LEAD. POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM FROM AT AT
TWO MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS.
LASTLY IT WOULD KNOW THAT THE
TARGETED CASE MANAGEMENT WILL
REMAIN AVAILABLE AND COUNTIES
THAT HAVE CHOSEN TO PARTICIPATE
AND PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES
COVERED UNDER THE STATE PLAN. D.
H. U. S. AS A PART OF ITS FULL
PROPOSAL DEVELOPED A DETAILED ON
CCP PROGRAM RESPONSIBILITY
CROSSWALK WHICH INCLUDES A
COMPLETE AND DETAILED LIST OF
ALL EXISTING CHP REQUIREMENTS
CROSSWALK WITH THE ACS PROPOSED. OUTCOMES IN TRANSITION SAN
DIEGO CS IS WORKING FORWARD
RELEASE THIS BOOK IS AS- SO THE
LEAD. IN AND NOW DO THE IN OUR
ON THE CROSS OF ALL. REGARDING
THE ESTIMATED PERCENTAGE OF
CHILDREN ELIGIBLE- ARE MEDICARE
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT
ENROLLED IN MEDICAID HOW THERE'S
A QUESTION IN THE GENDER
REGARDING THIS IDEA YES DOES NOT
COLLECT. THESE DATA ELEMENTS IN
GENERAL MEETING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE BUT NOT ENROLLED IS
CHALLENGING THING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO. A TYPICALLY
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTIONS
INVOLVE LOOKING AT SURVEY DATA
ON DEVELOPING PROJECTIONS IN
MOST OFTEN DONE BY RESEARCHERS
I'M MUCH OF ONE SUCH EXTERNAL
RESEARCH STUDY DONE BY THE URBAN
INSTITUTE INDICATES THAT. ARE
ABOUT NINETY FOUR POINT 6% OF
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN ARE ENROLLED
IN MEDICAID HOW- WE HOPE TO
RELEASES TRAILER BILL AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND THIS. REMAINS ARE
MY COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF WILL BRING IT
UP TO THE DAY FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
I WILL KEEP IT HERE THE CHAIR
RIGHT I WANTED TO BRING UP SOME-
RECENTLY RECEIVED COUNTY
CONCERNS THAT WE- HAD REGARDING
THIS PROPOSAL. PARTICULARLY
RELATED TO THE ELIMINATION OF
THE C. H. T. P. WILL HAVE ON
DENTAL CARE. CURRENTLY PROVIDED
THROUGH THE C. H. T. P. CAN YOU
PLEASE DESCRIBE THE IMPACT AND
ASSURE THAT NO SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN. WILL BE LOST AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROPOSAL. S.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- QUESTION AS
THOUGH OUR MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
REFERRALS FOR DENTAL SERVICES WE
ALSO- REQUIRED THAT OUR DENTAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND THROUGH
DENTAL FEE FOR SERVICE S. B. PER
SERVICE ORCHESTRA INTERMEDIARY.
ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGING WITH
INDIVIDUALS IN REGARDS TO NEEDED
DENTAL SERVICES- AND ADDS
MENTION BUT THE MAJORITY IF NOT
ALL CHILDREN TRANSITIONING TO A
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS- WE%
DO SEE THIS AS DUPLICATIVE
ASCENTS CHILDREN WILL NOT BE IN
VIEW FOR SERVICE- IN THE FUTURE-
MAJORITY MOVING TO MANAGED CARE.
WHICH IS REALLY AROUND
STREAMLINING OUR SYSTEMS AND
ENSURING BUT REALLY MAKING SURE
THAT WE ARE HOLDING OUR PLANS.
AND OUR DENTAL PRODUCTS YOU KNOW
MANAGED CARE PLANS AND DENTAL
FEE FOR SERVICE PROVIDERS- AND
ADVOCATES FOR ALSO INSURING
REFERRALS TO DENTAL SERVICES.
CURRENTLY ARE. CHD PROGRAMS. IN
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OUTREACH
AND- MARKETING TO HELP TO BRING
FAMILIES INTO THE PROGRAM. UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY ONLY OCCURS AS A
PERSON IS ALREADY IN THE CARE OF
A PROVIDER. AND I'M WANTING TO
ASK HOW DOES DH CS PLAN TO
ADDRESS THIS GAP AN OUTREACH- SO
I ONE THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT
RIGHT NOW IT'S VERY LIMITED
PROGRAM IT'S ONLY FOUR CHD P.
PROVIDERS WHO CAN DO THAT
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY A
GATEWAY SCREENING WHICH IS VERY
FEW A NUMBER OF PROVIDERS AND-
IF MY TEAM CAN SEND ME THAT THE
NUMBER THAT WOULD BE REALLY
GREAT- WE ARE. PROPOSING TO
EXPAND ON THE CHILDREN
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO ALL
MEDICAL PROVIDERS WHO ARE
WILLING TO YOU KNOW MEET THE
NEEDS- THE EXPECTATIONS OF
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY WHICH IS
NOT DIFFICULT A HUGE NUMBER-
PARTICIPATE IN OUR HOSPITAL
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE BUT THE PROGRAMS
JUST TO NARROW WE'RE NOT HITTING
ALL OF THE CHILDREN IN REGARDS
TO PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY. SO
WE THINK BY EXPANDING TO ALL
MEDICARE OUT OF PROVIDERS TO DO
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY WE WILL
BE ABLE TO CATCH A LARGER NUMBER
OF CHILDREN AND YOUTH WHO NEED
TO BE ENROLLED INTO MEDIC CAL-
IN BE BROADLY WORK ACROSS ALL
AREAS ADVOCATES ARE WORKING TO
HELP COLLECTIVELY INFORM.
INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR RIGHTS TO
HAVE MEDICAL SERVICES ON IN SO
REALLY WE DO THINK THIS WILL
GREATLY BENEFIT CHILDREN'S AND
YOUTH ACCESS TO MEDICAL SERVICES
MY TEAM IS JOHNNY ON THE SPOT
I'M IN THERE ARE ONLY TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FIFTEEN
ACTIVE OF PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE C. H. T. P.
EIGHT M. GATEWAY PROGRAM. AND WE
HAVE A YOUNG TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF MEDICAL PROVIDERS WHO COULD
HELP US ACCESS MORE CHILDREN IN
GET INCREASED IN ROAMING
pYOUTH AND SO WE DO THINK THIS IS
A VERY POSITIVE. PROPOSAL UP FOR
CONSIDERATION. WE WILL. UP WE
CAN- PUBLIC WHERE WE WERE ASKED
OUR QUESTION AND WITH THAT WE
WILL THANK VERY MUCH PANEL TEN.
AND MOVE ON THE PANEL ELEVEN ON
THE REDUCTIONS TO MEDICAL
PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS. WE WILL
HAVE TO PRESENTERS ON THIS PANEL
BEGINNING WITH CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR JC COOPER WITH DH CS.
FOLLOWED BY LUKE KASH MORROW
WITH THE L. A. O. LET US BEGIN
WITH CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
COOPER. THANK YOU ALL REGARDING
THE REDUCTION TO PREMIUMS TO
ZERO DOLLARS THE BUDGET REQUEST
OF FIFTY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
TOTAL FUNDS. IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND EIGHTY NINE MILLION TOTAL
FUND ON GOING TO REDUCE THE
PREMIUMS OF OUR PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS CHILDREN AND WORKING
DISABLED PROGRAMS TO ZERO
DOLLARS EFFECTIVE JULY ONE OF
TWENTY TWO- THIS PROPOSAL COVERS
ALL MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
CURRENTLY OPINION PAYING
PREMIUMS AND COPAYMENTS. ARE THE
THIS AT A PREMIUM REQUIREMENT
PLACES AN UNDUE ECONOMIC BURDEN
ON INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
THAT. ARE ALREADY LIVING ON
LIMITED INCOMES- AND ARE
RESTRICTED- IN THE PURSUIT OF
SUBSTANTIAL- A GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT DUE TO A DISABILITY-
MONTHLY PREMIUM PAYMENT
REQUIREMENTS CREATE BARRIERS IN
ACCESS TO CARE. AND CAN LEAD TO
UNNECESSARY BREAKS IN COVERAGE
FOR ELIGIBLE. INDIVIDUALS THE
POPULATIONS INCLUDED IN THIS
PREMIUM- REDUCTIONS ZERO UNGLUED
THE OPTIONAL TARGET LOW INCOME
CHILDREN PROGRAM- PREMIUMS ARE
IMPOSED FOR EACH ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN UNDER NINETEEN YEARS OF
AGE WHOSE FAMILY INCOME IS
DETERMINED TO BE ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY PERCENT. INTERRUPTS
YOU INCLUDING A HUNDRED AND 66%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL IT
ALSO INCLUDES THE GEORGIAN 50%
WORKING DISABLED PROGRAM
PREMIUMS AREN'T PROS FOR WORKING
DISABLED INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
INCOME IS DETERMINED TO BE UP TO
AND INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
PERCENT. OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL ON INCLUDES THE CHILDREN
HELP THAT ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS
ARE CHIP PROGRAMS ARE PREMIUMS
ARE IMPOSED FOR CHILDREN UNDER
NINETEEN YEARS OF AGE WHOSE
FAMILY INCOME IS ABOVE. 162% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL AND
INCLUDING THREE HUNDRED AND 22%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL
THIS PROGRAM COVERS CHILDREN IN
SAN FRANCISCO SAN MATEO AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTIES. WE ALSO
INCLUDED THE MEDI CAL ACCESS
PROGRAM OR- AND CAPPED A
PREMIUMS ARE IMPOSED FOR
PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS WITH
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY. 113% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL BUT NOT TO
EXCEED AT THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
TWO PERCENT. AND LASTLY THE
MEDICARE ACCESS AND THE PROGRAM
INFANTS BORN INTO THE EMPOWER
PROGRAM- ENROLLED INDIVIDUALS-
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THAT PROGRAM.
IN REGARDS TO THE REDUCTION OF
COPAYMENTS TO USE ZERO DOLLARS
OF THE BUDGET ADVANCES A
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE ALL
COPAYMENTS IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM TWO ZERO DOLLARS AFTER
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWO. TO BRING
THE DEPARTMENT- INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS I'M ALL
INDIVIDUALS ENROLLED IN MEDICARE
FEE FOR SERVICE ARE SUBJECT TO
NOMINAL COPAYMENTS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE FOLLOWING
FOSTER CHILDREN PREGNANT
INDIVIDUALS AND CHILDREN UNDER.
THE YEARS OF AGE OF NINETEEN. I
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS TO PAY AN ARM ON ALL
NON INFO. COPAYMENT FOR COME
SERVICES. MEDICARE BENEFITS MAY
BE CHOI BY- IN THE PROVIDER
RETAINS THE COPAYMENT WHEN
SERVICES ARE RENDERED A CO MAKE
A CO PAYMENTS ARE NOT PASSED TO
THE DEPARTMENT. OF THE
DEPARTMENT IS SEEKING TO REDUCE
COPAYMENTS- IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM TWO ZERO- IN AN EFFORT
TO REMOVE ANY POTENTIAL BARRIERS
TO ACCESS TO CARE IN TO AVOID
COSTLY SYSTEM CHANGES OTHERWISE
NEEDED TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS. ARE
CURRENTLY PROVIDERS MAY NOT DENY
CARE TO BENEFICIARIES UNABLE TO
PAY COPAYMENTS- AT THIS TIME AT
THE TIME OF THE APPOINTMENT
MEANING THERE'S LITTLE RATIONALE
FOR MAINTAINING THE NOMINAL NON
ENFORCEABLE. REQUIREMENTS FOR CO
PAYMENTS AT THE STATE DOES NOT
RECEIVE ANY REVENUE BASED ON THE
COLLECTION OF COPAYMENTS AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY. FINALLY
OUR CHANGES TO VERY SYSTEMS TO
EFFECTUATE THE TRACKING OF
COPAYMENTS WOULD OF PRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT COST ARE THERE FOR
DH CS ARE DETERMINED IT WOULD
NOT BE COST EFFECTIVE OR
BENEFICIAL TO BUILD A SYSTEM TO
TRACK COPAYMENTS. REDUCING
COPAYMENTS WHAT ARE WHAT
ALLEVIATE THE NEED FOR THE
TRACKING SYSTEM TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL REGULATIONS- THAT IS.
THE CONCLUSION OF MY COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME. NEXT TO HEAR FROM THE
L. L. THANK YOU AND WE WILL BE
PROVIDING A MORE DETAILED
ASSESSMENT OPINION PRO IS ALL IN
THE COMING WEEKS ASPART OF A
PUBLICATION ON HEALTHCARE ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY- ON HOW WE DO
ONE OR TWO ISSUES THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL FIRST THE
MINISTRATIONS BEST COSTUME TO
NOT ASSUME THAT THERE IS A CASE
OF INCREASED. AS A RESULT OF THE
PREMIUM REDUCTIONS. AND THEY'VE
NOTED THAT THEY SEEM THE IMPACT
WOULD BE RELATIVELY MINOR
DIFFICULT ESTIMATE I WOULD BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF STUDIES WE
REVIEWED WE THINK THAT WE WERE
USING THE PREMIUMS WOULD LIKELY
RESULT IN AT LEAST SOME AMOUNT
OF INCREASE ENROLLMENT WELL
THERE IS CONSIDERABLE
UNCERTAINTY. NEW ENROLLMENT I
TOLD REDUCING PREMIUMS AT ZERO
COULD RESULT IN INCREASED
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. OR HIGHER
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS. IN
BECAUSE ALSO TO GET. ON ARE ROLE
FROM THE PRO. AND LET PAY. YOU
IS YOUR FOR THEIR- ABLE TO
REGIONAL. POLITICAL WANT TO ASK
THE MINISTER HOW THIS POLICY
IMPACT THESE HOUSE. FOR EXAMPLE
A PREMIUM ARE REDUCED ZERO WHEN
THESE. DON'T NEED TO PAY BACK
ANY PAST IN PREMIUMS. ON BEFORE
THEY CAN RECALL IN MEDICARE.
ÓRDENES DEBTS BEFORE GIVEN. AN
OVERALL WE DO RECOMMEND TO
APPROVE THIS PROPOSAL I WILL BE
FORGIVEN SO WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE REQUEST AT THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. FROM THE
MINISTRATION. BUT THE TRUMP OF
THE RIGHT. FROM INCLUDING FOR
KESSLER. IMPACT AND MICHELIN POP
POLICY WOULD HAVE FAMILIES GOT
PAST DUE TO. ENTER OF THAT
COOKING TVS WE ARE REVIEWING
BILLING- DID NOT COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'LL BRING
IT UP TO THE DIE WILL BEGIN WITH
DOCTOR. THANK YOU EFFORT
PRESENTATION AND IS JUST A
QUESTION I GUESS- WE'RE LOOKING
AT IN THE CONTEXT OF
AFFORDABILITY- ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS IS BEING ADDRESSED- IS
ADDRESSING THE SHOW- MEDICAL
SHARE COST- I. AM I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT THE MAINTENANCE NEED
INCOME LEVEL I BELIEVE THIS
AMOUNT HASN'T BEEN ADJUTED AND
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
I BELIEVE DOCTOR REGULAR HAS A
BILL AND- INTRODUCED ON THIS
TOPIC- IF WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE. GET HEALTH CARE
SOONER- YET THEY'RE STILL
REQUIRED TO SPEND DOWN TO THIS
MAINTENANCE INCOME LEVEL- NEED
INCOME LEVEL THAT HASN'T BEEN
ADJUSTED FOR PROBABLY FORTY
YEARS- CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY THIS
WASN'T PROPOSED A I. THE GOAL IS
TO GET GOOD HEALTH ANCHOR AT
OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE AND HERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT SO
WHAT AM I MISSING. THIS IS FOR
ME PRINCE MISTER FOR NOT FOR THE
LA OFFICE SO. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR QUESTION I THINK
YOU KNOW AS WE EVALUATED A
NUMBER OF AREAS- ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN THE WAVING OF
PREMIUMS WHERE WE ZEROED IN IN
REGARDS TO PROPOSING. ARE THE
ELIMINATION OF PREMIUMS ARE
MOVING FORWARD- I THINK I WOULD
ALSO JUST SAY BE DEFINITELY.
KNOWLEDGE YOUR COMMENTS
REGARDING A MAINTENANCE NEED
IT'S CURRENTLY NOT A PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL BUT
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT IT IS ANOTHER
AREA. OF FOCUS. LET ME JUST
POINT I MEAN WE'RE DEALING WITH
THESE ARE THIS IS DEALING WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISABLED. OR FOR
PERSONS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE SO THESE ARE THESE ARE YOU
KNOW MORE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND SO- TECHNICALLY POSSIBLY
HAVE A GREATER NEED FOR HEALTH
CARE SO IT I'M SORRY DOES THAT
PART DOESN'T MAKE SENSE I HOPE
THAT WE COULD CONSIDER AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THAT IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
WILL FOLLOW UP ON ONE QUESTION
FOR THE DEPARTMENT- REGARDING
THE COPAYMENTS- THERE WAS A-
DEPARTMENTAL FACT SHEET FROM DH
CS. I WAS HOPING TO UNDERSTAND
THE RATIONALE FOR QUOTE UNLESS
REINSTATED FOR ANY IMPACTED
STATE FISCAL YEAR END QUOTE. IF
THE COPAYMENTS GO TO PROVIDERS
AS YOU MENTIONED AND NOT TOWARDS
DH CS. WHY WOULD IT MATTER WHAT
THE STATE FISCAL YEAR IS LIKE. I
THINK THAT'S JUST- I YOU KNOW
ENSURING THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE LANGUAGE IS NOT ELIMINATING
COPAYMENTS IT'S RESERVE REDUCING
THE COPAYMENT DOLLAR AMOUNTS TO
ZERO I'M SO IF AND WHEN OR IF IN
THE FUTURE THERE IS A NEED TO RE
INSTITUTE COPAYMENTS. ARE THAT
THAT WOULD BE ALLOWABLE UNDER
STATE STATUTE. THANK THE ONLY
POINT I'M TRYING TO REITERATE IS
THE ONE YOU MADE TO US WHICH IS
THE STATE DOESN'T RECEIVE
BENEFIT FROM THESE. COPAYMENTS
AND SO WIDE IS OUR FISCAL
CONDITION FOR THE STATE MATTER
AND THUS WHY ARE WE USING THAT
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IS. THE ORIGIN
OF THE QUESTION HAPPY TO FOLLOW
UP MCCARTY TO. YEAH I KNOW I- I
THINK RIGHT NOW- I THINK THAT
MAJORITY OF OUR COPAYMENTS OR
DOLLAR FIVE FOR EXAMPLE- BUT IN
THE FUTURE IF THEIR WORD TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY. OR OTHER ON DECISIONS
THAT PEOPLE NEEDED TO MAKE YOU
COULD PROPOSE A HIGHER COPAYMENT
ON THAT MAY BE MORE IMPACTFUL
BUT CURRENTLY IT IS NOT
IMPACTFUL FROM A BUDGETARY
PERSPECTIVE. AGAIN WOULD NOTE
THOUGH IF WE WERE TO DO THAT IT
WOULD REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN REGARDS TO COSTS
AND SYSTEMS TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS- AS WELL SO IT WOULD
BE COSTLY- I TAKE TO IMPLEMENT
IN THE FUTURE AND SO AT THIS
TIME. ARE RECOMMENDING BRINGING
THOSE DOWN TO ZERO AND THE
KNOWLEDGE IN YOUR COMMENTS
COMPLETELY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIRD PANEL NUMBER ELEVEN WE
WILL MOVE ON THE PANEL TWELVE ON
THE HEARING AID COVERAGE. FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM WE WILL HAVE A
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR J. C.
COOPER FROM DH CS BEGIN. CAN WE
BEGIN- CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
COOPER. THANK YOU- SO ENACTED IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM IS A STATE ONLY
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE SERVICES
FOR HEARING AIDS TO NON MEDIC
CAL CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO
SEVENTEEN WHO ARE UNINSURED- OR
WHO HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE THAT
DOES NOT COVER HEARING AIDS- AT
AND SERVICES I WOULD THE FAMILY
INCOME NOT TO EXCEED 6100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL ON THE
PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED ON JULY ONE
OF. TWENTY- ON JULY FIRST- THE
PRIOR TO THE LAUNCH- IN A JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY AN ONGOING OF
THE ACS HAS BEEN BEING
STAKEHOLDER WORK. TO INFORM THE
APPLICATION PROCESS- REFINED THE
BENEFIT STRUCTURE AND ONGOING
PROGRAM- ENHANCEMENTS I'M DH CS
WILL CONTINUE TO UTILIZE
EXISTING HEARING AID COVERAGE OF
FOR CHILDREN PROGRAM. MEDI CAL
NCCS AUDIOLOGY POLICIES TO GUIDE
THE PROGRAM STRUCTURE I'M
INCLUDING COVERAGE OF ON THE
VARIOUS SERVICES AVAILABLE IN
THE PROGRAM. MEDI CAL AND ROLLED
UP PROVIDERS I CAN BILL MEDICARE
ALL THROUGH THE FISCAL
INTERMEDIARY REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PROVIDING SERVICES UNDER THE NEW
BENEFIT IS THE SAME AS MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENTS. AS OF FEBRUARY
TENTH AT TWENTY TWENTY TO FORTY
FOUR CHILDREN ARE ENROLLED IN
THE PROGRAM MAXIMUS IS CURRENTLY
REACHING OUT TO TWENTY ONE
ADDITIONAL FAMILIES WHO
SUBMITTED PARTIAL APPLICATIONS.
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN MISSING
INFORMATION AND COMPLETE
ELIGIBILITY REVIEW AND
ENROLLMENT FOR THESE CHILDREN.
DMCS STAFF HAVE BEEN INFORMED OF
SEVERAL CHILDREN. WHO HAVE
ALREADY RECEIVED- OR ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING SERVICES
THROUGH THE PROGRAM ARE HOWEVER
DCS IS NOT ABLE TO ASCERTAIN THE
COMPLETE AND CURRENT NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SERVED I DO TELL THE
DELAYS BETWEEN A PROVIDER AND
USUALLY OUT RENDERING THE
SERVICE. EMITTING A CLAIM TO THE
DEPARTMENT. OF BILLING CODES FOR
THE PROGRAM'S COVERED BENEFITS
ARE A PUBLISHED IN NINETEEN OUR
DH CS IS WEBSITE THE CODES ARE
ALSO AVAILABLE FOR PROVIDERS TO
BUILD. A TODAY A DCS ARE UPDATES
THAT HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN PROGRAM COVERED BILLING
CODES ON A ROLLING BASIS AS
CODES ARE ADDED AND REVISED FOR
COMPLIANCE FOR BASED O FURTHER
MEDICAL RESEARCH AND SUBJECT TO
THE SCOPE OF THE PROGRAM-
AUTHORITIES. THE ACS ESTIMATES.
THAT THERE WILL BE ON A NUMBER-
A FEW PUBLIC- IN NEW. AT THAT
WILL BE ADDED BETWEEN. AND MAY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AT THE TO
YOUR WE- AND PROGRAM MATERIAL
WILL BE TO ALIGN THOSE SYSTEM
EDIT COMPLETIONS- ALTHOUGH THE
SYSTEM AT ITS WILL TAKE A FEW
MONTHS TO FINALIZE THAT MAY OF
TWENTY TWO TIME PERIODS- A
TREATMENT AUTHORIZATION REQUESTS
OR WHAT WE CALL IT'S- OURS. A
MAY BE SUBMITTED IN THE INTERIM
OF CLAIMS WILL BE PAYABLE
RETROACTIVELY TO THE EFFECTIVE
DATE OF JULY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- ONCE THE SYSTEM
EDITS ARE COMPLETE- ADDITION.
THE ACA CAN TO ENGAGE WITH
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES AND THEIR
CURRENT PROVIDERS TO FACILITATE
PROGRAM OF REFERRALS IN THE
FOLLOWING WAY. THE APPLICATIONS
AND INFORMATIONAL MATERIALS ARE
INCLUDED ALONGSIDE SIMILAR CCS
MATERIALS- WITH INFANTS ARE
REFERRED FOR A HEARING RELATED
SERVICES THROUGH. THE CALIFORNIA
NEWBORN HEARING SCREENING
PROGRAM- DH CS COLLABORATES WITH
FAMILY ORIENTED TO STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS TO PROVIDE APPLICANT
FACING RESOURCES- IN WITH
PROVIDER ORIENTED STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS IN
REFERRING PATIENTS TO THE
PROGRAM AS APPROPRIATE- AND
ADDITIONALLY DH CS RECENTLY
EXTENDED. THE TIME ALLOWED TO A
TOTAL OF SIXTY DAYS FOR
APPLICANTS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO COMPLETE AN
ACTIVE APPLICATION OF RATHER.
THAN NEEDING TO RE APPLY. I'M
ADDITION. ARE YOU KNOW THE
PROGRAM- FIND A PROVIDER WEB
PAGE INCLUDES MEDI CAL PROVIDERS
CCS PROVIDERS AND HIGHLIGHTS A
COMMUNICATION DISORDER CLINICS
ARE WHILE THE AB PROGRAM
PROVIDER DIRECTORY HIGHLIGHTS.
OF IT TO PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
INDICATED THEIR INTEREST IN
ESTABLISHING NEW PATIENTS WITHIN
THE PROGRAM WE CONTINUE TO
EMPHASIZE THAT OTHER CCS ANTI
FOR SERVICE MEDICARE PROVIDERS
REMAIN ELIGIBLE TO PROVIDE COVER
BENEFITS UNDER THIS PROGRAM I TO
CHILDREN IN OBTAINING
REIMBURSEMENTS. OPTING INTO THE-
THE PROVIDER DIRECTORIES NOT
REQUIRED AND DOES NOT REFLECT
THE ENTIRE SCOPE OF PROVIDER
ENGAGEMENT. IN THIS PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY A DH CS HAS TAKEN
SEVERAL STEPS TO SUPPORT TIMELY
ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE CARE OF
POOR CHILDREN ENROLLED IN THIS
PROGRAM SECURING FLEXIBILITY
AFTER FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE NOT JUST A CERTAIN SUBSET OF
PROVIDERS. TO REFER RENDER-
HACCP COVERED BENEFITS WITHIN
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE INTO A
TEEN REIMBURSEMENT FOR THESE
GOODS AND SERVICES THROUGH THE
FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE SYSTEM
LEVERAGING PROVIDERS FAMILIARITY
WITH EXISTING DEEPER SERVICE
MEDIC HELPED PARKS AND CLAIM A
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
REDUCE DELAYS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE LEARNING CURVE. IN PROVIDER
ONBOARDING. OFFERING PUBLIC
PROVIDER WEBINARS TAILORED
TRAINING QUALITY OUR Q. AND A
SESSIONS FOR MEDICAL TEAMS
PROVIDER NETWORKS EDUCATION
MATERIALS AND DIRECTING FIERY
SUPPORT. ADDITIONALLY WE
PUBLISHING THE PROGRAM SPECIFIC
PROVIDER DIRECTORY A TO
HIGHLIGHT MEDIC HOW AND WILL
PROVIDERS WITH RELEVANT
EXPERTISE- WHO HAVE THE FOR ME
AT LEAST A SIGNALED THEIR
INTEREST. IN PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM. AT THE CS ARE HAS
BEEN LEVERAGING OUR EXISTING
CLIENTS WHICH WERE ME. CHEAPER
THE SAME SERVICES FOR THIS
PROGRAM AS IT DOES FOR THE
OPTIONAL TARGETED LOW INCOME I
CHILDREN PROGRAM PERFORMING AT
PERFORMING CASE INTAKE BY
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS TO
APPROVE DENY RECIPIENTS- IN
ANNUAL RE CERTIFICATION OF
ELIGIBILITY OF THE COME WITH A
BROAD BACKGROUND OF EXPERIENCE
THAT PEOPLE ARE USED TO AND
FAMILIAR WITH IN OUR CURRENT.
PROGRAM THE OP ALSO OPERATE A
CALL CENTRE DEVELOP REQUIRED
INFORMING AND OTHER RELATED
MATERIALS NINETEEN A DATABASE
FOR CASE MANAGEMENT PURPOSES IN
CONDUCT PROGRAM MONITORING AND
OVERSIGHT AS WELL AS THE NEEDED
RECORDING. UTILIZING AMENDMENTS
WITH EXIT OUR CONTRACTOR MAXIMUS
WHO HAS YEARS OF EXPERIENCE WITH
MANAGING VULNERABLE MEDICAL
POPULATIONS IN INCORPORATING
THIS PROGRAM INTO THEIR EXISTING
COLLABORATION WITH THE ACS
FACILITATED SPEED AT ALLOWED US
TO REALLY GET SPEECH AT TO
MARKET ON THIS PROGRAM. MAXIMUS
HAS BROUGHT ADDITION A
DEPLOYMENT COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM
SUPPORT MILIARDY WITH THE ACS
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS POLICIES
AND SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
DEDICATION TO UNDERSTANDING THE
APPLICANT NEEDS AND CONCERNS TO
ENABLE THE TIMELY DEVELOPMENT
AND LAUNCH OF THE PROGRAM BY
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
PREVIOUSLY I SAID TWENTY TWENTY
HOWEVER ARE THE DATE IS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I AND THIS CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WILL BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE DIET AND SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS I WILL- KEEP. IT WITH
THE CHAIR- I'M GONNA BE- BY
TRYING TO AND- OUR PLAN TO BOTH
INCREASE CHILD ENROLLMENT AND
PARTICIPATION. AND HOW WE CAN
HELP TO SUPPORT TIMELY ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE PEDIATRIC CARE. HAS
ITS APPARENT FROM THE
ENROLLMENTS WE'VE SEEN SO FAR
THAT THERE. ARE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT CAN BE MADE AND I'M HOPING
THE DEPARTMENT CAN- SHARE WITH
US PLANS GOING FORWARD. YES SO
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO A
ROOMMATE AT RENEE MAILLOUX WHO
CAN ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE PROGRAM. SO SORRY
ABOUT THAT. HELLO AND MEMBERS
FOR NAY MODEL DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HEALTHCARE BENEFITS AND
ELIGIBILITY SO AS WE NEED TO
WORK WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
AS WE HEAR ABOUT I'M CURIOUS
HAVE INTEREST OR OUR
CONSIDERATION PARTNERS PROGRAM
WE DO TAKE THAT UNDER
ADVISEMENT- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY TO DO HERE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE CHILDREN UNDER THE MEDICAID
HEALTH PROGRAM FOR EQUALLY
AVAILABLE TO THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE INVOLVED IN THIS PROGRAM. SO
WE DO MAINTAIN REGULAR
COMMUNICATIONS WHAT
STAKEHOLDERS- WE DID HAVE A
DEDICATED STAKEHOLDER WORKGROUP
I HAVE TRANSITION THAT OVER TO
OUR CONSUMER FOCUS OF WORKGROUP
WHERE THERE IS TIME ON THE
AGENDA TO HEAR ABOUT CONCERNS OF
THE ADVOCATES AND THEN TO TAKE
THAT INFORMATION BACK AND THEN
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
PROGRAM. AREAS WHERE WE CAN DO-
ON IMPROVEMENTS IN SAY THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WE DO OF ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THAT PROCESS
SO IT'S AN ONGOING PROCESS AN
EVOLUTION WITH THIS PROGRAM AND
WE WILL AND WE DO REMAIN
COMMITTED IN TERMS OF WORKING
WITH OUR STATE LOCAL PARK AT
PARTNERS IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
MAINTENANCE OF THIS PROPER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I WOULD
JUST HIGHLIGHTED ON PAGE FIFTY
SEVEN OF THE AGENDA AT THE VERY
TOP IS A STAKEHOLDER
RECOMMENDATION- TO APPLY THE
MEDIKAL AND CCS STANDARDS FOR
TIMELY ACCESS TO SERVICES THE
PRESUMPTIVE COVERAGE. DURING
APPLICATION REVIEW TO AVOID
DELAYS IN CHILDREN RECEIVING
HEARING AIDS- IS THERE A WAY WE
CAN- IT SHOULD SHOULDN'T WE
BASED ON YOUR LOGIC ALSO BE
APPLYING THAT TO THE- HACCP
PROGRAM. DO YOU WANT ME TO GO. I
WAS A GOOD DAY I JUST WANT TO
REINFORCE THAT WE DO APPLY THOSE
CCS STANDARDS TOO I'M TO THE
REVIEW TODAY BUT BY ALL MEANS
RENEE AT ANY ADDITIONAL DETAIL.
I YOU KNOW I WAS GONNA SAY THE
SAME THING AND- WE CAN TAKE
BACK- UNDER CONSIDERATION THE
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY IT IS
NOT A COMPONENT PART OF THIS
PROGRAM AND BECAUSE IT'S NOT A
MEDICAID PROGRAM SO THERE ARE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT IN TRYING TO LEVERAGE-
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY AND THE
PATHWAYS THAT WE NEED. AB FOR
INDIVIDUALS IN THE- WOULD LOVE
TO FOR UP WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO DO THAT WITH
AND REGULATIONS OR WHETHER OR
NOT YOU WILL NEED A FOLLOW UP-
BILL FOR US. TO WORK ON- BUT-
FURTHER DOWN WITHIN THE
STAKEHOLDER RECOMMENDATIONS IS-
AN IDEA TO CODIFY THE- HEARING
AID COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
PROGRAM INTO STATE STATUTE AND-
AM WONDERING WHY THIS. WAS NOT
DONE THUS FAR. SO YOU KNOW AGAIN
THE PROPOSAL WAS ONE IN TERMS OF
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE PROGRAM
I THINK WHAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR ARE SOME ADDITIONAL-
PROVISIONS AROUND THAT COVERAGE
OPTIONS OF THE PROGRAM BUT WE DO
PUBLISHED THAT PROGRAM POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES. AND HARM MEDICAL
PROVIDER MANUAL AND THAT MANUAL
AND THOSE DATES ARE SHARED
BROADLY WITH THE STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUPS. AND WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND IT DOES OFFER
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO WAIT IN
ENFORCEABLE MAKE MODIFICTIONS
THAT THAT ARE APPROPRIATE BASED. UPON THE STRUCTURE OF THIS
PROGRAM. I'D LIKE TO- THAT WILL
CONCLUDE MY QUESTIONS BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST A COST
ESTIMATE. FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON RAISING THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR BOTH
THIS PROGRAM AND THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM TO MATCH THE RATES
WITHIN THE CCS PROGRAM FOR
HEARING AIDS. AND ANY SERVICES
OFFERED THROUGH THE HACCP AND
I'M HOPING YOU CAN GET US THAT
INFORMATION WHEN AVAILABLE-
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO LOOK THE
ANALYSIS I THINK WE'LL- ENGAGE
WITH YOUR YOUR TEAM MEMBERS I'M
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING TO
UNDERSTAND OF WITH THE PROPOSED
RATE INCREASE WOULD BE I WOULD
JUST THINK KNOWLEDGE THAT-
AUDIO- ART AUDIOLOGY SERVICES IN
HEARING AIDS WAS INCLUDED IN THE
EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN. OF PROPOSAL
MENTIONED EARLIER IN REGARDS TO
ELIMINATING THAT REDUCTION- BUT
WE WILL ENGAGE WITH YOUR TEAMS
TO BETTER UNDERSTAND YOUR
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WILL- NOW MOVE ON THE
PANEL THIRTEEN ON THE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM GRANT PROGRAM
RESTORATION P. C. P. WE WILL
HAVE A CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR G.
C. COOPER BEGAN WITH DHS WHEN
SHE WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU. ALSO THE BUDGET REQUEST
TWELVE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
ONE TIME FUNDING TO RESTORE THE
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM A GRANT
PROGRAM AND FIND A THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS EFFECTIVE
JULY ONE OF TWENTY TWO. OF FUNDS
WILL SUPPORT FORTY FIVE INDIAN
HEALTH CLINIC OF CORPORATIONS IN
RECRUITING AND RETAINING PRIMARY
CARE PROVIDERS I TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE FOR
AMERICAN INDIANS. A RECENT DATA
SHOWS THAT AMERICAN INDIANS
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE LOWER
LIFE EXPECTANCY AND ARE
PROPORTIONATE DISEASE BURDEN
UNPACKED THE HEALTH STATUS OF
CALIFORNIAN INDIAN AMERICAN
INDIANS- IS RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF
THE LOWEST OF ANY ETHNIC GROUP
IN THE STATE. I WITH HIGHER
PREVALENCE OF PRETERM BIRTH
SUICIDE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
I DRUG INDUCED DEATH I DO A
DEATH A DIABETES AND OTHER
CHRONIC DISEASES THAT- THAT ARE
HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION. UPPER THESE FUNDS
SUPPORT THE D. ACS ARE ALREADY
STRATEGY AND GOALS AS OUTLINED
BY DR. BARBARA EARLIER IN THE
DISCUSSIONS- AND ALIGNS AS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY FOCUS ON ACTUAL
HEALTH OUTCOMES WERE VERY. I'M
DH CS I'M HAS ALSO DONE A NUMBER
OF OTHER A PROGRAM INVESTMENTS
IN EFFORTS TO SUPPORT ADDRESS
HEALTH DISPARITIES WITHIN THE
TRIBAL TRIBAL COMMUNITIES.
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF TRIBAL AFFAIRS A DHS
DEVELOPED IN OFFICE OF TRIBAL
AFFAIRS TO SERVE AS THE
PRINCIPAL AND TO TEACH. IN THE
DEPARTMENT TO FACILITATE EARLY
ENGAGEMENT ON POLICY INITIATIVES
IN TO COLLABORATE IN ADDRESSING
THE SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN THIS POPULATION.
I. DAC HAS ALSO MAINTAINS THE
STATE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM I TO
ADDRESS THE COMPARATIVELY LOW
HEALTH STATUS OF AMERICAN
INDIANS IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE-
H. P. PROVIDES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM STATEWIDE TO ENSURE
THEIR ONGOING PARTICIPATION AS
STATING THAT OUR PROVIDERS IN
MEDIC CAL. ADDITIONALLY WE
CONTINUE TO D. A CHIROPRACTIC
SERVICES UNDER THE CALENDAR
SECTION ELEVEN FIFTEEN
DEMONSTRATION OF WHICH ALLOWED
AS- THE REINSTATEMENT. OF THE
TRIBAL UNCOMPENSATED CARE POOL
OF FOR TROUBLE HEALTH PROGRAMS-
WE ALSO ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH CMS IN REGARDS TO ADDING
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
TRADITIONAL HEALERS NATURAL
HARBORS- I HAD TO SERVICES
COVERED UNDER THE DNC OF YES
PROGRAM. I AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY FULLY EMBEDDED OUR
TRIBAL. PARTNERS I'M AND- EQUITY
TARGETS IN REGARDS TO OUR
COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY STRATEGY
AND ARE CURRENTLY SIGNIFICANTLY
ENGAGING WITH OUR TRAVEL
PARTNERS IN REGARDS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM- BUT WE
ALSO COLLEGE. B. H. CHIP WHICH
PROVIDES A COMPETITIVE GRANTS
FOR COUNTIES TRIBAL ENTITIES
NONPROFIT AND FOR PROFIT
ENTITIES TO CONSTRUCT ACQUIRE
AND REHABILITATE REAL ESTATE
ASSETS. OR TO INVEST IN MOBILE
CRISIS INFRASTRUCTURE TO EXPAND
COMMUNITY CONTINUE. ON OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT
REPORT SAYS AS A PART OF THIS
PROGRAM DEPARTMENT RELEASED.
SPECIFIC PLANNING BROW. TO HELP
COUNTY EACH IN TROUBLE AND BY
PLAN. HOW BEST TO A WILL
BEHAVIORAL FACILITY NEEDS ALONG
WITH DEVELOPING STRATEGIES AND
ACTION PLANS TO ADDRESS GAPS IN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES. INTO
DATE ADDED NINE TRIBES HAVE
RECEIVED THOSE PLANNING- GRANT
DOLLARS THROUGH THE B. H. THE I.
P. PROGRAM I KNOW TRAILER BILL
IS NEEDED FOR THIS PROPOSAL-
AND- REGARDING AS- THE PROPOSING
OF A ONE TIME RATHER THAN
ONGOING PH YES WILL DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REGARDING
THAT QUESTION. IN THIS CONCLUDES
MY COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAMIS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH- MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS- LIMITED TERM OR
ONE YEAR- MONEY THIS BEING
PROVOKED PROPOSED BUT- I ALSO
HAVE TO BRING ATTENTION TO-
DURING THE COLD AT A PANDEMIC
THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO GO
THROUGH- UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
STILL SUFFER AT A HIGHER RATE-
THE AMERICAN INDIAN POPULATION
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T BRING UP THE STATE INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAMS- THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THAT THERE WAS ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THEM UP UNTIL TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE. SO TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE THE ONGOING
FUNDING STOPPED BUT WE ALSO SEE
NOW THE PANDEMIC THAT IS
CONTINUE TO GO THROUGH THAT THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE STILL
SUFFER MAJOR UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS. AND SO WHEN WE SEE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ADDING
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS- ONE TIME
FUNDING THE QUESTION IS IF WE
WANT TO CAPTURE THE ONGOING
FUNDING TO NOT TAKE IT AWAY IN
TWO THOUSAND NINE WHAT WE SEE
THAT HIGH POPULATION OF
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS AND MANY-
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE NAY AMERICAN
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- SUCCUMBED TO THE
COLD AT. EPIDEMIC HIGHER THAN
ANY OTHER GROUP OUT THERE WHEN
YOU START TO LOOK AT THE DATA
AND STATISTICS THAT ARE THERE.
SO ARE WE TO LOOK AT A ONE TIME
FUNDING ARE WE TRULY GONNA START
TO DISCUSS THE ONGOING FUNDING
OF THE HEALTH CARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE.
MYSELF I'VE PUT FORWARD- THE
COST OF A TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING FUNDING. HOWEVER
I WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS WHAT IS
THAT AMOUNT MOVING FORWARD I
BELIEVE THERE HAS TO BE ONGOING
FUNDING THAT SOME COMPONENTS
SOME MEASUREMENT SO THAT WE
DON'T GET INTO A POSITION TO
WHERE THE DATA IN THE STATISTICS
ARE BEING READ IN THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING BY THOSE ON THE ZOOM IN
PRESENTERS THAT CONTINUE TO SAY.
THAT THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
SUFFER HIGHER AREAS OF SUICIDE
HIGHER AREAS OF DIABETES HIGHER
AREAS UNDERLYING CONDITIONS I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT THOSE WERE
THE SAME STATISTICS THAT WERE
READ BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THAT IS STAB WISH THE
PROGRAM. AND THEN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE SEE THAT
PROGRAM ABANDONED TO WHERE WE'RE
AT TODAY NOW TALKING AGAIN ABOUT
ESTABLISHING MONEY TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS I WANT TO THANK
THE MINISTRATION THOSE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS BUT IT'S ONE TIME
FUNDING. WE GOT TO START TALKING
ABOUT THE ON GOING FUNDING AND
REESTABLISHING THE TROOP
COMMITMENT TO HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST PEOPLE IN MY
OFFICE IS OPEN TO DIALOGUE AND
DISCUSS THIS ISSUE. BUT I THINK
IT'S TIME WE START TO SEE THE
DATA IS STATISTICS NOT CHANGE
FROM BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE TO WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY. A
GENUINE DISCUSSION HAS TO BE
MADE ABOUT THE HEALTH CARE OF
ALL CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
GENERAL WHICH THE CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE ARE THE FIRST. FIRST
PEOPLE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I WELCOME THAT
DISCUSSION I THANK THE TWELVE
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
FUNDING. BUT WE HAVE TO TRULY
START TO TALK ABOUT THE ONGOING
FUNDING. WHEN WE START TO SEE
THE UNDERLYING CONDITIONS
STATISTICS AND DATA AND HEALTH
CARE WHERE CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE ARE STILL SUFFERING A
HIGHER RATE THAN ANY OTHER GROUP
OUT THERE IN THIS TESTIMONY IS
DONE HERE TODAY BY THOSE
PRESENTING. THAT A TEST OF THAT.
I THINK NOW IT WARRANTS NOW MORE
THAN EVER THAT DISCUSSION TO
MOVE FORWARD AND I THINK AGAIN
THE ONE TIME MONEY BUT IT HAS TO
BE ONGOING IN OUR OFFICE IS OPEN
TO DISCUSS THAT WITH YOU. SO
WHERE IS THAT DISCUSSION I GUESS
IS THE QUESTION MISTER CHAIR AND
IF I COULD GET SOME FEEDBACK
FROM THOSE THAT ARE ON THE ZOOM
TO PRESENTING. ARE WE READY FOR
A GENUINE DISCUSSION TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH ONGOING FUNDING-
PER TRIP DEPUTY DIRECTOR COOPER
THAT'S GOING TO BE DIRECTED AT
ANDREW DUFFY FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON
INTERNET DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WELL THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS MUCH
IMPROVED CONSIDERABLE RISKS TO
REVENUES REMAINS AND BUILDING
STRONG RESERVES IS CRITICAL- AND
IT'S ESSENTIAL THE ONE TIME
REVENUES BE USED FOR ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THE STATE'S. FISCAL
STABILITY AND MAINTAINING A
BALANCED BUDGET OVER LONG TERM
WILL MINIMIZE DISRUPTION TO
ONGOING- EXPENDITURES AND- WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THIS MONEY IS
AVAILABLE OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD- WITH THE- ENCUMBRANCE IN
EXPENDITURE AVAILABILITY- UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR M. AND REALLY THE
FUNDING THE TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS THIS THERE IS ON A
COMPETITIVE GRANT BASIS AND SO-
THERE'S A HUNDRED NINETY FULLY
RECOGNIZE TRIES BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TRIBES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS SURPASSES THAT
AMOUNT SO TRULY TALKING ABOUT
HEALTHCARE WE HAVE TO START
TALKING ABOUT THE ON GOING
FUNDING AGAIN MISTER CHAIR WE
WOULD WELCOME DISCUSSION AND
FOLLOW UP. ON THIS TOPIC.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND- FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION I WOULD LIKE
TO ASSOCIATE- THE CHAIR WITH THE
COMMENTS FROM MY SEAT MATE AND
TO LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE-
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT. HOW WE SECURE
ONGOING FUNDING AND- WITH THAT
WOULD THANK VERY MUCH PANEL
TWELVE AND WILL. BE PENALTIES.
AND WE WILL MOVE ON THE PANEL
FOURTEEN ON TRANSFORMING QUALITY
OUTCOMES AND HEALTH EQUITY IN
THE MEDIC CAL PCP. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR CASEY
COOPER WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH ARE THE DEPARTMENT
IS REQUESTING OF FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS- AND
NINETEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS FOR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
TRAINING HEALTH EQUITY QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT. AND CULTURALLY OF
PROFICIENCY ADDED TO ADDRESS AND
LEAD QUALITY IMPROVEMENT AND
HEALTH EQUITY. EFFORTS FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES I'M IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE DAC HAS
CREATED A QUALITY AND POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT PROGRAM HIRED
ITS FIRST CHIEF ALREADY OFFICER
AND LIFTED AND SHIFTED ITS
OFFICE OF MEDICAL DIRECTOR WHICH
INCLUDED TWENTY POSITIONS. TO
THE QUALITY AND POPULATION
HEALTH MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE QUALITY OF
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT-
AREA OF RECEIVED RESOURCES IN BE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET-
BUT DO YOU REALLY FOCUS ON MANY
OF THE INITIATIVES AROUND THE
CALLIE POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
AN ONGOING EFFORT TO CONSOLIDATE
QUALITY AND HEALTH EQUITY
RESOURCES AND WORKLOADS. IN THE
QUALITY AND POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT AREA. DH CS WILL
CREATE A CULTURE AND PROGRAM OF
DATA DRIVEN IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WILL ADDRESS THE WHOLE PERSON OR
FAMILY. IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
PREVENTION AND CHRONIC CARE FOR
CHILDREN AND ADULTS SERVED BY
MEDIC CAL STRIVE TO ELIMINATE
RACIAL AND OTHER DISPARITIES
THROUGH COMMUNITY ARE CENTERED
COLLABORATION IN IMPROVE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF THE MEDICARE PROGRAM. THE
REFEREE AS REFERENCED IN THE B.
C. P. ONE NUMEROUS INVESTMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM QUALITY SCORES HAVE
GENERALLY BEEN STAGNANT WITH
SIGNIFICANT GAPS IN CARE IN
CHILDREN'S PREVENTIVE SERVICES
MATERNITY CARE. BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND DENTAL SERVICES
NUMEROUS DISPARITIES ALSO EXIST
BY RACE ETHNICITY GEOGRAPHY AND
LANGUAGE I WITH CONTINUED UNDER
UTILIZATION AND ACCESS ISSUES
FOR SOME POPULATIONS. THE GOAL
OF THE VCP IS TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A RE ORGANIZED
QUALITY AND POPULATION HEALTH.
PROGRAM I RESULTING IN A EIGHT.
OF AND HELP EQUITY AND A
DIVISION OF POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES ARE WILL SPECIFICALLY
ENSURE ADEQUATE LEADERSHIP TO
FILL THE AMBITIOUS QUALITY
EQUITY AND POPULATION HEALTH
AGENDA. THE DH CS HAS OUTLINED
IN ITS COMPREHENSIVE QUALITY
STRATEGY AND WITHIN THE CARRYING
INITIATIVE ADDITIONAL STAFF I
WILL BE USED TO EXPAND THE BEST
PRACTICES IN QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
IN COMPLIANCE MONITORING.
ESTABLISHED FIVE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE. I TO THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND DENTAL
DELIVERY SYSTEMS WHICH
TRADITIONALLY HAVE NOT HAD MUCH
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY OR
STANDARD EXPECTATIONS FOR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT IN
UTILIZATION AND LET SO REALLY
IMPORTANT AREA WHERE WE HAVE
MORE ROBUST- INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN MANAGED CARE BUT REALLY
EXPANDING THAT TO OUR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. DENTAL AND OTHER AREAS
WITHIN OUR PROGRAM TO ENSURE WE
ARE FOCUSED ON QUALITY OUTCOMES
IMPROVEMENTS MONITORING AND DATA
TRACKING ADDITIONALLY I WITHOUT
ESTABLISHED PROGRAM EVALUATION
AND MONITORING SECTION WHICH
WILL LEAD TO ALL OF THE CALLEVA
VALUATION COMPONENTS. AS WELL AS
BUILDING INTERNAL DH YES
CAPACITY FOR MORE ROBUST PROGRAM
EVALUATIONS TO GUIDE FUTURE
POLICY AND TO ASSESS
IMPLEMENTATION OF EXISTING-
PROGRAM PROPOSALS THESE NINETEEN
POSITIONS COMBINED WITH THE
REORG STAFF AND OTHER BCP ASSET
WERE. FUNDED PREVIOUSLY. OF WILL
REALLY ALLOW US TO FULFILL THE
COMMITMENTS MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF IN LIGHT OF BOTH
CALTRAIN AND THE COMPREHENSIVE
QUALITY STRATEGY. IN THIS
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- BRING
IT UP TO THE DIOCESE NO MEMBER
QUESTIONS LEVEL THANKS VERY
MUCH. PANELISTS ON- ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN AND WILL MOVE ON TO
PANEL FIFTEEN ON THREE
ADDITIONAL- BCPS- WE WILL HAVE
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR J. C.
COOPER FROM DH CS PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU FOR
THE FURTHER STRENGTHENING FISCAL
FUNCTIONS AN OUTCOME B. C. P. D.
H. YES REQUEST TEN A PERMANENT
POSITIONS TWO YEAR LIMITED TERM
RESOURCES EQUIVALENT TO FIVE
OPPOSITIONS TWO POINT FOUR
MILLION EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO BUILD
UPON THE FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET PACKAGE. RELATING
TO EFFORTS- TO STRENGTHEN FISCAL
ESTIMATES INCLUDING UPGRADING
THE ENHANCED MEDIC CAL BUDGET
ESTIMATE REDESIGNED SYSTEM
FUNCTIONALITY ARE AS WELL AS
STRENGTHENING CASH FLOW
MONITORING AND REPORTING AND
PROVIDING RESOURCES WERE
INCREASING AND COMPLEX
WORKLOADS. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY TO
MANAGE INCREASING- COMPLEX
WORKLOADS INCLUDE A BUDGETING
FOR EXPANDING POLICY CHANGES IN
THE BI ANNUAL MEDIC HOW AND
FAMILY HEALTH A LOCAL ASSISTANT
AS THE MEN'S LARGE VOLUME OF
RECURRING AND AD HOC DRILLS
RELATED TO YOU IN HERE. A
FEDERAL FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH
THE KOBE NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY NEW FUNDS AND ENHANCE
REPORTING OVERSIGHT TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
INTERNAL PARTNERS REGARDING
BUDGET DEVELOPMENT AND
FORECASTING AS WELL AS UPGRADING
THE AT. EMBER SYSTEM I MENTIONED
EARLIER- FOR THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ESTIMATES OF
DISABILITY IMPROVEMENTS TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
USABILITY. FIVE OR THE MEDIC HOW
ENTERPRISES THE MODERNIZATION
FEDERAL JOB REPORTING OPERATIONS
B. E. T. H. YES REQUEST FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION CONTRACT
FUNDING FOR TWO YEARS TO SUPPORT
FEDERAL DRAW AND RECORDING
SYSTEM OPERATIONS AS PART OF ITS
MEDICAID ENTERPRISE SYSTEM
MODERNIZATION. THE BCP WILL
PROVIDE THE FUNDING FOR
RESOURCES NEEDED TO SUPPORT ON
GOING OPERATION COST HER DH CS
IS NEW FEDERAL TROUGHTON
REPORTING SYSTEM THAT WILL BE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. BY JULY
TWENTY TWO. AND LASTLY IN PRO
WORK WOULD BE C. P. DO YOU.
BURKE THIRTY POINT FIVE
POSITIONS CONVERSION OF FOUR
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY A FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO ADDRESS
INCREASED WORKLOADS IN BENEFITS
DIVISION LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL
FINANCING DIVISION MEDIC HOW
DENTAL SERVICES DIVISION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. THE REQUESTED
RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY FOR
PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE
FOLLOWING WORKLOADS ADOPTING
UTILIZE EVIDENCE BASED
HEALTHCARE POLICIES AND
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT CRITERIA
AS WELL AS ADDRESSED VERITIES
YOUR POLICIES AND PROGRAMS.
CREATE THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FISCAL POLICY SECTION TO FOCUS
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF A
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FINANCIAL
POLICIES MAINTAIN THE INCREASED
ONGOING AND MISSION CRITICAL
WORKLOAD DEMANDS SUCH AS
ESTABLISH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE REGARDING THE MANAGED
CARE FINAL RULE. TRACKING
MONITORING COLLABORATING WITH
OTHER PROGRAM AREAS IN
RESPONDING TO DATA REQUESTS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND REPUBLIC RECORD
ACT REQUESTS ASSIST WITH
CONTRACT OVERSIGHT OF THE FEE
FOR SERVICE VENDORS- AND LASTLY
THE BUDGET AFTER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE INCREASE DH CS STAFF
ACCOUNTS BY THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY FIVE POSITIONS. IN
CONTRACT EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
WHICH REQUIRES AN INCREASE TO
THE STANDARD COMPLEMENT OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT POSITIONS
WHICH IS REFLECTED IN THIS
REQUEST REQUEST OF FOR OUR
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS
HUMAN RESOURCES AND. THIS
CONCLUDES MY COMMENTS AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU FOR MUCH I WILL
IT UP TO THE DÍAS FOR MEMBER.
SEEN THANKS VERY MUCH- PANELISTS
FOR ISSUE FIFTEEN WE WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR FINAL ISSUE OF THE DAY
ISSUE SIXTEEN. TO ALIGN MEDICAL
WE DETERMINATIONS WITH FEDERAL
GUIDELINES TRAILER BILL- WE WILL
HAVE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR JC
COOPER WITH T. H. C. S. BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU.
THE BUDGET REQUEST A ONE TIME
SYSTEM COST OF THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN. I TO UPDATE NOTICE OF
ACTIONS IN STATEWIDE AUTOMATED
WELFARE SYSTEM OR SODS IDEAS
THIS IS PROPOSING TO APPLYING
STATE LAW AND FEDERAL GUIDELINES
AFTER MEDICARE REDETERMINATION
PROCESS BEING TO AVOID LOSS OF
FEDERAL. FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION
AND REDUCE BURDENSOME
REQUIREMENTS FOR BENEFICIARIES
AND COUNTY ELIGIBILITY WORKERS
ON DECEMBER FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY
A CMS RELEASED A BULLETIN
CLARIFYING THE REQUIREMENTS. OF
FOR THE NINETY GET YOUR PERIOD
STATES MUST DETERMINE OF THE
DISCONTINUED BENEFICIARY'S
ELIGIBILITY AS A NEW APPLICANT
BASED ON THE DATE THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION IS SUBMITTED AND
GRANT RETROACTIVE ELIGIBILITY.
UP FOR ANY OF THE THREE PREVIOUS
MONTHS ONLY IF THE INDIVIDUAL
REQUESTS RETROACTIVE ELIGIBILITY
AND IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE
REQUESTED MONTHS. ADDITIONALLY
CMS CLARIFIED. THE- SETTING.
ANNUAL RENEWAL DATE OF FOLLOW
MORE AFTER PROCESS IN BOWLS A
THIS CHANGE. VERY THIS CHANGE
CONFORMS I TO UPDATE FEDERAL
GUIDANCE AND AVOIDS POTENTIAL
AUDIT FINDINGS AND FISCAL
PENALTIES I AND FUTURE ADDED CMS
COULD DETERMINE THAT F. P. IS
UNALLOWABLE AND DGS MUST RETURN
FFP DUE TO IMPROPERLY
DETERMINING RETROACTIVE
ELIGIBILITY AND CONDUCTING
ANNUAL RENEWALS LESS THAN TWELVE
MONTHS APART. IN THIS PROPOSAL
DH CS PROPOSES A MODIFICATION
AND STATE LAW BY REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE BENEFICIARY
TO REVIEW INFORMATION PRE
POPULATED ON THE CHANGE IN
CIRCUMSTANCE FORM OF REACH YOU-
OR UPDATED AT SIGN THE FORM
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY IN
RETURN THE FORM TO THE COUNTY
THIS PREVENTS EXTRA BURDENS FOR
THE BENEFICIARY AND INCREASED
WORKLOAD FOR COUNTY ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS. IN THIS CONCLUDES MY
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF BRING IT UP TO THE
DIOCESAN NO NUMBER QUESTIONS I
WILL THANK THE PANELISTS FOR
ISSUE. SIXTEEN AS WELL AS
THINKING ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
TODAY. IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL NUMBER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT. AS A REMINDER WE
WELCOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY
ISSUE ON THE AGENDA. WE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEREFORE I WANT TO
URGE YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
BRIEF SO THAT WE CAN HEAR FROM
EVERYONE. WE WILL START WITH ANY
IN PERSON PUBLIC COMMENT IN THE
HEARING ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO THE MICROPHONE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY BEING HERE FOR
HEALTH NET OF CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND WELLNESS
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE COVERAGE TO INCOME
ELIGIBLE ADULTS TWENTY SIX TO
FORTY NINE YEARS OF AGE.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDERING OPTIONS TO
IMPLEMENT SOONER THAN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. AS IT WILL PRESERVE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR YOUNG
ADULTS AGING OUT OF FULL SCOPE
COVERAGE AND ALSO ACCESS TO
COVERAGE FOR ADULTS IN THEIR
FAMILY. WE ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE DETAILS ON DHS'S TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL AND FOR ADDITIONAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BE POSTED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS MICHELLE FROM LET CALIFORNIA
KIDS HERE I'M A MOM AND WE'RE A
COALITION OF PARENTS AND
PEDIATRIC PROVIDERS I'M I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
RECOGNIZING THE NEEDS OF DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN I'M
IN OUR STATE UNDER THE SIX OR
PERCENT FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
EIGHT MONTHS IN WITH SIX POINT
SEVEN FOR DH YESTERDAY MINISTER
A TEN MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM AND
WITHIN OUR PROVIDER NETWORKS WE
ARE ONLY AWARE OF THREE CHILDREN
OF THE FORTY FOUR THAT HAVE
RECEIVED HEARING AIDS ARE THE
BIGGEST ISSUE PARENTS ARE FACING
IS BEING ABLE TO FIND A
PEDIATRIC PROVIDER-
PARTICIPATING IN THEIR PROGRAM-
LARGE PEDIATRIC AUDIOLOGY
CENTERS LIKE UC DAVIS SUTTER USC
UCLA CLASSICALLY TO REPORT THEIR
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE AT THIS
TIME BECAUSE ESSENTIAL PEDIATRIC
CODES HAVE NOT BEEN PUBLISHED
WITH REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
EVEN LOWER THAN CCS. THEY DO NOT
COVER THE COST TO PROVIDE TIME
INTENSIVE APPROPRIATE PEDIATRIC
CARE FOR PRE LEGAL CHILDREN- THE
FIRST CHILD THAT WAS AIDED
CALLED HER A LIST OF FIFTY
PROVIDERS PROVIDERS ONE DIDN'T
KNOW ABOUT THE PROGRAM AND THEY
DID NOT SERVE CHILDREN SO THAT'S
WHY THE OPT IN SURVEY WAS
CREATED THE REPORT THAT THERE
ARE- THIRTY FOR PROVIDERS
PARTICIPATING BUT REALLY- ONE
CENTER SAID THEY CAN ONLY AFFORD
TO SEE ONE SO THAT LEAVES
FOURTEEN PROVIDERS FOR SEVEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN. ON THE OTHER
ISSUE PARENTS ARE FACING IS
THAT- IF THEY HAVE PARTIAL
COVERAGE FIVE HUNDRED FOR SIX
THOUSAND DOLLAR BENEFIT THEY ARE
NOT THEY DO NOT QUALIFY FOR THIS
PROGRAM IF THE CHILD HAS A
TEACHER MICROTIA AND NEEDS BONE
CONDUCTION HEARING AIDS THAT IS
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR OF TEN
TO TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
HEARING AID THAT CODE HAS NOT
BEEN APPROVED WE KNOW FOR
FAMILIES WAITING RIGHT NOW IN
THAT CODE TO BE APPROVED SO THAT
THEIR CHILD. CAN BE IN CLASS
WITH FULL ACCESS TO SOUTH SO- WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
OVERSIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS TO ENSURE INFERENCE
AND TODDLERS ARE ABLE TO MEET
THEIR- MILE. IN SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN ARE ABLE TO ATTEND
SCHOOL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD EVERY JANUARY I THINK YOU
WROTE ME SPEAK TODAY- MY NAME IS
BUCKLING SEN I'M A MEMBER OF THE
WALKER RIVER PAIUTE TRIBE AND-
THE HEALTH POLICY ANALYST AT THE
CALIFORNIA RULING HEALTH BOARD.
THANK YOU- CRIB IS A NETWORK OF
FIFTY NINE TRIBES IN NINETEEN
TRAVEL HEALTH PROGRAMS TRUSTED
CALIFORNIA- WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE MOVE
FUNDING FOR THE INDIAN HEALTH.
PROGRAM FROM ONE TIME TO ON
GOING- AS NOTED THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS- THE ANY HEALTH PROGRAM
WAS CONTINUOUSLY FUNDED FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. FROM ITS
CREATION NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
UNTIL FUNDING WAS CUT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE- SINCE FUNDING WAS
LIMITED HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT-
IMPROVED. IN FACT- NEEDED PEOPLE
WERE THREE AND A HALF TIMES.
MORE LIKELY THAN GENERAL HELP
POPULATION. I TO BE
HOSPITALIZED- BY WACO IN
NINETEEN- SUICIDE AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE RATES HAVE SKYROCKETED- IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC- INTO MORTALITY RATE IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES ALMOST TWICE
THAT OF THE GENERAL POPULATION-
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN- ALIENS ARE
AMERICAN LASKIN IT IS- WERE 50%
MORE LIKELY TO BE DIAGNOSED
WITH. CORONARY HEART DISEASE AND
ARE TWICE AS LIKELY TO HAVE
DIABETES- THAN THEIR NON
HISPANIC WHITE COUNTERPART- THIS
IS A FEW OF THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES- BUT THEY EXPRESSED
A DEFINITE NEED FOR ONGOING
FUNDING- ON ANOTHER NOTE- PERSON
DOORS IN A PUBLIC LOT TO EIGHTY-
THE STATE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO PROVIDE HEALTH AND SAFETY
RESOURCES TO TRAVEL COMMUNITIES.
AFTER NOT FAMILIAR WITH PUBLIC
LAW TO EIGHTY- IT GAVE THE STATE
JURISDICTION OVER TRIBAL LANDS
IN EXCHANGE. FOR THE PROMISE OF-
READY HEALTH AND SAFETY RE. TO
TRAVEL. I WITHOUT ON GOING- ANY
HEALTH PROGRAM FUNDING TRAVEL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE TO RECRUIT RETAIN
MEDICAL PROVIDERS I DO THE RURAL
LOCATIONS- AND THE SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING DISPARITIES BETWEEN.
INDIAN HEALTH SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND OTHER FEDERALLY FUNDED.
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS. FINALLY A
NATIVE PEOPLE ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO CARRY HEALTH INSURANCE-
RATHER HEALTH CARE IS A
GUARANTEED RIGHT. BASED ON
TREATIES AND STATUTES SUCH AS
PUBLIC LAW TO EIGHTY-
INDIFFERENCE TO THIS FACT THE
STATE EXEMPTED NATIVE PEOPLE
FROM THE STATE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE- CRITICALLY AGREES THIS
COURSE OF ACTION. HOWEVER TRAVEL
HEALTH PROGRAMS ARE STILL
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO UNINSURED INDIANS-
AND DO NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
THE BILL FOR THE SERVICES-
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM FUNDS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY HELP PROVIDE-
HEALTH SERVICES TO THIS
UNINSURED POPULATION. I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN CAN YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEN NO MORE IN
PERSON COMMENTS WE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AS A REMINDER OF THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD
BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU ARE.
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET THE
NUMBER. IS PUBLIC TOLL FREE. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE ONE TWO SIX. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS YOU CAN
CALL THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2090 NINE
AND THE STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST
YOU. OPERATOR WE ARE READY TO
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
ON THE PHONE IF WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO YOUR TOUCH TONE
PHONE. AND OUR FIRST QUESTION
COMES FROM THE LINE THAT NINE
YOU STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. LIFE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE TAKE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. HELLO MY
NAME IS DIEGO AND I'M CALLING
FROM CELTIC HERE IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND TODAY I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
MEMBERS HERE WITHIN THE
ORGANIZATIONS SPECIFICALLY SAID
YOUR RIGHT IT'S NOT THINK. THAT
PASSED AWY OF FORTY HELP FORTY
EIGHT YEAR OLD FARMWORKER WOMEN
OUT OF THIS POLICY HERE IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY THAT DIDN'T
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IN
HER NAME WE ARE ADVOCATING TODAY
TO MAKE SURE THAT HEALTH FOR ALL
PASSES. AND INCLUDES THAT IT'S
ALL INCLUSIVE JUST HOW IT IS
SENT TO HELP ROTH WE ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT. HEALTH PROBLEMS IN
THE FINAL. CALIFORNIA BUDGET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT IS
LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES SIR.
HI GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME CONGRESS IANS- COMMITTEE ON
THEM BUT THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS PROMOTED FROM A- THE
DEEP STATE COLLEGIAN A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECTS AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF FUNDING FOR HEALTH
FOR ALL. OF THE ADVOCATE AND
INDIGENOUS MEMBER OF ALL FOUR
COMMUNITY ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
ALLOW ME TO TREAT MY VISION
WHICH AT A SEMI HUGE CHANGE IN
MY LIFE FOR THE BETTER. NATURE I
MIGHT LOSE FULL SCHOOL MEDICAL
BECAUSE I'M TURNING TWENTY SIX
UNIVERSAL PLEASE INCLUDE HELD
FOR ALL IN THE FINAL CON FORGET
BUDGET BECAUSE MY BUDGET MY
MISSION. HELPS CATHOLICS EVERY
ASPECT OF MY LIFE YES I WORK IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND I LINE TWO. WE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERTO
CRUZ AND I'M WITH KANYE CAL
HEARING COACHELLA VALLEY- I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I AM-
INTO PORT OF HEALTH FOR ALL
FOUR- TO BE ACCORDED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET- BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS HERE IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WHO. REALLY
NEED THAT THAT- COVERAGE THAT
SUPPORT- ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE BACKBONE OF OUR YOU KNOW
OUR AGRICULTURE AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO DO IS- HAVE SOME PEOPLE
THAT WORK IN OUR ORGANIZATION TO
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT ARE JUST-
SUFFERING FROM THE PANDEMIC SO
WE WOULD LIKE TO. PLEASE HELP-
OPEN GET THAT. COVERS THAT THEY
NEED THANK YOU SO MUCH. Q. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU OUR
NEXT LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
INCOMING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS AMBER MENDOZA A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER FROM
ABROAD WITH THEM EXPECT WE BEGIN
OUR COMMUNITY ORGANIZING PROJECT
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF FUNDING
FOR HEALTH FOR ALL. WE DID UNITS
COMMUNITY IS DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY THE LACK OF ACCESS TO HELP
ACCESS AND COVERAGE DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THANKS TO
HE EXPANSION OF HEALTH FOR ALL
YOUNG ADULTS IN TWENTY TWENTY
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WERE ABLE TO ACCESS FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL CURRENTLY SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITY IS A MEMBER AS THEY
WILL LOSE THEIR HEALTH COVERAGE
WHEN THEY BECOME TWENTY SIX
YEARS OLD. PLEASE INCLUDE HOW
FOR ALL IN THE FINAL CALIFORNIA
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THAT COME FROM THE LINE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO JOHN- I'M
SOME SORT OF AN IMMINENT FIRE.
HOW CONTENT DESPERATELY NEEDED
ESPECIALLY MAINTAINED THAT HAVE
UNDOCUMENTED REST RESIDENTS ARE
YOU GREATER RISK BECAUSE THEY
ARE EXCLUDED FROM OUR STATE
PROGRAMS- PLEASE INCLUDE HARPER
ON THE FINAL QUOTE FOR YOUR
BUDGET THANK YOU AND ARE THERE A
FEW DAYS. THANK. YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND THAT'S LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK YES PLEASE CONTINUE. HOW
WONDERFUL GOOD FOOD. DR STEPHEN
STEAK I'M THE CEO OF COMPOUND
MEDICAL CENTER AN ENTITY OF THE
HOOP OF ALLEY TRIBE IN HUMBOLDT
COUNTY I AM CALLING- TO REQUEST
FUNDING FOR THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM. AS YOU WELL KNOW AND
HAVE HEARD ALREADY EITHER MANY-
HEALTH DISPARITIES AMONG NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATIONS INCLUDING
THE ONE THAT I WORK FOR THE
HOOPA VALLEY TRIBE- THE BARRIERS
AND CHALLENGES ARE ENORMOUS. I
IN BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE
HEALTH SERVICES AND ON AN
ALREADY FRAGILE HEALTH SYSTEM WE
HAVE CO BID AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES ON TOP- ONE OF OUR
PRIMARY NEEDS HIS RECRUITMENT
RETENTION OF PROVIDERS IN THE
AREA AND- WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COMPETE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES FOR THE RURAL TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS OTHER
TRAVEL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE URGENTLY COULD USE THIS
FUNDING- TO BE ABLE THAT HAVE-
MORE JUSTICE IN HEALTH CARE FOR
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. DR OPERATOR
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO CREATES JEREMY ARE. WE CAN
PLEASE CONTINUE. HERE GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RICARDO
FROM CELTIC IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
HOPE FOR OUR IT IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC COMING FROM AN
UNDOCUMENTED BACKGROUND WORKING
OUT IN THE FIELD HARVESTING THE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES WE ARE
CONSTRUCTION CONSTRUCTING THE
HOMES WE LIVE IN THAT
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY IS IN
GREATER RATES BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS PLEASE INCLUDE HELP FOR
ALL IN THE FINAL. CALIFORNIA
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BILL
THOMPSON I AM CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER RIVERSIDE SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY INDIAN HEALTH SERVING THE
NATIVE AMERICAN ALASKAN NATIVE
POPULATION WITHIN RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES I SPEAK
REGARDING THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM PROPOSED BUDGET OF
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS. A FEW
POINTS OF INTEREST REGARDING
DISPARITIES AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE. ERIC
AN INFANT MORTALITY RATE IS
ALMOST TWICE THAT OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION. NATIVE AMERICANS AND
NATIVE MOTHERS ALMOST THREE
TIMES AS LIKELY TO RECEIVE LATE
OR NO PREDICT A PRENATAL CARE AS
COMPARED TO NON HISPANIC WHITE
MOTHERS. IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AMERICAN INDIANS AND
ALASKAN NATIVES 450% MORE LIKELY
TO BE DIAGNOSED WITH CORONARY
HEART DISEASE. THERE ARE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO HAVE DIABETES AND
NOT- LIKELY TO HAVE DIABETES.
THAN NON HISPANIC WHITES.
SUICIDE RATES AMONG AMERICAN
INDIAN OR ALASKA ARE YOU FROM.
AND YOUNG ADULTS ARE TWO POINT
FIVE TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION. THESE ARE
JUST SOME OF THE DISPARITIES TO
SPEAK ABOUT IN THE MEN'S NEED
FOR GREATER ONGOING RESOURCE AND
IN OUR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. THE PROPOSED BUDGET
INCLUDES A ONE TIME TWELVE
BILLION DOLLAR TO RESTORE GRANT
MONEY FOR TRAVEL HELP PROGRAMS.
TRABERT PRIOR TO THE STOPPAGE OF
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM ARE IS
BCI CHAI WAS THE RECIPIENT OF
THE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM FUND.
I DON'T RECALL THE EXACT DOLLAR
AMOUNT OF THE FUNDING. HOWEVER I
DO RECALL USE THESE FUNDS TO
SUPPORT THE SALARY AND PART OF A
COMMUNITY HEALTH REPRESENTATIVE.
PURCHASE NEW BORN IMPRINT TAKE
HOME KITS. PARTIALLY SUPPORTIVE
FAMILY WELLNESS CONFERENCES FOR
MEN AND WOMEN AND FAMILIES TO
EDUCATE OUR POPULATION ON HEALTH
FACTORS RELATING TO DIABETES.
OBESITY NUTRITION IMMUNIZATION.
SUICIDE WITH RESILIENCY OBGYN
CARE DENTAL NEEDS MENTAL HEALTH
AND CHEMICAL DEPENDENCY TO NAME
A FEW. ALL OF THE UPS ALL OF
WHICH HAVE ADVERSELY AFFECTED
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
IN VARIOUS WAYS. OUR COMMUNITY
HEALTH REPRESENTATIVES AND
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES HAVE MADE
FAR THIS WHOLE BUSINESS THING OF
THE PAST DUE TO STAFF SHORTAGES
AND FUNDING. WITH THESE BONTA
ONCE AGAIN WE CAN PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY HEALTHCARE TOOLS TO
EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITIES INTO
LIVING A MORE HEALTHY PHYSICAL
MENTAL LIFESTYLE. THIS MONEY
WILL PROMOTE THE RETENTION OF
THE HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE THAT
SERVE THESE PROGRAMS AND WE'LL
EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS ON
HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT AMERICAN
INDIANS EXPERIENCED. THANK YOU
FOR SUPPORTING THIS
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CLARK CAP ON I AM THE
CEO FOR SOUTHERN INDIAN HEALTH
COUNCIL LOCATED IN CAP OUT FINE
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THIRTY MILES
EAST OF DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO WE
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO OUR SEVEN
CONSORTIUM TRIED. ADDRESS YOU
TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND MAKING FUNDING FOR THE
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM ONGOING
THE NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION
HAS GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
PAST DECADE AND A POPULATION
INCREASE SPEAKS TO THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE. THE STATE OF OFFERED
ASSISTANCE WHEN IT IS REIMBURSED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT FOR TRAVEL COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN SCARCE. EACH YEAR THE
GUY. WORK ON X. MEDICAID SO.
THROUGH IT IS NOT REGION AT THE
CONNECTICUT UNINSURED NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION. THE THIRD
BOOK SHOW THAT THE NATIVE
AMERICANS HAVE THE HIGHEST
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND OTHER
GROUPS. TO FIGHT RATES ARE AMONG
THE HIGHEST IN A TO VIEW ANY
OTHER ADULT. THERE NEEDS TO BE
GREATER ONGOING RESOURCES IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. ARE
SATELLITE CLINIC IS ANOTHER
FORTY MILES EAST OF OUR OUR BY
LOCATION. IN THIS ROLE AREA WE
FACE CHALLENGES SUCH O NO
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY A LONGER
RESPONSE TIMES FROM LOCAL SHARE
CUNNINGHAM TO SERVICES. WE ALSO
FACE HIRING SHORTAGE OF FROM
DOCTORS AND NURSES WHO DON'T
WANT TO WORK IN THIS ROLE
ENVIRONMENT. THE GREAT
RESIGNATION HAS INCREASED OUR
TURNOVER RATE AND MAKES IT THAT
MUCH MORE CHALLENGING. TO
RECRUIT FOR HELP THEIR POSITION.
WE HAVE TO BE CREATIVE AND HOW
WE CAN RETAIN STEPPED UP BOTH
COMPETE WITH LOCAL HOSPITALS.
THAT ARE ABLE TO OFFER HIGHER
SALARIES AND BENEFITS. I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE SUPPORT ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM. BUT THE SOUTHERN INDIAN
HEALTH COUNCIL AND OTHER NATIVE
HEALTH CLINIC TO CONTINUE THE
WORK WE. DO FOR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. AND YOU.
OPERATOR CALL PLEASE. LINE EIGHT
AIRLINER OPEN. THIRTY EIGHT.
THAT'S WHEN I FOUND A NUMBER OF
BY ABOUT THAT YES BUT YOU HAVE
ON THE MAKER THAT I AN EMPIRE
BUT I BY THE APPLE YOU OKAY
THAT'S BE MANY QUITE BUT I'M NOT
PERSONAS IN THE- AND ALSO I YES
THEY NUMBERS ARE NOT BY THE MORE
JAPANESE I CAN THE KENTUCKY ON
THE CALL THE INABILITY AND IT
OUT OF YOU WITH THANK YOUNG
MEDICAL OR NOT THAT WILL. YEAH
CAN NOTHING LOOK MENTAL PROBLEM
OR YOU'RE NOT FOR ARE NOT
KNOWING BROADBAND ALSO IN THE
NEED IT I THOUGHT YOU AGAIN MOST
OF A MONTH. NATIONAL PROGRAMS
WITH GREAT MAKERS CONCERNED WITH
IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES. WE ARE
NATIONAL NONPROFIT THAT WORKS TO
EDUCATE AND CHANNELISE SILVA
INVESTMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE AND ASYLUM
SEEKER COMMUNITIES. WE BELIEVE
VERY STRONGLY IN PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS. HAVE BEEN PLEASED
TO BE ABLE TO. PARTNER WITH THE
CITY CALIFORNIA ON THE
CALIFORNIA'S IMMIGRANT
RESILIENCE FUND. THE CALIFORNIA
DIGNITY FOR FAMILY FUN. WE'RE
CALLING TODAY TO EXPRESS THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION AND FUNDING. FOR THE
HEALTH OF ALL PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF STATUS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS.
HEALTHCARE SERVICEMEN COURAGE
INDUCTION OF THE FUNDING THE
FINAL BUDGET AND IMPLEMENTATION. SEEMS POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT. AND
THANK THANK YOU LINE FORTY SEVEN
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT DID YOU NEED
TO THANK. NINE FORTY SEVEN. YEAH. NINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU HI MY WALLET-
YEAH THAT'S I AM CALLING FROM
THE LOTUS WITH THE FOUNDATION I
LIVE IN KERN COUNTY WHERE WE
HAVE HIGH LEVELS OF CARCINOGENS
AND POLLUTANTS IN BOTH OF OUR
AIR AND WATER. AND I KNOW THAT
WE ALL WANT HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
IN ORDER TO HAVE HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES WHO DEFINITELY NEED
HELP FOR ALL MEANING M. ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS- ESPECIALLY
DURING A PANDEMIC AND I REALLY
THINK IT'S UNACCEPTABLE THAT. ON
DOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS STILL
REMAIN EXCLUDED FROM HEALTH
ACCESS. JUST BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY WERE BORN. I THINK IT OF
CALIFORNIANS WERE BETTER THAN
THAT AND HAVING HEALTHY
COMMUNITY MEANS PROTECTING ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
ESPECIALLY ARE IN. NEED TO HAVE
BEEN HIT THE HARDEST AND OUR
MOST VULNERABLE SINCE THEY ARE-
EXCLUDED FROM YOUR HOME THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THAT'S LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CLOTHING
FOR THE CALL BACK TO CALIFORNIA
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND MEDICARE
COVERAGE TO PEOPLE AGES TWENTY
SIX TO FORTY NINE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT WE
EXTENDED MEDICAL PROGRAM. ALL
WHO QUALIFY AND NO LONGER
EXCLUDE ANYONE BASED ON
IMMIGRATION STATUS. ON ISSUE
ELEVEN. HEALTH ACCESS OR THE
ADDITION OF BUDGET INVESTMENT TO
INCREASE THE MADE IN THE LEVEL
AND THE MEDICARE SHERIFF COST
PROGRAM. AS THIS PROGRAM HARMS
OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
BY HAVING INDIVIDUALS PAY A
MINIMUM. OF 60% OF THEIR INCOME
TOWARD THE COST OF THEIR CARE
EVERY MONTH. AND ON ISSUE
FOURTEEN WE WILL SUPPORT THE
GOAL OF THE DEPARTMENT- DTS THE
IMPROVE THE HEALTH EQUITY.
WITHIN MEDICARE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU LINE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ESPN PALLID WITH JUSTICE IN
AGING CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE ONE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
EXPANDING WELCOME MEDICAL
COVERAGE TO PEOPLE AGES TWENTY
SIX TO FORTY NINE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS TO HELP TREAT
AND PREVENT ILLNESS THAT MAY
BECOME MORE SEVERE IN OLDER AGE
AND ENDING WITH UNFAIR AND
INEQUITABLE EXCLUSION. ON ISSUE
ELEVEN WE SUPPORT MAKING HEALTH
CARE MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES.
BUT OUR DOCTOR WOULD NOTED WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE ADDITIONAL
BUDGET INVESTMENTS TO INCREASE
THE MAINTENANCE NAY LEVEL IN THE
MEDICAL SURE COSTS PROGRAM WHICH
HAS NOT BEEN ADJUSTED SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE CURRENT
PROGRAM CAUSES SIGNIFICANT HARM
TO OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
BECAUSE FOR THOSE WHO MAKE JUST
ONE DOLLAR OVER THE INCOME LIMIT
FOR FREE MEDICAL THEY MUST PAY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DOLLARS
A MONTH TOWARDS THE COST OF
THEIR CARE. THIS LEAVES PEOPLE
LOOKED AT SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH THE BASICALLY THE
EXPENSIVE AND THE MOST.
EXPENSIVE STATES ELEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OPERATOR CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN- HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS CARLOS LET
ALONG WITH- CLEANING DOUBLE
SINGLES GOVERNMENTAL IN LOS
ANGELES- WE ARE CREAMY
GOVERNMENTAL WE'LL GET TO
PROVIDE A HELPFUL REGARDLESS OF
THE ELECTION AS PART OF. THE
SERVICE EVERY DAY WE COUNT OF
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO SAY THE
CALL THE BOXING BECAUSE OF FEAR
OF BEING DEPORTED. PLEASE DO THE
RIGHT THING AND PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERYBODY
HEALTHCARE IS A BASIC HUMAN
RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
THANK OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHE YES GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN PLEASE CONDUCT WONDERFUL
GREAT YET I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
WONDERFUL HI GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LEE AND ALONZO I'M WITH
ALLIANCE FOR A BETTER COMMUNITY
A. B. C. A. B. C. FOCUSES ON
ADVANCING SOCIAL ECONOMIC RACIAL
EQUITY AND JUSTICE FOR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY- IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION- ABC HAS A STRONG
NETWORK OF MORE THAN SIX HUNDRED
PARENTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN
THE FRENCH OF THE COUNTY. AND
THE MAJORITY OF THOSE FAMILIES
ARE MIXED STATUS OUR AT LEAST
ONE OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS IS
UNDOCUMENTED- AND AS THE
PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO DEVASTATE
THE WORLD THE RECENT YEARS HAVE
SHOWN US THAT THE EMPLOYEES OF
HEALTH ACCIDENTS- IN THE SEVENTY
TWO HEALTH COVERAGE FOR ALL IS
VERY IMPORTANT- WE HAVE THE
DEADLY EFFECTS OF CALL THE
NINETEEN- AND HOW THE FACT THAT
HE HAD CREATED- PROFESSIONALLY
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES- AND
FOR UNDOCUMENTED- BRENT
DOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
ABC BELIEVES THAT HEALTHCARE IS
A HUMAN RIGHT AND THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
CITIZENSHIP STATUS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTH
INSURANCE WE URGE YOU TO INCLUDE
HEALTHCARE ALL IN THE FINAL
CALIFORNIA BUDGET TO HELP US GET
UNDERSTAND THAT MAKE AND CREATE
A CALIFORNIA. FOR ALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WELL I SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS A- THIRTY
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE NOT IN
ATLANTA PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ROUTE OKAY
CALIFORNIA WELL THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION ON
AND ON A COUPLE OF ISSUES- AND
TODAY'S AGENDA. UNDERSTATEMENT
SEVEN- AS WELL AS ISSUE EIGHT
HONESTY THANK BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR THE HPV
VACCINE COVERED UNDER THE FAMILY
PACK AND- MEDICATION ABORTION
BABBITT GIVEN THE FACT THAT. FDA
APPROVED OPTION- ACTIVE IN
LAFAYETTE TELEHEALTH BURKE FOR
THOSE SEEKING BARRIERS DUE TO
INEQUITIES AND HEALTH CARE. ACT
THAT. YEAH I DON'T- BECAUSE
TODAY ON ISSUES THANK I'M A NEON
IT SHOULD BE- REPORTED THAT THE
ABOUT IT AND HELP- DO MEDICARE
PROVIDER ARE WE IN. IF THE
ANIMAL AS THEIR VALUE MEMBERS-
AT THE HEALTHCARE TEAM. AND
UNDERSTOOD EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
DECISION WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
AB NINETY SEVEN REIMBURSEMENT.
REINSTATEMENT- THE- REALLY GO A
LONG WAY TO IN OUR- AND SELLING
- ACCESS GAP- FOR WORK WE'RE
SUPPORTING THE STATEMENT THE
PROVIDERS LISTED AND- AND
ACTUALLY LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY ASSUMING THE
WORST. AND OTHER- OTHER THAN THE
COMMITTEE- TO ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE OTHER
PROVIDER TYPES WITH THE BIG LEON
LICENSED MIDWIVES AS WELL AS A
NURSE MIDWIFE WORK IN
COLLABORATIVE PRACTICES. WITH
LICENSING RIGHTS IN MANY AND
MANY BIRTH CENTERS- AND IT
WOULD- IMPROVE ACCESS OR MANY OF
THOSE THAT ARE USING MEDIC HOW-
AND OTHER. FOLKS IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO QUALITY HEALTHCARE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU
YOUR LINE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. LINE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITHOUT
RESPONSIBLE BONTA LINE SEVENTY
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING KELLY BROOK
FINE ON THREE ISSUES ON BEHALF
OF A FEW QUITE FIRST I WILL
COMMENT ON THAT HELD A HEALTH
ISSUE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS.
AFTER YEAR TELEHEALTH. HAS
PROVEN TO BE A CRITICAL MODALITY
FOR PUBLIC HOSPITALS THEY
REACHING PATIENTS AND PROVIDING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CARE. WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF MANY ASPECTS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TELEHEALTH
PROPOSAL INCLUDING CONTINUING
THE COVERAGE OF BOTH PHONE AND
VIDEO SERVICES. UNITARITY AND
ACROSS PROVIDER TYPE INCLUDING
ACCURATELY. RECORD PARTNERING
WITH DHS NINETY TELL THOSE
PROPOSALS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING THIS CRITICAL
MENTALITY OF CARE AND BEST OF
THE KITCHEN. I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO COME AND HELP ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE. FOR ELDERS
INDEPENDENT PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
THE INITIAL ASSESSMENT THAT HIS
CONDUCT IS TANTAMOUNT TO DOUBLE
STANDARD PATIENTLY SHINSHA AND
SHOULD BE. ABLE TO BE CONDUCTED
BE A SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO. HIS
PROGRAMSLOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE CONTINUE TO USE
TELEHEALTH BEYOND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH. EMERGENCY EVEN IF IT
REQUIRES FEDERAL APPROVAL.
SECOND ISSUE ONE PUBLIC
HOSPITALS ALSO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
COVERAGE TO ALL. ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS AND A COLOR GUARD
WITH THE DOCUMENTATIONS THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
PROVIDE 40% OF ALL HOSPITAL CARE
FIFTIES UNINSURED. AND MANY OF
OUR SYSTEMS PROVIDE EXCELLENT
THE PRIMARY AN OUTPATIENT CARE.
TORRENT INSURED RESIDENTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP ON THIS PROPOSAL
NEVER BECOME THE CALIFORNIA ALSO
I COULD SUPPORT THE MEDICAID
EXPANSION TO ALL. FINALLY ON
ISSUE NINE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
METHODOLOGY. PUBLIC HOSPITALS
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S WORK ON
MOVING THE PROPOSAL FORWARD.
WHICH PUBLIC HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE LEAD TO TWENTY
TEN. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND PROVIDE INCOME.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO COMMENT ON ALL OF THESE
PROBLEMS. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY YOUR IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
SPOKE ABOUT OPEN CALIFORNIA
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS CONTRIBUTE
TREMENDOUSLY TO THIS GREAT STATE
AND IT'S UNACCEPTABLE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS AGES TWENTY
SIX TO FORTY NINE REMAIN
EXCLUDED FROM ACCESS AND
COVERAGE TO HEALTHCARE AND
TAKING A PROGRAM HEALTH FOR ALL
IS URGENTLY NEEDED ESPECIALLY
DURING A PANDEMIC. MY BROTHER
HAVE YET IMMIGRATED COMMITTEE GO
TO THE U. S. AT THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN AND BEGAN WORKING IN
SWEATSHOPS HE IS NOW FORTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD AND REMAINS
UNDOCUMENTED HIS WIFE WAS ALSO
UNDOCUMENTED AND SHE PASSED AWAY
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO FROM THE
KENYA ONLY THIRTY EIGHT YEARS
OLD. THANKFULLY SHE RECEIVED
MEDICARE EMERGENCY MEDICAL TO
TREAT HER CANCER UNTIL SHE DIED
BUT WHAT ABOUT MY LITTLE BROTHER
NOW WHO NEED TO TAKE CARE OF HIS
THREE CHILDREN YOU CANNOT WAIT
FOR AN EMERGENCY TO RECEIVE
MEDICARE NOW HOW WILL HE STAY
HEALTHY OR PREVENT A LIFE
THREATENING ILLNESS OR AN
INJURY. MY BROTHER NEEDS ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE NOW TO STAY
HEALTHY AND BE THERE TO RAISE
THE NEXT GENERATION OF
CALIFORNIA WORKERS AND LEADERS
IT IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO ME
THAT HE AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
RECEIVE HEALTHCARE THROUGH A
POSSIBLE LET'S MAKE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY JOBS AND EQUITABLE STATE
PLEASE INCLUDE HEALTHCARE ALL IN
THE FINAL STATE BUDGET THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I AM A FOUR
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MONTELLA AND I AM
LOOKING FOR THAT I THANK YOU
PREVIOUSLY BY MANY OF THE
MEMBERS ARE WELCOME HERE TODAY
HOW FAR IS VERY IMPORTANT AND IT
WOULD BE THAT IT WOULD BE THE-
THING TO DO. MANY PEOPLE DO NOT
RECEIVE HEALTH CARE OR ANY
HEALTH BENEFITS THE CHECK NOT TO
MANAGE- MIGRAINES AND WHAT THEY
THOUGHT CONTRIBUTED THE STATE
SUFFER GREATLY DAY TODAY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T RECEIVE THE
HEALTHCARE NECESSARY. MANY
FAMILIES ARE PUT ON THE LINE BE
TODAY AND MANY FAMILIES LOSE
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS BUT IT'S
GOING. TO BREAK UP AND THAT
MAKE. IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYONE RECEIVE HEALTH. AND TO
RECEIVE THE HELP THAT IS NEEDED
. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND PLEASE
MAKE SURE. THAT THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU HAVE A GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS YOU ON BUT
I'VE DONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ISSUE
NUMBER ONE WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF REMOVING IMMIGRATION
STATUS AS THE BARRIER KANNADA
CAL ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT
REALLY NEEDED ESPECIALLY IN A
PANDEMIC THAT HAS RAVAGED
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND THE
LOS. B. CALIFORNIA ARGUED
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXCLUDED FROM
TAKING PROGRAM AND HAVE NO OTHER
RECOURSE. SO WE URGE THE PATH TO
GET HELP FOR ALL FOR THESE
REASONS AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR WORK. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR
REGARDING MEDICARE I'LL ADD MEN
AND MEDICARE L. ADMIN RESTARTS
AND REDETERMINATION AND WE
SUPPORT THE TO FUNDING PROPOSALS
AND THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
FINDING MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY
WORKERS TO DO THIS WORK- THE
BUDGET WOULD- BE FIFTY MILLION
FOR MEDIC CAL ADMIN. AND SEVENTY
THREE MILLION FOR MEDIC CAL
ADMITTED FOR THE RESTARTED WE
DETERMINATION SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SYDNEY
HARASSED OR NOT A MOVE VEHICLE
IT'S TRONG WHICH IS A COLLECTION
OF EIGHTY INDIVISIBLE CHAPTERS
AROUND THE STATE AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF FUNDING EL FORO.
THANK YOU. THE YOU. OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR SERVERS ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
EXTENDING OUR SUPPORT TO THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS AGE
TWENTY SIX OF FORTY NINE
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ADDITIONALLY WORKING
PART OF A NUMBER OF ITEMS
INCLUDING THE DEPARTMENT'S
TELEHEALTH PROPOSAL INCLUDING.
ROTH MODALITIES YOU HOWEVER HAVE
REMAINING CONCERNS PARTICULARLY
AROUND A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH INCLUDING AN ABILITY TO
ESTABLISH PATIENT THEIR AUDIO
ONLY DOES IT. THIS ALONG WITH
PATIENT CONSENT CHANGES
LIMITATIONS ON THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS COULD HINDER ACCESS
FOR PATIENTS IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF THE STATE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE-TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
ADDITIONAL DETAILS AND
CONTINUING WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
I'M CONRAD THE TOP QUALITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BROKE OUT FROM
SACRAMENTO ADVOCATES ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
AUDIOLOGY. RECREATION COMMENTS
ON ISSUES EIGHT AND TWELVE FIRST
ON ISSUE EIGHT HELPING A CAPTIVE
IDEOLOGY STRONGLY SUPPORTS
RESCINDING THE AB NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTION BROUGHT
THE I'LL JUST. AND MANY OTHER
PROVIDER TYPES TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE.
IMPACT THE RATE REDUCTIONS THE
EXTEND BEYOND THE DIRECT
PROVIDES A CRUCIAL MEDICAL
SERVICES. NOT THE VERY
VULNERABLE PATIENTS OF THE LAND
TRAITEMENT. IN THE CASE OF THE
STATE LIKE THE IDEOLOGIST TO
IDENTIFY THAT THEY MANAGED TO
SORT OF HEARING BALANCE ANOTHER
GIRL SYSTEMS. REDUCTION OF
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT RATES HAS
RESULTED IN FAR FEWER PROVIDERS
BEING ABLE TO CORRECTLY NAVIGATE
HARD OF HEARING RESIDENTS. RATE
THE NATIONAL MEDICAL CHALLENGES
NAVIGATING THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
PANDEMIC. RESTORING THE INVERSE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WILL HELP
PLUG A SIGNIFICANT GAP IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE QUALITY AND
EQUITY GOALS. AND TEKANAN ISSUE
TWELVE. WE CARRY ABOUT LG
APPRECIATE THE AFRICAN
COLLABORATION THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WANT TO HEARING A
COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN PROGRAM.
WE KNOW THE DEPARTMENT IS
FINALISING ADDITIONAL COVERED
BILLING CODES WILL BE ESSENTIAL
TO ENSURING THE PROVIDERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
YOU CREATE THOSE EFFORTS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THEM
THROUGH. OVER THE COURSE OF THE
NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR MEXICO PLEASE
. FIND EIGHT NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRTH MEGHAN SUPERS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES OF HELLO- COMMITTEE
HEALTH CENTERS ARE PER PEARL TO
SUPPORT ISSUE NUMBER ONE
EXPANDING THAT ACCOUNT ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
AN ISSUE NUMBER TWO TELEHEALTH
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PUTTING OUT
THE POLICY PAPER SOWE CAN. KIND
OF GET AN IDEA OF WHAT THE
PROPOSAL IS HEADED AND FOR THE
WORKING GROUP'S ENGAGEMENT WE'RE
EXCITED THAT THE PROPOSAL
MAINTAINS PAYMENT PARITY FOR
TELEHEALTH INCLUDING AT PPS
UNLESS THE SITE LIMITATION FOR
FQHCS PERMANENTLY AMONG OTHER
THINGS THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
AREAS THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE ON ONCE WE
SEE THE TRAILER BILL. LANGUAGE
INCLUDING THE ESTABLISHED
PATIENT ALLOWANCES AND THE
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS
AND FINALLY ON ISSUE NUMBER NINE
THE TBL RELATED TO THE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT METHODOLOGY
FOR FQHCS WE APPRECIATE IT ALL
THE TIME AT THE STATE IS
DEDICATED TO THE STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS OVER A NUMBER
OF YEARS. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL AND
CONTINUING THE PROCESS TO
IMPLEMENT THE EIGHT PM THANK
YOU. THANK. YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAMBERS MICHELLE
GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE WISH TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
ONE THE MEDICAID EXPANSION TO
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS AGED
TWENTY SIX TO FORTY NINE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND ALSO OUR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE
SIX ADDING THE HPV VACCINE
FAMILY PACK COVERAGE. HOWEVER WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE ISSUE
10% VETTING OF THE CHILD HEALTH
AND DISABILITY PROGRAM I'D LIKE
TO FIRST THANK YOU CHAIR
APPEARED THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS ON
THIS ISSUE AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE EACH YEAR BEGIN TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS
PROVIDING PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT VGP HAS EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND
HELPING THEM NAVIGATE ENROLLMENT
INTO COVERAGE AND ACCESS TO BOTH
MEDICAL AND DENTAL SERVICES.
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
LEVERAGE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHER COUNTY AGENCIES AND HOST
COMMUNITY EVENTS TO SPREAD THE
WORD ABOUT THE H. T. P. AND P.
GP PROVIDER SO WHILE THE NUMBER
OF PROVIDERS. IN VGP MAYBE LESS
THAN THE TOTAL NUMBER MEDICAL
PROVIDERS T'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
KNOW THAT THEIR REACH AND THE
COORDINATION IT IS REALLY STRONG
AND WE CAN'T IGNORE THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE FEE FOR SERVICE
POPULATION MIGHT BE SMALL WE
CAN'T IGNORE THE NEED TO FIND
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES AND
SUPPORT THEM ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO ARE NOT ENROLLED IN COVERAGE
OR A MANAGED CARE PLAN. AND
WHILE LASTLY WHILE THE STATE DID
NOT INTEND TO REDUCE SERVICES
AND THAT HEALTH CARE PROGRAM FOR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE OR THE
LEAD PREVENTION PROGRAM STAFF
OFTEN ARE SPLIT BETWEEN THESE
PROGRAMS ANTI G. P. AND
THEREFORE THE COMFORTING OF PGP
WILL LIKELY HAVE AN ADVERSE
IMPACT TO THE PROGRAM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND WE HOPE TO ENGAGE
FURTHER WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. LEGISLATURE ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT PLEASE
. LINE ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THERE THANK YOU MY NAME
IS DAILY AGAIN I'M AN ADVOCATE
WITH CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR
NURSING HOME REFORM- I'M CALLING
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
EXPANSION OF MEDICAID TO THOSE
WHO ARE TWENTY SIX TO FORTY NINE
YEARS OF AGE REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AND WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE REDUCTION OF
PREMIUMS FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE 210050% WORKING DISABLED
PROGRAM. TWO ZERO DOLLARS THIS
REDUCTION OF PREMIUMS PAID THE
WAY FOR REFORM IN OTHER AREAS A
MEDIC CAL SUCH AS THE NEED TO
INCREASE EQUITY FOR MEDICAL
BENEFITS CHANGE WITH A SHARE OF
COSTS SAID DR WITH HAD NOTED IN
THE HEARING WE OFTEN TALK WITH
PEOPLE IN THESE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WHO HAVE TO PAY THE
MOST JUST TO GET THE CARE THEY
NEED AND WE HOPE THAT THE STATE
CONTINUES TO FOCUS ON.
ADDRESSING THE INEQUITIES IN
MCALLEN INCREASE HEALTHCARE
ACCESS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING LINDA
WAY WITH WESTERN ST ON MON
POVERTY TO COMMENT ON MULTIPLE
ISSUES PARTICULARLY WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND POLITICAL
MEDI CAL THE CARCASS OF THE
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND AGE AND
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRMAN
LEGISLATURE COULD WORK ON THIS
TRULY TRAIL BREAKING ISSUE.
PLEASED TO HEAR POTENTIAL WORK
AROUND TO PREVENT AGING OUT I
WOULD ALSO URGE IMPLEMENTATION
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. WE AWAIT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TELEHEALTH PPL AND ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO STRENGTHEN
CONSUMER CONTENT LANGUAGE AND
AVAILABILITY OF TRANSLATION
SERVICES. ESCO COUNTERS WITH SB
SIXTY FIVE WE SUPPORT THE P. C.
P. AND REQUEST FOR A BI SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND HAITIAN BY FINDING
THE MIDWIFERY WORKFORCE TRAINING
ACT AND COUNTY FETAL. INFANT
MORTALITY REVIEW COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS COOLEY FUNDING THE MEDIC
CAL DO A BENEFIT TO ENSURE
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION.
RELATED TO THE PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT WE SUPPORT THE
ELIMINATION OF NINETY SEVEN
REDUCTION. ARE PARTICULARLY AS
IT RELATES YEAH DURABLE MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT AND WE'VE HEARD OF
ISSUES ACCESS ISSUES AROUND THAT
AND APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT
FOCUS ON EQUITY PROVIDER
PAYMENTS. AND TO MEET THOSE
GOALS RECOMMENDED DEPARTMENT SET
ASIDE FUNDS TO IMPROVE THE
COLLECTION. AND RECORDING A
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. WE SUPPORT THE
ELEMENT OF PREMIUM RITUAL
PREGNANT. AND THE WORK HE WAS.
PROGRAM WITH EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE BEING COMPANION
LEGISLATION HE PREMIUMS FOURTH
MANY TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
HEALTHCARE RENT FOOD OR OTHER
BASIC NECESSITIES. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE ELIMINATION OF
COPAYMENTS BUT ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE PROPOSAL. TO ALLOW CITY
ADMINISTRATION TO UNTO YOU BY
SIMPLY REVISING THE MEDI CAL.
INSTEAD CANNELLA OTHER STATES WE
RECOMMEND CALIFORNIA ELIMINATE
COPAYMENTS COMPLETELY ESPECIALLY
AT THE DEPARTMENT AND SHARE
NOTES THERE'S NO FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE. FOR THE STATE TO KEEP
CALM PAYMENT INSTITUTE. AND A
DOCTOR WHAT NOTES THE REMAINING
PIECE ON MEDICARE HOW
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS TO THE%
VERY HIGH SHARE COST OVER HALF.
OF YEAR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES. INCOME- SO WHAT
DIRECT ADDITIONAL BY AND TO THE
LEAD INTO LEVEL WITH HE TELLS IN
AB NINETEEN HUNDRED AND FINALLY
TO PART AT THE WE- THE THAT. WE
RECOMMEND THE USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO MAINTAIN THE
BENEFICIARY FAMILY AUTOMATIC
YOU'RE BACK TO THE
DISCONTINUANCE EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE CONTINUE
. GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON INSURANCE
REMEMBERS MY NAME IS SHERRY I'M
CALLING FROM PATRICK COUNTY WELL
WHERE DO I START I THANK YOU FOR
GENERAL COUNSEL. I'M COMING UP
THREE DOLLARS. I ISSUE NUMBER
ONE ALONG WITH UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS PAY TAXES AND APPLY
FOR VISAS I HAVE NO PROBLEM
EXPANDING OUR MEDICAL RESOURCE
TO LAUNCH. OR GROW THE
VACCINATION STATUS AND THAT IS A
HUMAN RIGHT FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THAT SHOULD BE RESPECTED. I
SHOULD THEIR TEAM I'M IN FAVOR
OF ADDING MORE BUDGET TO THIS
PROPOSAL ONLY TWELVE MILLION
BUDGET FOR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. I
HAVE A SUGGESTION WELL E HAVE
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
RENOVATION ON THE CAPITAL. AND
I'M MORE EQUITY TO OUR NATIVE
CALIFORNIANS WHO REALLY CARED
ABOUT THEM YOU WOULD DO THAT.
AND WHAT IS YOUR- ES ON- UP FOR.
THE VACCINATION- I'M IN STRONG
OPPOSED I'M I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED
TO THAT SO I APPRECIATE. YOUR
TIME AND. PLEASE LISTEN TO MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
OUR- FIND ONE AND NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HILLARY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN RESPECT FOR THE
LIMITED TIME FRAME HERE TODAY IN
MY WORK WHILE BRITAIN RESPONSES
WITH THE FACT BUDGET PROPOSAL
CRITICAL TO OUR MEMBERSHIP
ENSURING FULL ANALYSIS OF
RELEVANT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
PRIOR TO COMMENTING. GENERALLY
CMA WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THAT INCREASE ACCESS TO
CARE INCLUDING THE EXPANSION OF
THE FULL SCOPE MEDIKAL ALL
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS
OF AGE OR DOCUMENTATION STATUS.
AND TO MAINTAIN AND EXPAND
ACCESS TO FAMILY PLANNING
SERVICES. POLICE EMS THE
GOVERNOR'S. THAT HELP SHORE UP
THE HEALTH CARE INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR PHYSICIANS
AND PHYSICIAN PRACTICES IN LIGHT
OF THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
CMA CONTINUES TO BE AN ADVOCATE
FOR INCREASING ACCESS TO CARE
FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
POSITION TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. PROTECTING PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX FUNDING FOR
SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER PAYMENT
EQUITY IN PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION GRANT AND
RESTORATION OF EARLIER CUTS ARE
ALL AVENUES TO DEVELOPMENT GOAL
OF IMPROVED ACCESS TO CARE. AS
ALWAYS HOWEVER THE DETAILS OF
IMPLEMENTATION MATTER WE SUPPORT
THE OVERALL DIRECTION THE
ADMINISTRATION SEEMS TO BE
TAKING ON HOW HOW. AND STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF PAYMENT
PARITY FOR TELEHEALTH REGARDLESS
OF MODALITY GOING FORWARD. BUT
WITHOUT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
REVIEW IT IS DIFFICULT TO KNOW
IF THE DETAILS ALIGN WITH CMA'S
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS GOLD AND
POLICIES FOR TELEHEALTH.
ADDITIONALLY PMI IS A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR ROLLING BACK
PREVIOUS REDUCTIONS TO PROVIDERS
SUCH AS THE EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
CAUGHT. BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE RESTORATIONS
ARE IMPLEMENTED IN THE PATHWAY
AND COVER. ALL APPROPRIATE
PROVIDER TIGHT. YEAH MY LOOK TO
TOGETHER WITH THE LEAD. AND THE
IN MINISTRY AS WE COLLECTIVELY
STRIVE IN ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT TODAY. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
GRANDSTANDS ON BEHALF OF TO
CLIENTS AMERICAN COLLEGE OBGYN A
COG IN THE CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION PERSPIRATION
NUMBER TO BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
WOULD APPRECIATE A CONTINUATION
OF PAYMENT PARITY IN TELEHEALTH
REGARDS MODALITY LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE TRAVEL LANGUAGE
PRECOGNITION OVER SIX LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO ADD THE HPV VACCINE
IS A COVERED. FAMILY BACK AND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUT THE AFTER
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ON ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT REGARDING THE
ELIMINATION BABY NINETY SEVEN
REDUCTIONS WE DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE FOR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER OTHER
PROVIDERS SPECIFICALLY DOES TO
PROVIDE PHYSICIAN SERVICES AS
PROPOSAL. MOVES FORWARD THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
ARE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KATHY SANDERLING A
DONALD FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR THAT- PHD LEFT
RESTORATION AS WELL AS THE COST
OF DOING BUSINESS INCREASE
PROVIDED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
REGARDING ITEM SIXTEEN THE
CHANGES TO HOW COUNTIES HAVE A
STARKLY IMPLEMENTED THE NINETY
DAY CURE PERIOD ARE SIGNIFICANT
THE CHANGES ALSO APPEAR LIKELY
TO BE TAKING EFFECT AT THE SAME
TIME AS COUNTIES WILL BE
PROCESSING MILLIONS OF CASES
THAT WERE KEPT ON THE CASE BUT
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC HOLD
HARMLESS. AS LAWS DURING THE
CONTINUED FEDERALLY REQUIRED
MIGRATION TO A SINGLE STATEWIDE
AUTOMATED SYSTEM WE WILL WORK
CLOSELY WITH YOUR STAFF AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO IMPLEMENT THESE CHANGES
IN A WAY THAT MINIMISES WORKLOAD
AND DESTRUCTIONS AND MAXIMIZES.
CONTINUED COVERAGE FOR OUR
CLIENTS. BURGER ITEM ONE HEALTH
FOR ALL W. D. EIGHT STRONGLY
SUPPORTS EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE
MEDICAL COVERAGE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. NOTING THAT
THE FINAL EXPANSION GROUP IS
ESTIMATED TO NUMBER SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND ENROLLEES WE
ARE TO TIMELINE THAT ALLOWS FOR
A SMOOTH IMPLEMENTATION I
COUNTIES PLANS AND THE STATE.
AND FINALLY REGARDING ITEM CAN
THE SUN SETTING AS HE H. T. P.
AND EXPANSION OF PRESUMPTIVE
ELIGIBILITY TO ADDITIONAL
MEDICAL PROVIDERS. WE NOTE THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
INTERRELATED COMPONENTS HERE
THAT MAY BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OR UNANTICIPATED
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES SOMEONE
NOTED BY OUR- PARTNERS FROM THE
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCIES.
WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO REVIEW THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND WORK
WITH THE STATE AS WELL AS OTHER
COUNTY AGENCIES AND YOUR STAFF
TO DETERMINE THAT POTENTIAL
ISSUES WE WILL PLAN TO WEIGH IN
WITH MORE DETAIL AT THAT TIME. I
DID JUST WANT TO FLAG THAT WERE
VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO
SEEING THE TRAILER BILL HERE SO
WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME LOOK
FORWARD. TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU DURING THE
SEASON. THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JEFF HAMPTON
WITH CALIFORNIA THE HEALTH PLAN.
BEGIN THE ISSUE NUMBER ONE I WE
ARE- STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND A
FULL BOOK OF MEDIC CAL- TO ALL
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH THE COMMITTEE-
WITH WRITTEN COMMENTS- TO
EXPRESS OUR VISION SUPPORT FOR
THIS PROPOSAL- AND LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATION ON THIS ISSUE MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AND
THAT'S LINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF AFRICANA WITH KATIE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS FIRST OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP
HOME VISITING PROGRAMS SUPPORT
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE FOR ALL
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THEN ON BEHALF OF CALPE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF
PROGRAMS OF ALL INCLUSIVE CARE
FOR THE ELDERLY WELCOME PART OF
MEDIC HELP BRAWL HELP YOU FOCUS
THE PARTY ADVOCATE PROPOSAL ON
THE MEDICALLY NEEDY MADE.
NOTHING AT LEVEL ONE MEDIC CAL.
EARNING TELEHEALTH. AWAIT THE-
TRAILER AND IS APPLAUDING THE
WORK THAT THE DEPARTMENT DOWN ON
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT OVER THE
LAST YEAR. WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR UNIQUE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROVIDER BASED PLAN. ADD TO
AVOID NURSING HOME CARE
STATEMENT ACCOUNT. THE INITIAL
ASSESSMENT BUT IF HE'S PROGRAM
CONDUCTED HOW ARTS CENTER THE
SALVATION EDUCATION LECTURESHIP
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO BE
CONDUCTED VIA SYNCHRONOUS VIDEO.
ESTABLISHING THE FLEXIBILITY IS
LIKELY TO ALL WHO REQUIRE
FEDERAL APPROVAL BUT WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A CASE FOR IT AND HOPE TO SEE
MORE ON A- TELE HEALTH POLICIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN IN SCOPE WITH THE FRIENDS%
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING COAL SCOPE MEDIC CAL
TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT FOR
PLEASE. AND THAT SLIDE ONE
HUNDRED AND NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING JAPANESE
STAR AND WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH
COUNCILS IN LOS ANGELES CALLING
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EXPANDING MATAGALPA ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE ADULTS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. IF LONG
OVERDUE STEP IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER AS WE CONTINUE TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE PANDEMIC. ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS DESERVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE NOW AND WE-STRONGLY SUPPORT ENSURING YOUNG
ADULTS DO NOT AGE OUT BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION. WE ALSO KNOW
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY CHANGES
WILL REQUIRE COORDINATED EFFORT.
AND WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CRITICAL ROLE THAT COMMUNITY
HEALTH NAVIGATORS PLAY IN
SUPPORTING COMMUNITIES AND
ESPECIALLY IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
IT'S- IN NAVIGATING THE OFTEN
CONFUSING ELIGIBILITY AND
ENROLLMENT FEES. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT FUNDING
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATORS TO
ENSURE ALL ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
CAN GET AND STAY ON THAT ACCOUNT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I HAD ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING TERM MEMBERS
OF FREEDOM MEDINA CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ULTIMATE HELD SERVICES
IN SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER ONE
WHICH WOULD EXPAND FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL TO ALL REGARDLESS OF
AGE VERIFICATION STATUS. ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR I WOULD LIKE TO
FULLY ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE MADE BY THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION AND
CALIPHATE. AND WE ALL LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO FUTURE GAUGE.
WITH ADMINISTRATION AND THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CHEN MEMBERS RITA MEDINA
WITH COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHEERED LACKS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
HEALTH FOR ALL AS IT'S KNOWN TO
OUR COMMUNITY WE'VE BEEN DOING
THE WORK ALONG WITH THIS
COALITION TO PUSH FOR HEALTH FOR
ALL FOR MANY YEARS WE HAVE DONE
SO MUCH WORK WITHIN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THIS GOVERNOR.
TO TACKLE THIS ONE COMMUNITY AS
TIME AND NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO CLOSING THE
GAP THE COVERAGE WE ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS FROM OTHERS TO SAY THAT
WE HOPE THEY'RE NOT DESTRUCTION
TO COVERAGE FOR YOUNG ADULTS BUT
ARE ALSO REALLY HOPING TO GET
OUR OLDER COMMUNITY MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY POST COLD IT ON BOARD
WITH HEALTH CARE AND EVEN BEFORE
THEY TURN FIFTY IT'S A CRITICAL
MOMENT WE'VE A LOT OF SUPPORT OF
THE COMMUNITY BEHIND US AND
LOOKING FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HEARING HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ITEM EIGHT AND ITEM TWELVE
BOTH OF WHICH WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO INCREASE ACCESS FOR HEARING
AID. DEVICES FOR THAT CAL
POPULATION ALSO SPECIFIC TO OUR
TO MEET- WOULD IT WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO HEED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD PROVIDE AND ONE OF
THE CONSIDERATIONS OF ELIO BY
LOOKING IN A DIFFERENT
ADDITIONAL PROVIDER GROUPS FOR
THE RESTORATION. SPECIFICALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN PROSTHETIC
ASSOCIATION THOSE PROVIDERS A
MEDICAL PROGRAM IS IT URGENT
CUSTOMIZED. DEVICES IN
PROSTHETIC DEVICES TO RESTORE OR
REPLACE FUNCTION AND ALSO
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS AND
SPECIALTY PHYSICIANS PRACTICING
IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE MINISTRATIONS
TRAIL THE LANGUAGE ON THESE
PROPOSALS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND. THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE POOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND YOU NEXT CALLER.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS PATIENT WATSON I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND ARE NOT MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND MEMBERS. HE SUPPORT
THE BEST MESSAGE UNIVERSAL
ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE COVERAGE BY
EXPANDING FULL SCOPE MEDICAL
ELIGIBILITY TO ALL INCOME
ELIGIBLE DOES REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. YES THE
PEOPLE LEAN COMMUNITIES ARE
SAFER AND HEALTHIER WITH ALL
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE. YES HE ALSO
SUPPORTS ACT THE PUBLIC SERVICES
AND THAT ANY POLICIES ADOPTED BY
B. H. YES CONTINUE TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO THIS CRITICAL SERVICE.
MOST HIGHLY CARE EXPRESSLY FOR
PATIENTS WHO FACE TRANPORTATION
GEOGRAPHIC AND OTHER BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING SERVICES. FINALLY CSP
SUPPORT EQUITY IN PRACTICE
RECOMMENDED PAYMENTS TO PROMOTE
PATIENT CENTERED MODEL OF CARE
IN PRIMARY CARE IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE GREATER HEALTH EQUITY
IMPROVED. PATIENT OUTCOMES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING THAT MATT WAS A
FROM A SEAT YOU CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF OUR SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS LIKE THAT FULLY
THROW SUPPORT BEHIND THAT HEALTH
FOR ALL- PROPOSAL IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET TO ENSURE THAT ALLOWS
DOCTORS TO HEALTH CARE
REGARDLESS INFORMATION ABOUT
ITS- JUST ONE NOTE JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- DO GIVE PROPER
LEAD TIME FOR COUNTIES IN A ROLE
MEANT- STOPS. AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN- IN WALL
AND HANDLE THE INFLUX OF NEW
ENROLLEES- ALSO ON THE
TELEPHONES- JUST WANT TO GO BACK
INTO YOU TO EXPRESS OUR DESIRE
TO ENSURE THAT. INDIVIDUALS HAVE
THE OPTION SHOULD RECEIVE CARE
IN PERSON WHEN POSSIBLE- IN AB
RECEIVED CARE AND THAT THE
PROVIDER OF THAT- TELE HEALTH
CARE WOULD BE- ESTATE BASED
PROVIDER AS WELL SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LIVE ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BENJAMIN TRAN ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ISSUE ONE HEALTH FOR ALL TO
EXPAND MEDICAL COVERAGE
REGARDLESS WHEN CATION STATUS TO
THOSE AGES TWENTY SIX TO FORTY.
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND
OR ONE OUT OF EVERY EIGHT ASIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER IMMIGRANT
IN CALIFORNIA ARE DOCUMENTED
LACKING LEGAL IMMIGRATION STATUS
DOES NOT MAKE ANYONE LESS
DESERVING OF HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
DRUG PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
MEMBERS SUFFER SOME OF THE
HIGHEST COURT WITH INFECTION AND
MORTALITY RATE. IT IS NECESSARY
TO SUCCESSFULLY COMBAT THIS
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO FOR FUTURE
HEALTH EQUITY HAVE MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
FOR THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I CLEAN
BACK NOT REGION HEDRICK STRAIGHT
ON MAIL MY CHEQUE NOT LOOK
LOCKED AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
VIRGINIA HEDRICK I'M A MEMBER OF
THE IRAQ TRIED AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM URBAN INDIAN HEALTH
WE REPRESENT TEN I JUST
CONTRACTED. AN ORGANIZATION
PROVIDING SERVICES TO MORE THAN
90% OF THE POPULATION OF
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
IN CALIFORNIA THE TWENTY TEN
CENSUS CENSUS INDICATED ONE AND
SEVEN AMERICAN INDIANS AND
ALASKA NATIVES IN THE NATION
LIVED IN CALIFORNIA THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS INDICATED THAT
MORE THAN ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
AMERICAN INDIAN ALASKAN NATIVE
CALLER STATED CALIFORNIA HOME WE
ALSO HAVE THE GREATEST
POPULATION A FAMILY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES. I WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS THATIS LONG OVERDUE THE
RESTORATION OF INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAM SO I SUPPORT ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN- AND ALSO SUPPORT A
MOVE FROM ONE TIME TO ONGOING IT
WAS A GREAT INJUSTICE TO THE
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN THIS WAS REDLINED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AND DID NOT TO
BENEFIT OUR COMMUNITY AS WE'VE
SEEN HELP THE FERRY TO GET
CONTINUE TO DECLINE. THE STATE
THE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA WERE ESTABLISHED
ORIGINALLY TO ADDRESS SEVERE
MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH OUTCOMES
INCLUDING SUDDEN INFANT DEATH
SYNDROME IN THAT INSTANCE
INCEPTION IN THE SIXTIES WE HAVE
NOT MOVED THE RATE OF- SUDDEN
INFANT DEATH SYNDROME AND
CONTINUE TO NEED AND RELIANCE
SERVICES. FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENT. THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
. NINE ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING ON
MULTIPLE ITEMS IN TERMS OF ITEM
NUMBER SIX THEY EACH FEEDBACK
SEEN- BEING COVERED TO THE
FAMILY PACKED PROGRAM- INFORMED
CONSENT FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IS A MUST WHEN
PUBLIC OFFICIALS BEGIN MAKING
MEDICAL RECOMMENDATIONS IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THEY GIVE FULL
INFORMATION ON BENEFITS AND
RISKS AS WELL. AS BEEN WIDELY
OBSERVED- THAT PAP SMEARS AND
OVERALL BETTER ATTENTION TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HAVE ALREADY
BROUGHT DOWN THE RATES OF
CERVICAL CANCER A COUPLE OF
THINGS ON THE HPV GARDASIL
VACCINE ITSELF WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS NOT EVEN COMPLETE
CLINICAL TRIAL DATA WITH
APPROPRIATE ENDPOINTS TO
INDICATE WHETHER OR NOT ANY
POTENTIAL REDUCTION IN VACCINE
STRAINS OF HPV. EQUATES TO TRUE
CANCER REDUCTION MERCK WAS
ALLOWED BY REGULATORS TO CUT THE
TRIAL SHORT AFTER FAST TRACK
APPROVAL WAS GRANTED WE KNOW
THAT DURING THE CLINICAL TRIAL
DATA WERE AGGREGATED FOR THE
GROUP GIVEN THE PLACEBO AND THE
ALUMINUM ADJUVANT ONE REPORTED
SO THAT IT LOOKED LIKE ADVERSE
EVENTS FOR THE VACCINE ARM OF
THE STUDY WERE SIMILAR TO
ADVERSE EVENTS FOR THE BUNCH
PUTS PEOPLE AND ADJUVANT GROUPS.
THIS WAS THEN REPORTED AS SAFE
AS **** BOW BY THE MEDIA AND
INDUSTRY FRONT FRONT GROUPS WHEN
FURTHER ANALYSIS WILL SHOW
SERIOUS- INJURIES AND THE ADVENT
ACTING GROUP SO IN TERMS OF A
FINAL COMMENT ABOUT- NUMBER ONE.
THIS LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR TALKED NONSTOP ABOUT
INCLUSION EQUITY AND NOT LEAVING
ANYONE OUT SUCH AS WITH
INCLUDING THE UNDOCUMENTED IN
HEALTH CARE ACCESS EVEN AS YET
ANOTHER GROUP IS BEING EXCLUDED
AND DEMONIZED THE UNVACCINATED
IT IS NOT A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
IF THE UNVACCINATED ARE EXCLUDED
AND THIS ENORMOUS IRONY AND
HYPOCRISY IS NOT LOST ON ME WE
DO NOT CONSENT. WE DO NOT AGREE. WE WILL NEVER EVER SUBMIT IT
TO THIS COVERT. NO WHAT YOU OR
WHAT YOU JUST. MY FATHER MY
CHOICE INCLUDES INTO. IT
INCLUDES PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS
IT INCLUDES VACCINES BODILY
SOVEREIGNTY IS A REAL PEOPLE ARE
WAKING UP TO THE REALITY OF
WHAT. THESE VACCINES ARE AND
WHAT THE SCOPE WHICH SHOT IS
THEY DO NOT WANT IT THAT'S THE
REASON ONLY A QUARTER OF PARENTS
HAVE OPTED TO GET THEIR CHILDREN
VACCINATED IN THIS STATE. AND
YOU'RE GONNA SEE A LOT MORE PUSH
BACK ON THIS IF YOU CONTINUE TO
PUSH THESE KINDS OF THINGS. EVEN
IF YOU JUST INCLUDE THEM IN
BUDGET. THIS IS OUR MONEY WE ARE
THE TAXPAYERS WE DECIDE IT'S NOT
UP TO YOU TO DECIDE HOW TO SPEND
OUR MONEY COOPER HOW TO PUSH
THESE LIABILITY FREE-
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS THE
PEOPLE ARE SAYING NO. IT'S THEIR
RIGHT TO SAY NO BODILY
SOVEREIGNTY MATTERS INFORMED
CONSENT MATTERS. AND IN TERMS OF
BEING LAWMAKERS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS YOU PEOPLE NEED TO
STAY IN YOUR LANE YOU'RE NOT
MEDICAL DOCTORS AND EVEN IF YOU
HAVE A MEDICAL DOCTOR THEY'RE ON
THE- YOU KNOW PANEL OR- IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT IN THE RELAY
WITH MATTER FIRST DO NO HARM
IT'S UP TO AN INDIVIDUAL TO
DECIDE WITH THEIR OWN SPECIFIC
DOCTOR WHAT THOSE MEDICAL
PRODUCTS ARE THAT THEY WANT AND
AGAIN YOU ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE AN ENORMOUS PUSH BACK ON
THIS. MY BODY MY CHOICE INCLUDES
VACCINES AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. VIEW OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LIVE ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD EVENING
ANDREA SAN MIGUEL BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
CALIFORNIA- REGARDING ISSUE CHIU
TELEHEALTH WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING IN THE
NEXT ADVISORY WORKGROUP MEETING
AND WILL ESPECIALLY BE ENGAGED
IN DISCUSSIONS ON A FEW ASPECTS
SUCH AS THE ABILITY TO ESTABLISH
PATIENTS REMOTELY AND THE
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL OCCASIONS
OFFERING AUDIO TO ALSO OFFER
VIDEO. OTHERS ARE JUST TWO
POINTS OF CONCERN FOR ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES-
AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOU ALL
THE REMAINING WORK ON NOT- ON
THE TWO ITEMS OF AN ISSUE SIX I
WANT TO EXPRESS BRIEFLY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE ADDITION
OF EACH PEAVEY VACCINES INTO
pCOVERAGE FOR FAMILY PRACTICE
WERE VERY GLAD TO SEE THAT
PROPOSAL- IN HERE AT THIS YEAR.
ACTUALLY MEDICATION ABORTION
SERVICES PROPOSAL WE APPRECIATE
THE ACTIVE AND ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH EACH THE ASK
ON THE DETAILS I WILL SHARE
THOSE NINETY THAT WHAT WE
BELIEVE- PAYMENT STRUCTURES
THROUGHOUT MEDIC HOW ART SHOULD
REFLECT SUSTAINABLE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR SERVICES
PROVIDED WALL ALLOWING
FLEXIBILITY TO PROVIDE MEDICALLY
APPROPRIATE AND PATIENT CENTERED
CARE AND FURTHER BELIEVE YOU
FROM BELOW SHOULD OUT WEIGH
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROPOSAL IS
COST NEUTRAL. BE CURRENT
PROPOSAL AS MENTIONED DURING THE
PRESENTATION REQUIRED USE OF
MODIFIER ANOTHER TRIGGER RATE
REDUCTION AND THAT THIS IS AN
ELEMENT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
CONCERN LAST- BALL THERE IS MORE
WORK TO DO THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET
PROCESS WE ARE VERY VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S WORK ON ALL OF
THESE ISSUES AND. FOR THE CHANCE
TO PROVIDE COMMENT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR MEXICO
PLEASE. FIVE A ONE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE TO SEE
CALLING WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS AND CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE FIFTEEN LOCAL
NONPROFIT MANY COMMUNIST
CAMPAIGN- WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT ISSUE ONE MEDICAID
EXPANSION TO INCOME ELIGIBLE
ADULT REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION-
DEATH AND EMCC HAS DEMONSTRATED
THE IMPORTANCE OF HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE FALL INTO THE TIME TO.
MAKE UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO HEALTH-
A REALITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. I
AND ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LYNN KERSEE I'M WITH MATERNAL
AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS AND LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS A SOCIAL
SERVICES MULTI ORGANIZATION
WE'VE DONE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
AND SOCIAL SERVICES AND
ENROLLING PEOPLE INTO PROGRAMS
FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS WE
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME OF ALL THE
ISSUES THAT LEND. OF LEXINGTON
LINE POVERTY BROUGHT UP WE
ESPECIALLY WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR HEALTHY FOR ALL IN
ADDITION IT'S NOT AGING OUT AND
WANT TO STRESS THAT- NEED
IMMIGRANTS WILL NEED- COMMITTED
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY WHO THEY TRUST TO BE
ABLE TO GET INTO PROGRAMS AND
PLANS AND- UNDERSTAND ME WISE
AND WHERE FLOORS OF MEDICAL FULL
SCOPE. THE STORIES ARE MANY THAT
WE HAVE ADULTS THAT ARE JUST
WAITING AND HANGING ON UNTIL
THEY TURN FIFTY NEXT IN MAY SO
THAT THEY CAN GET INTO FULL
SCOPE I REALLY. HOPE THAT THE
AGING OUT ASPECT OF THE DUMP
TWENTY SIX TO FORTY NINE YEAR
OLD CAN BE PUT INTO PLACE- WE
HAVE ONE YOUNG MAN WHO
ACCIDENTALLY GOT DROPPED OFF A
FULL SCOPE MEDICAL HE AGED OUT
AT TWENTY SIX AND DURING THE-
PANDEMIC THERE SHOULD BE NO
NEGATIVE ACTION LIKE THAT IT
TOOK ONE OF OUR NAVIGATORS A
VERY STRONG- WELL SPOKEN
NAVIGATOR TO TELL MEDICARE KNOW
THIS GENTLEMAN THIS YOUNG MAN.
DESERVES FULL SCOPE HE WAS
TORTURED IN MEDICARE IN IN EL
SALVADOR HE WAS BEATEN BY ICE HE
NEEDS MEDICAL COVERAGE- AND- WE
NEED THAT KIND OF EXPERIENCE
HELPING PEOPLE IN THAT KIND OF
TRUST IN THE COMMUNITY SO I
SUPPORT BOTH HEALTH FOR ALL AND-
NAVIGATION FOR A SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMPASSION IN
SEEKING THIS KIND OF COVERAGE
FOR- FOR EVERYONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT'S WHY ONE HOW
ILLEGAL. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH LARA OVERWORK I'M
HOPEFUL URICH ANGELA FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
UNITED INDIAN HEALTH SERVICES
I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE
INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM GRANT
RESTORATION ISSUE THIRTEEN. I
FIRST LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEN
RAMOS FOR HIS COMMENTS I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
TWELVE MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING
ALSO THANK YOU FOR ADDING TO
TRADITIONAL HEALERS AS AN
APPROVED SERVICE. THE SERVICE IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE NATIVE
COMMUNITY AND MEETS THE NEEDS OF
HEALTHY MIND BODY AND SPIRIT
WHICH POSITIVELY IMPACT AND
INCREASES SUCCESSFUL HEALTH CARE
INTERVENTIONS AND HEALTH
OUTCOMES. ALTHOUGH I CAN
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT MANY
MAY BE HESITANT TO APPROVED
CONTINUED FUNDING I IMPLORE YOU
TO THINK ABOUT THE FACT. THAT
THE MONEY SPENT TODAY AND
PROVIDING NEEDED SERVICES WILL
SAVE EVEN MORE MONEY IN THE
FUTURE. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
SAVE THE LIVES OF THE ORIGINAL
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. OUR PEOPLE
ARE DYING DUE TO CHRONIC
DISEASES AND OTHER HEALTH ISSUES
SUCH AS SUICIDE AND OVERDOSES.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED
WITH CONTINUED FUNDING. THIS
NEEDS TO CHANGE. PLEASE CONSIDER
PROVIDING CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
THE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COLD WARMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP I'M
SPEAKING TONIGHT IN SUPPORT OF
THE CONTINUED IMPORTANCE OF
EQUITY CENTER TO HELP WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
RESPONSIVE AND INNOVATIVE AND
INTERESTING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST MARGINALIZED.
CHILDREN THROUGH THIS BUDGET.
FIRST WITH THE COURT EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE. REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS ONE IN SIX
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA HAS AT
LEAST ONE ON DOCUMENTED PARENTS.
ON TELEHEALTH WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF INCREASING ACCESS
TO TELEHEALTH FOR FAMILIES OF
COLOR AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. YOU TOO GAUGE
STAKEHOLDERS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH SPECIAL%
HEALTH CARE NEEDS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE TRAVEL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
IT ALIGNS WITH ACCESS EFFORTS WE
PUSH THROUGH THE PHD. WITH THE
COURT THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
DECLINING PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
REVENUES TO PROMOTE WELL CHILD
CARE. THE MEDICARE REDUCTIONS TO
PREMIUMS AND CO PAYMENTS TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO ACCESS. I
NEED COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
PROGRAM AND THE RESTORATION OF
GRANT FUNDING FOR TRIBAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK
ON THESE ISSUES. WHEN YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOULINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR NUMBERS MY
NAME IS OSCAR SANDOVAL AND I AM
THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS SENIOR
MANAGER FOR THE LOOKING UP
COALITION FOR A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA ALSO KNOWN AS YOU
SEE. IT IS UNACCEPTABLE BUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS STILL
REMAIN EXCLUDED FROM HEALTH
ACCESS BECAUSE OF WHERE THEY
WERE BORN. I KNOW TOO MANY
FRIENDS THAT ARE BEING FORCED TO
SPEAK HEALTHCARE IN BORN
COUNTRIES BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
UTILIZED THE HEALTHCARE BENEFITS
THAT THEIR TAXES ARE PAYING FOR.
THIS NEEDS TO CHANGE WE ASK THAT
YOU ALL PLEASE INCLUDE HELP FOR
ALL IN THE FINAL CALIFORNIA
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. KEN MADDEN
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS ON ISSUES NUMBER ONE
AND NUMBER EIGHT RELATED AB
NINETY SEVEN CARRETERA CATS.
WHEN ISSUE NUMBER ONE EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS RUN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE PROPOSAL TO EXPAND AT A CAL
TO INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. ON ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT WE
THINK IT'S ONLY MEMBER WOULD FOR
HIS QUESTIONING COMMENTS ABOUT
THIS BEING THE RIGHT TIME TO
ELIMINATE THE AB NINETY SEVEN
CUTS FOR ALL PROVIDERS.
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS ALONG WITH
MANY OTHER PROVIDERS INCLUDING
NURSES HAVE BEEN WORKING IN A
CRITICAL ROLE TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC. IT SHOULD BE NOTED THE
AB NINETY SEVEN CATS WERE PUT IN
PLACE WHEN THE STATE BUDGET.
WITH FACING A SHORTFALL OF
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THE STATE IS NOW IN A
TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL CONDITION
AS COMPARED TO WHEN THEY AB
NINETY SEVEN CATS WERE PUT IN
PLACE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. WE ENCOURAGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
EXPANDING THE PROPOSED AB NINETY
SEVEN CUTS TO APPLY TO ALL.
PROVIDERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER. FIVE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME IS
LAURIE JOHNSON NOT A FAMILY
NURSE PRACTITIONER I VOLUNTEER
AT LOW TO CARE FREE CLINIC IN
SAN RAFAEL I AM IN SUPPORT OF
HEALTH RALPH PROPOSAL YOU
GOVERNMENTS AND BUDGET. HAD
CARED FOR HUNDREDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED PATIENTS OVER THE
TWENTY YEARS I'VE VOLUNTEERED
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE EVERYTHING A PATIENT
NEEDS OR CAN AFFORD THEREFORE WE
OUGHT TO SEND THEM TO THE LOCAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT FOR CARE.
HERE GRANTED EMERGENCY MEDICARE
TO GET SERVICES THAT CAUCUS
STATE OF FORTUNE WHEREAS IF
IMMIGRANTS WERE ALLOWED TO
ACCESS ACCESS TO REGULAR
MEDICAL. MEDICARE THEY COULD
RECEIVE NEEDED CARE AND LOCAL
CLINIC MEDICARE WILL BENEFIT THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA REGULAR PREVENTED
RARE REGULAR PREVENTATIVE CARE
TO KEEP THEM HEALTHIER AND AVOID
UNNECESSARY VERY COSTLY
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT VISITS AND
HOSPITALIZATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
FIVE ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING AND THANK
YOU THIS IS GABRIELLE LESSARD ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
IMMIGRATION LAW CENTER- SPEAKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AND BEING
IMMIGRATION BASED EXCLUSIONS
FROM MEDIC CAL FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THANK YOU
LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS EDDIE
WHO WITH ASIAN RESOURCES THANK
IN SACRAMENTO IN LOS ANGELES.
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
NUMBER ONE MEDICAID EXPANSIONS
TO INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS TWENTY
SIX TO FORTY NINE YEARS OF AGE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS- THERE'S A LOT OF DIAPERS
CITY AMONG DOCUMENTED. AND ASIAN
AMERICANS NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS MAKE UP ABOUT
15% OF THE STATE AND DOCUMENTED
POPULATION AND EXPANDING
MEDICAID HELD TO ALL ELIGIBLE
ADULTS WEEK OUT REGARDLESS OF.
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS A PRIORITY
FOR ALL OUR EIGHT INCH BLACK
COMMUNITY SO PLEASE INCLUDE
HEALTHCARE ON THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK. YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE COMMENT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
GABBY FIVE EXAMPLE TO JAM ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IMMIGRANT POPULATION
COLLABORATIVE SAID. I'M ON OUR
RADAR CAN I DON'T MOM ONE WE'RE
EXPANDING FONG FOR ALL THE OUR-
OF. THEY CAP QUALIFY FOR A FULL
CALLED ME BY OF THE FOR THAT'S
ANOTHER TO WORK WITH ANYTHING
FAMILIES IN THIS ABOUT WHERE.
MANY FARMWORKERS ON THERE AS-
DURING THAT TIME THAT AND
GABBANA'S OF ACCESS TO. SERVICES
WE JUST THAT ACCOUNT. MORE THAN
TO HAVE A- THE MEDICAL. AND I
REALLY HAVE. ALL THAT SHE
REMEMBERS FOR THANK THE TIME
LISTEN TO OUR PUBLIC COMMENTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THERE
WAS THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK BURN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S TO EXPAND
MEDICAID HEALTH TO ALL
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES TO MOVE THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE EARLIER. IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THIS NEW-
EXTENSION IS SUCCESSFUL THE
STATEMENT ALSO SET ASIDE FUNDS
FOR MEDICAL HEALTH NAVIGATOR.
I'M WHO ARE CAPABLE OF PROVIDING
COMMUNITY DRIVEN CULTURALLY
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE
OUTREACH AS WELL AS MOMENT
RETENTION AND UTILIZATION URBAN
. IT'S IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS YOU
GOT OUT OF REACH FOR VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ESPECIALLY KEEPING
IN MIND THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE WELCOMING A
WHOLE NEW COMMUNITY. OF
INDIVIDUALS INTO OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. THE OTHER THING THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MENTION- THAT WAS
NOT PREVIOUSLY TALKED ABOUT IN
THIS- COMMITTEE HEARING. THIS
THE NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT THEIR-
PRIORITY FUNDS THAT ARE SET
ASIDE SPECIFICALLY FOR HEALTH
FOR ALL MARKETING OUTREACH
CONFORMABLY TO EARLY BUDGET
ACTION AS WE'RE QUICKLY
APPROACHING THE MAY
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND THERE
REMAINS A HUGE GAP WITH
TARGETED. CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE
AND OF COURSE WE APPROPRIATE
OUTREACH. WITH REGARDS TO THE
PROPOSALS ON TELEHEALTH AS A
MEMBER OF THE U. S. AND ALLIED
HEALTH THE COLDER WORKGROUP
REPENT THE PORT THE H. B. S. I
WILL HELP POLICY RECOMMENDATION.
AND WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS MOVING
FORWARD- WITH WAYS TO CONTINUE
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTH
BEYOND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY AND REALLY INCLUDING
VIDEO AND AUDIO ONLY SERVICES.
AS WELL AS ESTABLISHING NEW
PATIENT FOR TELEHEALTH URBAN.
ACCORDING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO UNIQUE PROPOSAL
EXPAND. AND WE REALLY HOPE TO.
INCREASE ACCESS TO HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED GROUPS. LASTLY I'D LIKE
TO APPLY YOU TO THE ASPEN KIND
AND MEDICAL PAYMENTS TO- TO
ACHIEVEMENT OF CONCRETE YEAR
OVER YEAR EQUITY COLD. AND IT'S
A CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN
IMPROVING HEALTH CARE QUALITY
AND UNPRECEDENTED. HOWEVER WE
ALSO URGE DH YES ASIDE ADEQUATE
FUNDS TO IMPROVE THE COLLECTION
OF REPORTING FOR SELF. FOR SELF
REPORTED GRANULAR DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA AND HEALTH RELATED SOCIAL
NEEDS DATA THAT IS NEEDED BY
MEDICO THERE IS NEEDED FROM
MEDICAL PLANS AND PROVIDERS IF
WE REALLY HOPE I CAN CONFIDE THE
THERAPIES. AND ADDRESS
INTERVENTION WOULD DRAFT. IN THE
SO MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF MAIN CHAIR AND
MEMBER MY NAME WITH THE PLO
BATTLE I AM A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH A LOT OF WHEN I
FOUNDATION IN KERN COUNTY I AM
HERE TO REQUEST AN SUPPORT HELP
FOR ALL. ON THE STATE BUDGET I
WORK WITH FAMILIES MULTI
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS WHO
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO WAIT TO BE
SEEN BY A DOCTOR UNTIL THEY ARE
RUSHED TO THE HOSPITAL. THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS
PREVENTIVE CARE SERVICES TO LIVE
AND STAY HEALTHY. PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE IS A HUMAN RIGHT YOU
THINK DENTAL COVERAGE TO
UNDOCUMENTED WE ALREADY KNOW.
PEOPLE UNDER TWENTY SIX AND
PEOPLE OVER FIFTY ARE COVERED
BUT WE NEED EVERYONE. TO BE
COVERED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CAROLYN BIEL HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF TELADOC HEALTH WHICH
IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S LEADING
PROVIDER OF VIRTUAL CARE- WE ARE
ONE OF THE MINOR COMMENTS ARE-
THOMAS BUT INSPECTED ITEM TWO
AND THE TELEHEALTH POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS. WITH THE
CERTAINLY CONCERNED WITH THEM
THE FACT THAT TELEHEALTH IS ONE
THE LARGEST BRIDGES TO PROVIDING
ACCESS TO PROVIDING GREATER
ACCESS DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AND THE CONCERN THAT
THERE'S SOME POTENTIAL- JUNE
DOMINATE SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND AVAILABILITY
FOR FOLKS WHO NEED ACCESS- IN
THE RULEMAKING WILL CONTINUE TO
BE ENGAGED IN THE BILL MAKING IT
DCHS BUT THINK THAT THE-
LEGISLATURE SHOULD SPECIFICALLY-
TAKE NOTE OF THE COMMENTS BY THE
LA- TOPICS WHICH I'M
SPECIFICALLY SAID TO CONSIDER
HOW WITH THIS PROPOSAL. I'M
GOING TO PROHIBIT YOU STATUS OF
NEW PATIENTS HEALTH RECORD
IMPACT ON ACCESS. TO CARE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
OPERATOR NEXT. THANK YOU AND
THAT COMES TO MIND ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SHE GOOD EVENING- THANK
YOU OUR SYSTEM WHITE HIM ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND I AM HERE TO-
SPEAK ON ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
WITH REGARD TO MEDICAL PREMIUMS
AND COPAYS. DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA IS EXCITED TO BE A
PART OF AN EFFORT TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO MEDICARE ALL AND TO
SERVICES WHICH HELP KEEP PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND THEIR
HOME. AND COMMUNITIES BY WAY OF
REDUCING SHARE COSTS. WHICH AND
DECADES ARE DECADES OLD
REQUIREMENT THAT PEOPLE
IMPOVERISH THEMSELVES IN ORDER
TO GET THE CARE THEY NEED- IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND THAT COMES BY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING- I'M KAREN WATER
BACK REPRESENTING VENICE FAMILY
CLINIC OR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SERVING OVER FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
PATIENTS. I'D LIKE TO COMMENT ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT EXPANSION
OF MEDICARE TO COVERALL THE
QUALIFY REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. AND
IMPORTANTLY ALONG WITH EXPANSION
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE INCLUSION OF NAVIGATORS TO
HELP THE COMMUNITY ROLL. INTO
THE NEW BENEFITS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. LINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MR KENT SAID COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NANCY
CAPACITY ONLINE CALLING AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO SHARE THE CALIFORNIA
I'D LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR
COMPLEX FOR ISSUE ONE WHICH
EXPANDS MEDICARE COVERAGE TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE DON'T REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS. WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A CRICKETER PORTER AND
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
HEALTHCARE ESPECIALLY HAVING
SUPPORTED LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ITEM THAT EXPANDED MEDICAID TO
ADULTS OVER FIFTY YEARS OF AGE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. WE ARE ENCOURAGED TO
KEEP THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TAKE
ANOTHER LARGE STEP TOWARD
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE ENSURING MORE
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE THIS ALLOWS FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE PREVENTIVE
CARE AND EARLY TREATMENT BEFORE
CONDITIONS BECOME SERIOUS AND
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO LEAD TO
COSTLY LONG TERM HEALTH ISSUES.
EXPANDING MEDICARE COVERAGE IN
THIS REGARD IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO THERE'S ONE FACT AND
PROMOTING HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THAT'S WHAT THE OF OUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS THEY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE MOVE THIS
IMPORTANT. MEASURE FOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. MEXICO
PLEASE. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK YOU
OPERATOR I WILL TAKE THAT AS THE
CONCLUSION OF PUBLIC COMMENT HI
WILL TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK ALL
OF THE STAFF WHO WORKED HARD AND
DILIGENTLY TO PREPARE THE AGENDA
AND- ALLOW US TO HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION TODAY
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS AND THE ADMINISTRATION
PER. PARTICIPATING FOR. THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
FOR HELPING US TO KEEP CLEAN FOR
THE SERGEANTS FOR KEEPING US
SAFE AND FOR THAT TACK FOR
ALLOWING US TO BROADCAST. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE PUBLIC
FOR PARTICIPATING IN THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING AND- WITH THAT TODAY WE
ARE ADJOURNED. HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.